uh start uh the committee meeting here
we have a number of meetings which are
please over there the the great
discussions got to stop
we got to get going here
the the reason why well it's right at
nine o'clock when our hearings start but
I do have some announcements which have
to be made here one of which I'm getting
committee reports
that are coming in in the name of
somebody that did not make the motion
that's going to stop
so if if if somebody made a motion and
that's where we go then anybody's
welcome to work with that individual but
the report Still Remains in the name of
the person that makes the motion you
can't substitute something like that in
a committee report that's been
identified by our uh support Personnel
they're looking at the minutes of the
report that comes from representative
cordelli here and then checking out the
blurb and they don't match up so it's
okay to have support for example if
represent cordelli makes a motion ought
to pass and he doesn't want to write
that blurb he could ask you know
represent luno to write that report
however it still comes in underneath
representative cordelli's name in the
blur
well no no no I'm told but at that point
in time by the the ranking person here
who's going who's going to the report's
going to be written that's I have no
problems with that nor does anybody
upstairs but we're seeing the some of
the majority reports coming in very very
different than what we have on the floor
so Rick while we're talking about
reports because we've obviously all been
been through some of these
um the uh and I know there's a um
there's there's a standard template for
that now yes the template I think has
some confusion when it comes to 1010
without recommendation yeah absolutely
definitely we're working on that yeah
yeah and um and so the reports that we
that my reports this interview I think
were pretty clear I didn't use the
template but uh but they were they were
10 10 no recommendations and and rather
than using terms like majority or
Minority Report in the 1010 it's a
report in support of ought to pass or in
support of itl it's not majority I'm
sure that's going to be brought up in
the ranking leadership meeting that they
have today at nine o'clock and in uh my
leadership is going to be at 9 15. that
is on the docket because that is I've
been using the template but I've been
putting on the top of a 1010 yeah and
then modifying the templates but it'd be
nice if it's just a box which you can do
right thanks Rick the uh the other point
that I want to make is that
um I need to have all the committee
foreign
I need to have all the committee reports
for
February 1 February 3 and February 6.
hand it to me by the close to shop today
by the close of school today you have to
get those things into me
uh it's simply because that by the Bell
if it doesn't come in by the by the Bell
time
I will write the report or there will be
no report of the position
uh so it's absolutely imperative that we
are really getting slammed with
committees that have uh a lot of reports
coming in now the sessions are now going
to come in very loaded and our
administrative support staff is
basically on tilt right now and we want
to really support them also if you're
doing a report
please do it either on that template or
Microsoft Word
so that the document can be transmitted
to those Folks up the hallway here and
they don't have to input everything over
it again I'm having to do that at night
myself on some of these reports and and
inputting my itself and it keeps me up
to 11 30 12 o'clock every one of these
nights that's stopping if if it comes in
so I can't can't uh transmit it the way
it's not going to get transmitted
yes
I'm not saying on that template I said
that's the template that's the template
it'd be nice if you leave it on the
template because when you come
you you just save it as on your computer
just send it off to to myself with an
attachment and that's it so you never
have to mess your template up in case
you want to use it again
so you have your template on your
computer
you
okay we'll we'll we'll we'll we'll we'll
work on that for you
so I want to go through some of the
reports that let's just go back and
check I'm missing uh a report for 2-1
Minority Report for three it's February
1 367. I I that I think that's coming in
um on two three February 3 missing The
Minority Report for 6 26.
on two three
um missing The Minority Report for three
uh going on down here 429 we're working
that out that's that's uh an issue which
we had
um dealing with the breakfast and lunch
program that represent Allison you were
involved with that and how you write
these things we're working on that
um going down to 521 which is on 2 2 6
February 6. that's done
um
um I I need that from uh both both uh
parties
uh if it's done please you know forgive
my saying that but I I couldn't find it
uh 540 that's been done
um
601 the the report will be named The
Minority Report will be named and the
person who made the blurb not the person
that you know is doing that so that has
to come from the person that made the
report or made the motion
um
yeah um yes there was yes yes there I'm
not going to because we have a hearing
coming up uh four six four I need them
both for 464 that was made on February
6th yesterday
um on 466 I need that
on
um 501 I have that that's in
on 102
I I need that and um
and uh 435 I I don't believe that that
may have been sent to me I heard maybe
this morning but I haven't gotten that
so please if you made these make sure
you have sent them and please send them
in either word doc or in the template
format
other notice is we will be having in on
February 13th I haven't got the schedule
sent in yet but at least four of the
bills that our early bills will be
coming up on that date that would be 272
and I'll get the subcommittees together
I'm meeting with the ranking member here
at noon time and we're going to talk
about some of the subcommittee work and
we have one two three four five areas
where we have to do some work on
so that's it we need to get going with
our hearing I got to be out of here at 9
15. I see that reps and Miles already
of what you just went over because I was
we have
272 that's increasing public school
funding per pupil
uh for 492 that's the one that we
already have all the material that's
your bill represent Tanner that's going
to be held that's the statute books you
know that we've asked for
um
529 that's a fiscal capacity disparity
Aid if in fact we we have a small get
together at noon time today the four of
us and and uh we'll work on that we'll
see whether that goes 213 or 215.
um and then we have
on 210 we will be doing the 577 that's
the state aid for special education
that's this week that's that but also on
213 we're going to be going to the
charter school report HB 71 remember
that was the report where they have to
report uh is it quarterly or three times
a year charter schools and we have that
question there
we should be able to hassle that out and
get that one done but there's others of
course which will be coming up uh so
that concludes that and what I'd like to
do now is get into the hearing today
which is scheduled for nine o'clock uh
HB 382 authorizing local school boards
to give students release time for
participation in religious instruction
in an elective course for the purpose of
satisfying curriculum requirements do we
oh
you're no stronger is the sponsor here
is the co-sponsor here
we still have to okay we'll have to
dispose of it because it is a bill
regardless do you want me to just
introduce it Tom
yes but would you introduce that bill
then we'll close it down
welcome representative cordelli uh thank
you Mr chairman and uh honorable
colleagues uh for the record uh Glenn
cordelli representing something Borough
Wolfeboro and Ossipee and the Beautiful
Lakes Region and I would like to
introduce House Bill 382 authorizing
local school boards to give students
release time for participation in
religious instruction in an elective
course for the purpose of satisfying
thank you very much
so I will I will ask one other point is
there any member of the public that came
here for this particular bill
that will not be here for the bill that
we have later on today which is very
similar
welcome
two
good morning thank you chair
um
my name is Claudine Burnham
representative from Stratford County
District 2.
um I I support this bill I think that um
gives opportunity to
students who may be involved in
missionary work or Ministries that May
coincide within time frame of school
so
um
so I just wanted to speak on that behalf
I think it's a great idea to give that
opportunity to the students that for
programs that are not available within
the school
thank you for taking my question can you
give um just so we get a better idea and
an example a specific example of where
well I was involved with youth groups in
my church for many many years and it
limits to students being able to support
local
um
soup kitchens or
working within the community within
those time frames that are available
so it limits students to maybe weekends
or evenings which is difficult as well
because many resources and Ministries
aren't available at that time and also
for educational purposes there could be
a Bible study or something that children
can attend and not be available to do
that during school hours such as
students who are homeschooled or another
School charter schools are maybe a
little more flexible to do that so this
just gives that availability to the
public school students as well thank you
very much thank you very much you're
welcome thank you representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
inquire because I I know some schools
have different policies regarding
relative courses and uh whatnot
um do you know if president law would
actually prohibit
schools from giving uh credit for uh for
any sort of outside religious
instruction
I don't know of the law that would
prohibit that
um but I don't know of any law that
accepts it either so okay thank you
representative Tanner
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
so the what you're asking for is not a
course
that talks about religion and Compares
religions you're talking about basic
instruction Catechism classes that train
people to be
um
their particular religion whether it's
Seventh-day Adventist or whatever so
um I can't speak on our behalf on all
religions but
um if there are courses sometimes
there's online courses that are just
strictly during
school hours that may not be available
to the students that are in public
school so it allows them to have that
time set aside to take those classes
regardless of which religion it is
follow-up yes I think maybe you
misunderstood my question my question
was is this just a general core course
on world religions uh that you're
talking about or comparative course
versus religious instruction where the
instruction is specific to a religion
like Seventh-day Adventist or Buddhist
or whatever
um that the the student takes that
actually trains them in that the
catechism the ideology of that religion
which are you talking about
one or the other or
I think this bill kind of keeps it
General it's not real specific as far as
which
course or religion or practice I think
it's just open to
um for the faith-based program or
instruction
thank you further questions uh yes
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I actually have two
um so one is it sounds like
some of this would be students leaving
their school campus to
do something affiliated with their
religion off the premises
so what are they missing when they leave
school it seems to me the school day is
already rather full
and then I do have another question if I
may
I'm not sure what you mean what are they
missing I mean I don't every student has
their own schedule within school
um
so
let me think how to put this differently
you can't really do two things at once
so if you're at the soup kitchen you're
not in something at school right how do
compensate for missing the class that
they're yes
um that would be something I think on a
based uh individual base
basis as to what they would have to make
up for
I don't see that I I don't really know
um the sponsors purpose but I did
support this because I know of students
that have wanted to be involved in
certain instruction it may not be
ongoing it may be
it may be just a sporadic thing it might
be something based on requirements for
their faith to receive certain
sacraments and it's difficult for them
to do that during school time hours
that's my understanding I don't know the
specifics of
um people's schedules that's certain
certainly something that would be
brought to the school board to make that
decision as to how they would have to
make up for even in their teachers
so sorry I can't be a little more
specific but every student's different
and and their faith may be different so
it's not specific to one religion did
you have follow-up
um it's a different question and I
actually think probably it's for the
sponsor I'm wondering where the language
in the
sort of preamble to the actual bill
but I felt compelled to speak regardless
because I do think it's it's good for
the students representative Allison oh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question and this may be another one
of those questions that should go to the
sponsor uh but it it in lines 25 and 26.
and on that I'm sorry 22 and 23 24 of
the of the actual bill it talks about an
intellectual
click
that is imposing Upon Our Nation modest
fads and fallacies do you have any idea
what the fads and fallacies are that are
referred to in this bill I do not thank
you
any further questions representative
Damon yes
just one more I was
wanting to clarify in line 17 and 18 in
Roman numeral 5 on the first page it
reads the United States Constitution the
state law allows local school districts
to offer religious release time
education for the benefit of public
school students
so I
interpret that to say we already have
this somewhere it doesn't specify
what RSA or where they're getting that
from but if that's so it seems like it
perhaps it's just to help educate the
school board to know that it's there I
don't know
I I have found that many of our local
school board members don't understand
some of the Privileges that are offered
for the questions see none thank you
very much thank you for being here
this is not the bill
no you should just representative
thank you chairman good morning members
of the community bear Christina from the
New Hampshire School Board Association
um were opposed to the bill and not
because of the content by any means um
actually I think it's a very well
crafted bill in that it's permissive
um and then you know it puts a lot of
the burden um on the parents if they
wanted to enact this without putting the
burden on the school district to help
the student fulfill that our objection
um you know opposition relates to your
question representative Belcher about is
there anything already in law that would
allow school to search to do this uh we
would say yes our high schools have very
uh vigorous Extended Learning
opportunity programs where a student can
work with sort of a third party either a
company or an individual there's no
reason it couldn't be a church or or
religious organization where the student
can sort of do that work outside of the
quote-unquote traditional class time I
hope that's not me
good
um where the student you know can can do
some work outside of um outside of the
uh uh the uh the traditional classroom
sometimes during school hours sometimes
not during school hours so there's no
reason that a program like this couldn't
be turned into an Extended Learning
opportunity
um we have the learn everywhere program
um that was initiated by the State Board
of Education two or three years ago at
this point I suppose
um there's nothing in the law that would
prohibit a religious entity or religious
organization from being alone everywhere
entity where the student could then get
some level of credit for participation
with that organization or that course or
that group or or whatever it might be
um I guess another uh objection nhsba
would have is why just the religious
instruction then why are we doing just a
single carve out for religious
instruction instead of if a kid wanted
to join any other group or a sports team
or a band or a community theater or
anything anything else along those lines
and last is one of nhsba's frustrations
with some of these bills we keep talking
about Credit Credit Credit Credit
yes school districts are still offering
credit but with the significant changes
that are coming through the Department
of Education and the State Board of
Education relative to the review of the
minimum standards for public education
department of education rule 306 where
we're shifting more back towards
competency language and putting a lot of
Competency language in those particular
bills credit is becoming
um I don't want to say passe but um more
and more we're using competencies and
meeting competencies in order to earn
credit so again those are our basic
oppositions we think that school
districts and and and students could
already engage in something like this
through existing programs whether or not
that was Extended Learning opportunities
or learn everywhere programs or School
District might just be able to say sure
you need to leave it at two o'clock on
Fridays to go to a Bible study course
absolutely we can accommodate that and
you know put some sort of academic um uh
parameters around it so the child could
earn credit and meet certain
competencies so those are nhsba's um
concerns with the bill I'm happy to
happy to answer any questions
uh represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
thank you for that that was very good
information thank you um and you were
able to answer my question which is a
very important question that there's
nothing currently prohibiting it there
is a necessary follow-up to that
question which is
is there anything that would allow as a
current law schools to prohibit a
student from
utilizing the faith-based outside
education for as described in the bill a
um extra career I'm not extracurricular
but um non-essential credit sure thank
you for the question representative I
just want to be clear is there anything
in law that would prohibit a student
from engaging in something like this is
that no do I have a backwards sort of is
there anything that would allow for a
refusal on the part of a school of the
school
um so the Extended Learning
opportunities that high schools offer
there's usually some level of review by
either the high school principal or some
high schools will have a an Extended
Learning opportunity coordinator
um I would certainly hope that the if it
were to be objected to by the school
district I would certainly hope that it
would not be based on their religious
grounds because I think they'll be
clearly discriminatory there may be
um a a disallowance based on
um more I'd say sort of academic
components if you will
um so with the Extended Learning
opportunity programs yes there's some
level of oversight and usually it has to
be initially authorized or agreed to by
somebody in the school district the
guidance counselor the El coordinator
the high school principal so that would
be the that would be the perhaps one
barrier thank you
representative Woodcock thank you
chairman Cordell good afternoon good
morning good morning good to see you uh
the question uh follow-up uh
this bill as I read it doesn't uh
differentiate between grammar school
elementary school or high school right
um so I I didn't we're talking about
current times and release times which
which I find is a concerning but the
other the question I had for if you make
this applicable and intent to high
school with the local school board then
be responsible to approve it as an
elective course so it'd be allowable in
um if it was done through the ELO
program
uh yes there's I'm reading the language
it's I'm on page two line eight and the
locals the local Board of Education the
local school board May Implement a
policy to allow that
um and then you know there's a handful
of criteria about written consent
um you know things are things of that
nature so I mean to that extent it would
be if the as I read this if the bill
were to pass the State Board of
Education would adopt rules the local
school board and its own decision could
then Implement those rules adopt a
policy to allow for this
um and there was there a second part to
your question represented
I was telling the crap can I just follow
up yesterday
um bro I I disagree with yours I
disagree with your reading on line eight
because I I'm reading that as the school
board can uh approve the time release
and I'll see that as uh I don't mean to
disagree to be disagreeable uh but the
time release versus the credit part
um so that's just my thinking as I read
it yeah thank you for the question
representative I read it and the you
know maybe maybe we're actually have to
clarify with the speaker or this but I'm
not sorry the speaker the um the sponsor
of the bill or when we've got a similar
Bill coming back later this afternoon
okay I was reading this as meaning the
State Board would adopt rules but it was
still left to the and and each local
Board of Education May Implement a
policy for a student to attend release
for a student to attend release time
release but I'm looking at that as this
local school board would have their own
local decision of whether or not they
implemented those those doe rules all
right thank you that's my reading of it
okay um thank you Mr chair
for the questions given that we have
another bill like this this afternoon
um we have two more uh people who would
like to uh speak on this one and the
first is a state representative Perez
foreign
District 43 in Milford I'm here to speak
in a position of this bill is someone
who
growing up when I was a little girl I
went to a Catholic private school
I believe these kind of bills is not
helping the students I wish we can
utilize the time not to push our own
religion beliefs with students which
should be pushing for students to learn
the same way that I learned even when I
went to a Catholic School by my time it
wasn't spent on learning religion it was
explained to learn how to cook
Hadid so
how to manage my money
us pushing religion
is not helping it the people to be
better humans
enough is enough I see this happening
everywhere
and I see
members of
the school committee's commission this
agenda
we need to teach our kids to be a better
humans and be better from their soul for
the future
we can't keep pushing religion
just because it's our beliefs
please book note on to this build and
the other one is coming later on today
we don't need this we don't need them
all religion if you want to put you on
religion during your own time by getting
credits for learning religion is that
not what the kids need for the better
future thank you
thank you any questions
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair just just wanted to
clarify so on page two line ten it talks
about parent or Guardian giving written
consent this appears to be something
that would be parent directed more so
than than directed by us or a school
board is so is that is that the uh
the opposition here is it to the school
board directing uh religious
experience for the children or parents
oh the parents want to
are students might as well teach them
how to be a better human or how to
handle the future for themselves like I
say how to cook
how to clean and maybe learn something
maybe a trade
so they can be a better humans and they
can have a better future that's what my
point is
thank you
um representative cascaden
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony representative
I guess I would want your opinion I mean
I went to Catholic school as well
in your opinion who's responsible to
teach children their faith a parent or a
school
yes
thank you for taking my question
um you keep using the phrase pushing
religion I'm just wondering how is
allowing students to have release time
for participating in religious
instruction pushing religion
like I say at parents
wants to do their own religion thing
that's one thing but with this kind of
build
it's as stolen the school that has to
teach religion this is not what we need
we need kids to learn trades we need
kids to learn how to manage their future
how to be better for themselves
growing up like I say
me learning
how to cook how to manage my money
both of the things that brought me a
better future yes it's an immigrant it
was hard
as someone who didn't know the language
when I was 15 years old and learned in
English as a second language it wasn't
easy
but trust me the things that I learned
growing up it helped me to be a better
very human and better person
thank you
um I think uh thank you for your
testimony and we have one more person as
Claudine
I guess that will end our
time
and our Hearing in on 382 and next
um we're almost on schedule for
um we have one card so far and that is
from the uh Prime
from uh representative Joshua Kella and
uh
foreign
a co-sponsor I can speak to first if you
want
is it representative Phillips yeah why
don't you come up and
okay all right thank you yeah thank you
he's in another committee presenting a
bill at 9 30 somewhere else so that's
why we're kind of okay juggling
representative Phillips thank you for
I'm sorry
good morning so this bill uh essentially
uh removes a requirement did you just
introduce yourself to where you're from
and all sorry I'm a little flustered I
ran up the hill with my toddler on my
back um so I'm Emily Phillips
rockingham7 and I'm a sponsor of this
film
um this bill removes a requirement in
public school education laws that people
attend the school in the district of
their residence
change of school or assignment are to be
granted without discrimination based on
the resident of the student I have three
children currently we are homeschooling
two of them I was formerly on the school
board in my town for three years that
ended in 2022 and now I here I am at the
state house but sometimes
um I think that we need to refocus
public education on the student centered
aspect and um I think that we should put
power back into the parents and the
students to do what's best for
individual students and not worry about
the systems in general so this is
essentially removes the language you can
see in the Bill of to attend the public
school of assignment to a public school
so that would allow the parent to
request a change of school assignment
based on the child's individual needs
um there would be no additional tuition
charged to the parent or legal guardian
if they should request it it would be
um either a negotiation between the two
districts or um it's a little bit
there's some language in there that you
can read into but um I think that this
helps Public Schools this is not a
um
this is not a controversial bill as far
as um you know funding private schools
or home school and things like that it's
just essentially removing the language
of the public school that you were
assigned to to a public school in the
state
and I'm open to uh obviously questions
and thank you very much uh
representative thank you and good
morning so my question is relating to
special education which there is a large
special needs population in my town in
the surrounding area and currently under
the existing laws the town of residency
would be liable to provide services or
payment for services and special
education how would this change that is
my question it doesn't change it so I
read it the same way that it says it be
it that the child attends the school
would be responsible like meaning that
the services will be provided there but
I believe that it is still the
responsibility of the sending School
okay thank you yes
for the questions representative Myler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here
the question that I have for you is that
many school districts have a certain set
number
of students that they
can accommodate in a particular School
let's say you know the the sampling
let's say fourth grade they only have
room for 30 kids let's say how would
that deal with an issue if you for
example wanted to have your child go to
that school but they have a limit
limited number of spaces available well
I think like in response to like a
budgeting aspect because that's that's
the opposition I hear is that they
budget for so many kids
um you know a year in advance a year and
a half in advance I think that the
economies of scale plays a plays a role
in here so you have 18 kids in a
classroom say in a fourth grade and you
add in three more kids there's not going
to be that much more of a cost
resource-wise to educate those three
more children in one District or if you
lose a few through children leaving and
going to a different school so I think
that the budgeting process allows you to
move money around to accommodate changes
within a district now so I think that
that would apply here there would be a
little bit of a you know
um a transition point I should say
um for every District they have to
balance their budget regardless as the
year progresses so I don't see it being
thank you chairman good morning I um in
my review of this I need to be honest my
quick review of this
um I didn't see anything about
transportation
is it in here did I miss it it's a
parent's responsibility okay so just
like if you were to choose like a
charter school now you'd be responsible
to I'm at the public school and can you
tell me where that is here from the bill
transportation
yes thank you
um and thank you uh earlier on it was it
was there's no additional cost to the
student
in school districts
um could this is because the audit could
be out of District by looking at it
under the um in school districts for
instance would have a a significantly
higher uh student support from The Local
District in the local town uh say Talent
expense 35 40 000 a year on their
student and you're coming from town y
that spends twelve thousand dollars a
year so that receiving town you have to
make up the additional Gap
for your youngster
those local taxpayers for 30 40 000 per
diem
you're talking about for like a typical
child for the cost of
time if I wasn't
a school system that's only supporting
my youngsters say at twelve thousand
dollars a year in a town down the road
which I could transport them to on the
way to work spending forty thousand
dollars a year
um in the sort of tax period in that
town of forty thousand dollars who's
going to pick up the difference of
thirty thousand because there's no cost
so the way I read it is that there's a
negotiation process between like the
superintendent of the sending school to
the next one but there should be no cost
additionally to the parent or Guardian
so I think that
um like I said economies of scale the
pupil cost per pupil cost at the
receiving school will change based on
new enrollment
well let me take it I'm in Conway and I
work in Northampton and I want to put my
youngster in Rye
and it's a 30 000 difference and the
superintendent Right Said No we're going
to take off an extra 30 000 expense
because you don't you know you don't
like your school uh for whatever reason
um where's that money get picked is it
the right taxpay have to pay for that so
I don't believe that receiving a child
then will cost that school thirty
thousand dollars I think that's what the
per pupil cost is based on like again
you're funding the system not the
student like to add one more child into
Rye I don't believe it's really going to
cost the taxpayers of Rye thirty
thousand dollars
representative Woodcock I have a
question that's going to follow up
exactly on that track you're on I'm done
you're in uh captain and you want to
send your youngster to Waterville Valley
or a community which is a huge drop but
your child is also a catastrophic Aid
student where the costs are 250 000
who's going to pay that burden
the way I interpret this bill and maybe
someone else has a different opinion but
I think it's the the taxes you paid and
you're you're sending your current
District your is what's funding
the special ed program
thank you represent Damon
I have more than one question I'll start
with on page three lines 27 to 30. where
it limits the number of reassignments or
transfers in any one school year
so what happens if more parents and
students apply what
they're just shut off or
what happens I believe this would allow
the school to give priority to students
who do reside in that District over kids
who want to
move their is that your question I'm
sorry
let me say back what I think I heard you
say to see if I have it right
you are is that okay Mr chair yes go
ahead so you're saying the residents in
a district would have priority for their
local school
and then if I'm reading this 27 to 30
lines correctly the incoming students
from anywhere else
are capped at this amount but my
question is
if there's more incoming students what
is the criteria deciding who who can
come and who doesn't get to come
I don't think the bill
um specifies that I would assume I would
assume each district could set those
parameters if they wanted to do a
lottery or you know enrollment in
general in New Hampshire is is falling
so I'm not sure there's a physical space
limitation in most of these schools if
that's where you're if that's what
you're referring to I guess you could do
a lottery system that sort of thing like
Charter Schools do I'm not sure if that
the bill specifies what a superintendent
can do to decide who gets in
in what order
I don't think it does represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um
so first of all I think what this bill
is ultimately trying to do is is
introduce competition which is something
that I applaud I do have a couple
concerns and one of them and I'm hoping
you can speak to it that maybe help
alleviate the concern is that under this
bill we could conceivably see rapid
swings of relatively large numbers of
students between schools and how how
could that impact the ability to do
things like large-scale new construction
and other projects within different
areas
is there a three okay three lines 27
right here
okay I would withdraw that because there
is a limitation on the bill but I if I
may
um
in that case would it not I mean if
there is a limitation on this we're not
allowing every student to participate is
that not in itself
kind of another problem that I was
talking
I think
what we saying rep oh
we're putting a limit on that to prevent
that the first question I asked about
the large swings apparently we're going
to prohibit that by eliminating the
number of students that are able to
transfer from any one School director
any one other school district to one
percent but is that is that not in
itself kind of an unfair way of of doing
it we're just kind of lottery for which
students are going to be able to go
foreign
that are going to change schools because
of this but there are a small percentage
maybe it's one percent maybe it's less
that are not having their needs met at
their current District school if they're
assigned to by ZIP code I wanted to
reference one other thing if I may like
the correct the housing crisis that we
have in New Hampshire is limiting people
from keeping their children in the
district they're in so imagine if you
are having trouble finding housing uh in
your current district and you're basing
your child moving into another District
because you have to move to another
apartment for example this would save
that student if the parent is willing to
drive them to the next town over uh if
they should find housing nearby that
would eliminate this as a school board
member formally we had children who
would petition to stay in the school
because their parents lost their housing
and we would have to make a case-by-case
basis
um on whether we let children finish the
year because they were forced to move
out of the ZIP code that's an arbitrary
line that decides where this children
belongs so um I guess I just thought
about when I was when you were asking
but thank you
I I do have a follow-up question in mind
um about 10 years ago we had a bill that
dealt with students going from one
District to another and there had to be
mutual agreement between the receiving
district and the sending District
my concern is how does this bill prevent
a school that's the receiving School
saying we're going to selectively
admit to our school
the kids that are going to be able to
make our division one basketball team a
winner here in the state and by that the
and the parents going to say well that's
going to provide my child a better
opportunity to get a division one
scholarship uh for post-secondary
Education later so how do we stop this
from you know developing these
athletic superpowers and it will occur
so this bill still maintains you need to
manifest educational hardship
or any other hardship is determined by
the parent but it does not include
playing competitive Sports at the D1
student uh the other school down the
road that's how I interpret it
Mr thank you representative Hall
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question I
was just wondering if you you could give
your two or three
um the best interests of the child give
examples of what that would be to go to
another school
so thank you for the question so
um child wants to do Robotics and their
their school uh their High School in
their District doesn't have a robotics
program but um I'm gonna say Pinkerton
because that's a school near me uh
Pinkerton does can their parents uh
choose Pinkerton and send their child
there for high school because they have
a love for robotics or curriculum
offerings that this school doesn't have
um we have a student who wants to learn
Mandarin Chinese and elementary school
because their family is
um a speaker of that language they don't
offer that at their elementary school
but they offer it in Portsmouth I'm not
sure I'm just you know
um I would say bullying also exists as a
um
a hardship if they're having trouble
there or
um there's a lot of reasons though so in
my district uh Fremont we have a tuition
program with a Regional High School and
so parents will come and say something
we'll petition for their own child to go
to a another school that's not on record
because of XYZ and it's some sort of
educational hardship I think that most
people are familiar with that
thank you
we have another six cards on this bill
so if you have a question it might be
asked to somebody else that's you know
might be good represent
Allison I'll be talking about this and
uh thank you chair thank you for taking
my question building on an example that
representative Miler used early on we've
got a fourth grade classroom that has 30
kids in it and one teacher if in fact
the transfers coming in amount to like
10 or 15 students in the school district
has to hire a half-time fourth grade
teacher who pays the salary of that
additional half-time fourth grade
teacher
that that District does so just like
within the year uh within any school
year there's budgeting adjustments like
transfers uh based on enrollment you
don't know when you're budgeting out 18
months who's going to be there you take
a best guess maybe you put in some ghost
students into the budgeting process to
allow for that growth but you don't know
come September 1st who's moved out of
the town or who's moved in so would you
take from another grade that maybe had
some attrition who lost students who now
the second grade has 14 kids would you
you know now not have two second grade
classes maybe go down to one that's what
we do in my district is that we move
teachers around
to accommodate the current situation and
that's the part of the budgeting process
thank you represent a noble
almost did you write your hand up
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question can we just talk
about the special ed just one more time
page four lines 13 through 15. if I went
back to
the original wording it would say if a
child is enrolled out of District the
town that the child resides in would
retain all responsibility provision of
special ed services is that correct
that's the original morning okay may I
follow up yes
um so we you switched it to attends so
but maintained all the same
responsibilities
so does that mean that the attending
district has to pick up all the price
so I questioned this myself this morning
because I didn't like the wording I have
two special ed kids so I'm familiar um
so you're paying so much per pupil in
your current residing district and that
money would go to be a
attending I'm not I'm not sure if this
should be reworded or amended but I read
it that way too that it's the opposite
and I don't think that's
um
possible okay in this school so um I do
think that wording's a little
maybe that's an error thank you thank
you representative Tanner and then we're
going to go on to the next card thank
you for letting me take the question
um
thank you for taking my question is this
bill based on an Alec open enrollment
national uh bill
I don't know the answer to that I'm a
co-sponsor um I agree with that I don't
know where it came from
if it was model legislation is what
you're asking
model Edge from Alec from Malik I don't
know that question I'm sorry I'm the
answer
thank you thank you very much I'd like
good morning good morning I'm David
Trumbull I live in the town of where I'm
opposed to this bill for three reasons
first I think it will do harm to the
property poor towns in the state because
under this bill if they lose five
percent of the students at a particular
school that will affect the amount of
money they get from the state as part of
the state aid meanwhile those five
percent of the students who go to
another school they're going to have to
negotiate with the receiving town the
amount of tuition so I live in where we
spend about sixteen thousand dollars per
student we border with Hopkinton we fact
share a robotics team with them I can
invest and envision
vast amounts of people in my town saying
I want to send my child over to
Hopkinton because they spent closer to
30 000 per student so somebody's going
to have to negotiate how much they get
if it costs where fifteen thousand more
per student and we lost money from the
state we now have less money but we
still have fixed costs we still have the
same classrooms the maintenance costs
probably the same number of teachers
that's going to hurt the property poor
town so a bill like this will widen the
gap between the property four towns and
the property Rich towns as far as their
ability to provide an education so I
don't think it will help second of all
this bill lacks any criteria if the town
of where is only going to be allowed to
send so many to Hopkinton how do you
decide who it's going to be the chairman
was concerned that it might be for
athletic reasons I could see a property
Rich Town saying we'll only take the
children who have the highest gpas from
your school so now you've got this drain
of all of your top students from your
school now going over to the property
richtown school who already do much
better on the state a proficiency exams
that's going to hurt the property poor
town school because you need to have a
good balance of students in your schools
so without criteria this bill just
really doesn't even have the the the
solidity to be legitimately considered
the third thing is what's the
alternative to this uh a representative
said something about this bill promotes
competition maybe competition between
public schools and private schools is a
good idea but competition between public
schools and different towns is not a
good idea the property poor towns can't
afford to provide an adequate education
you saw in the Concord Monitor that last
week the town of Allenstown the school
board there examined what they would
have to do if they could only get the
amount of money that was defined as
adequate under the state definition they
basically had to get rid of all
individual special ed Sports after
school activities plowing the driveway
fixing the roof they had to fire 85
percent of their people in town the
state isn't providing enough money so
the alternative would be to adequate
fund every school in the state the
property poor towns and the property
Rich towns as was required by the
Supreme Court in the Claremont decision
that you wouldn't have a need for this
sort of a bill or the very few cases you
would you could find some other
alternative like Charter Schools or
things like that but there's no need for
this bill if we go back to the beginning
this legislatures have a duty sitting on
its desk for 30 years to adequately fund
education in the property poor towns and
every one of the bills that you're
considering and I've been watching from
home and I appreciate how hard you're
working most of them could be resolved
if you just solve that problem
originally you wouldn't need a bill like
this so those are my three reasons thank
you very much sir thank you very much
are there questions
thank you you're welcome I'd like to
welcome Barrett good morning chairman
Ladd good morning again members of the
community bear Christina school boards
Association we are opposed to the bill
um the previous speaker summed it up um
perfectly from nhsba standpoint there
are a couple other
um sort of logistical aspects of the
bill that um I think they're probably
oversights but I think it's important to
um to draw attention to them
um for example
um on page two line 20 we talk about or
any other hardship as determined by the
parent and then also at the bottom of
that page it says the superintendent
shall have the burden of establishing
the absence of a manifest educational
hardship by clear and convincing
evidence but if we jump to page three
line five it says if the school board
finds that the parent or Guardian has
not met their burden so I don't know if
that was an oversight in drafting or or
whatever that that may have been
um the other challenge too with this
bill is that
um yeah it's somebody over here
mentioned I forget who it was about sort
of Swing in student population in any
given year and how are School District's
going to be able to respond to that if
you don't know how many kids you're
losing in any given year and you know
how many kids that you're having coming
in every year I don't know how you're
able to properly budget your budget is
based on the number of students that you
have in the building your state aid is
have in your ADM in your in your adma so
you know are there timelines from one
parent or students would have to like
apply to the other school what happens
if this is if you suddenly you lose or
gain 20 kids in the middle of a school
year I mean we can't find enough
paraprofessionals and teachers today as
it is and also our school district
budgets are set 18 months before they're
actually becoming operational based on
Based on data that's like two years old
so I don't know I don't know how you can
properly budget or a school district
could properly prepare for anything like
this the other aspect
um I'm gonna see where page four
lines 11 through 15 where it's now
shifting special ed
costs to the where the the district
where the student attends that is a
seismic shift in special ed funding in
New Hampshire I remember when this
provision came into law and I want to
say 2007 2008 maybe 2009 where there was
a a disagreement with um a local policy
actually over who was going to be
responsible for special education costs
for a student that did not attend in
District and I believe it went up the
federal court I think federal court
determined that it was going to be the
District of residence that was going to
provide the special education cost so
that would be that would be a seismic
shift as as well too
um the rest of the stuff about the
definition of residency I didn't really
I didn't really have any too too many
object objections with
um there is one curious provision though
on page six line five where it says um
actually that whole
preceding paragraph lines 31 through
about 36. no person shall be excluded in
participation
um based on discrimination based on age
sex gender identity race color sexual
orientation so on and so forth and it
says or their residents within the
borders of the state so
what town you live in is now going to be
a protected class under
anti-discrimination law that I don't
that that seems that seems peculiar that
we're creating another protected class
based on based on where somebody lives
um the other aspect too I won't I won't
get into this again a lot of this
committee has has
um we've lived through various
iterations of the Manifest educational
hardship statute over the last five or
six years now representative or chairman
lad you know nhsba was always happy to
help with that there have been some
changes to the manifested statute that
nhsba has opposed there were some
changes to the man educational statute
nhsba was happy to support and how happy
help craft I mean I'm not hearing those
questions and concerns about manifests
that are not coming across my desk our
staff attorney is not getting those
calls we've maintained that for a number
of years the manifested system will
perhaps not perfect by and large worked
well and continuing to change the
statute every single year is is
problematic for school districts and
really not in the best interest of
parents or kids either because when the
chain of law is changing every single
year you're not able to rely on what the
system that preceded it may may allow or
encourage or or benefit students in so
those are nhsba's objections and I'm
happy to answer any questions I have one
question for you if a student is
attending Rivendell
which is one of our intergovernmental
Interstate type districts and the
student from Warford wants to go to
Hanover recording this bill they could
do so but what about the other high
school students sitting right beside
this student in class comes from Corinth
or fairly that comes from I'm sorry the
last bit or fairly Vermont which is
right in our school district right yeah
I mean the the the the the inter state
districts are sort of their own animal
aren't they it's not really clear who
those students belong to are they
Vermont students are they New Hampshire
students
um that's certainly a question relative
to the bill I guess one of the other
aspects too we've talked about a
robotics team or a hockey team in
athletics there are a series of
decisions from the State Board of
Education going back 15 20 years where
the state board has determined that the
lack of an extracurricular activity is
not a manifest educational hardship it
doesn't necessarily it may it may you
know yeah the kid might like to be on
the hockey team or the robotics team or
whatever program you know that there is
but you know to some degree that's going
to get back to the previous speakers
questions about if you're at high school
can't offer a hockey team it's probably
you know one reason maybe because of
money it may be they can't afford it
maybe they don't have enough kids to
field a team but we know that you know
we have sports teams now that comprise
of three or four different high schools
whether or not that's soccer whether or
not that's hockey whatever it might be
so public schools are already working to
integrate these sorts of programs and
extracurriculars in areas
um that that kids may not otherwise be
able to access them thank you further
questions
representative Lucas
I wanted to address your budgeting
issues
um
my understanding is schools can't tell
how many kids are going to be there at
any point in time anyways because people
move in and out of the district and a
previous speaker had said they actually
budget for go students just in case they
get others would does this school boards
Association not have you have policies
for everything do United policies for
how to deal with fluctuating populations
based on all the things we see now kids
moving in and out all those kinds of
things let's take for the question
representative I mean we know we don't
have any specific policies on that there
are probably internal budgetary
um
um that's where I'm looking for
protocols that your ba uses in
conjunction with your superintendent and
your business manager and whatnot I mean
you have we have a former superintendent
on this committee we might be able to
ask her how she would budget for these
ghost students and and how to deal with
the fluctuations in the student
population in any given year thank you
thank you it's just a follow-up to that
and let's represent Cascade and let's go
there
we have a budget process established by
Doe in which our budget is premised upon
the attendance in the prior year
so we do not budget for go students is
that correct thank you for the question
I mean well that there's funding and
budgeting yes the funding is based on
the number of kids that we've had based
on all the doe reports whether or not
you you know you I don't want to you
know and to some degree they're not so
much go students but you have to
anticipate you know historical Trends
say you know you know we may go up one
and a half percent of our student
population over the course of these 12
months the other aspect too and this
just popped into my mind I'm sorry I
want to take up any more time I know
we've got a lot of bills today the other
question that this doesn't necessarily
reflect is what happens if the receiving
School District ends up with a
significant budget surplus at the end of
the year where does that money does it
go back only to the taxpayers in that
Community or does it go back to the
taxpayers that are then sending their
kids in to that community
the bill doesn't address that we have at
least with our tuition agreements where
a district maybe sends their high school
kids to it to a different town that can
at least be negotiated all right we want
a certain percentage back of your
unexpended fund balance every year to
come back into our community because
we're paying 25 000 ahead but you've got
a million dollars on reserve fund
balance next year maybe that you know in
part because we were paying tuition
maybe maybe our voters should get some
of that money back as well too so the
law doesn't address for the simple the
summary of this is that there are a lot
of budgeting and revenue problems if you
just open up sort of open enrollment
across across any New Hampshire school
thank you not seeing any other hands
thank you very much thank you uh Deborah
house
okay
good morning Jeremy Ladd and members of
the committee I am happy to be here
addressing you on House Bill 4041 this
morning
um Confederation of teachers New
Hampshire and I want to express our
position to this bill we have 4 000
members across the state and I was doing
a little math yesterday our members are
mostly in K-12 education but also uh
public higher education and public
services and in one way or another we
work with about 29 000 students in
districts across the state so that's a
good chunk of the 165 000 students in
public education in New Hampshire and we
do oppose this bill
um as you know New Hampshire cherishes
public education so much so they put it
in the Constitution but it doesn't do a
good job funding it and previous
speakers have talked about that so I
won't go into too much detail
but um
you know we have huge disparities in
what you can get for your public
education in New Hampshire
just a few statistics here
in New Hampshire for a dollar spent on
public education 64 cents comes from
local property taxes 31 cents comes from
State funding and five cents
approximately comes from the federal
government that's from the national
Center for educational statistics
um and we are last in the country for
State funding of public education
so you can get
a lot
different level of opportunity in your
public education depending upon where
you are getting that public education
and that's what we need to fix not by
letting a few kids go here or there
depending upon whether their parents can
provide transportation whether they are
close to another District that provides
a lot more opportunity but by fixing the
funding formula so that every Public
School in New Hampshire can provide a
great education be wonderful if Mandarin
were an option in elementary school or
robotics were an option for all public
school students let's strive for the
goal of having
quality
well-resourced public schools for all of
our students and really rather than
repeating what other people have said I
think I'll stop there I do have
testimony that will be coming to you by
email Microsoft is aside I need to
update all the drivers on all of my
technology this week so I apologize for
not having it to hand out to you but you
will be getting it as soon as I get back
to my seat and I'll answer questions if
I can thank you very much representative
Lexus
um my understanding is that some
students some of the reasons they don't
want to go to their public school as it
stands now special needs students it's
because the school is too big and too
noisy and whatever and when they go to a
charter school it's because it's small
because they have problems with all of
that input and everything of the noise
and the other students would that not
also
help them if the neighboring school
which you say you know maybe as small
and doesn't have much to offer but maybe
what they have to offer is the fact that
they're small and quiet and so that
special needs student might choose to go
to the smaller and potentially poorer
school just because it's smaller and
quieter and they wouldn't have to go to
find a small charter school they could
find that smaller public school right
next door
I hear you mixing several different
types of schools small Charter Schools
small next door school I'm not going to
try and parse through a bunch of
hypotheticals here I think I'll just
just leave that for your discussion with
the committee so but I appreciate the
question thank you thank you very much
for the questions
thank you
uh it's representative what oh I didn't
see that thank you thank you for taking
my question do you feel that um charter
schools actually offer the alternative
choice for parents in a in a public
school system uh that would that would
kind of
place the take the place of this
particular need to to be able to go to
um schools without outside of your
residence we do have that within our
state law framework already in our
framework of laws we have the existence
of charter schools so that is already an
option
yes thank you further questions thank
you very much uh it's representative
Josh Keelan right here
oh Josh you're hiding behind her no no
no he's not here
I'm right here
if he wants to testify yeah okay Josh
thank you chairman my name for the
record is representative Joshua Kella
I'm from Fremont
um representing Fremont Danville and and
Brentwood Rockingham 32. and I thank you
for um
taking my testimony
um as the prime sponsor I I'm sorry I'm
late I had to uh a bill to introduce him
in the committee next door at 9 30 also
um so the what I was really trying to
um
do with this bill is to not discuss
the
um outside uh other educational
opportunities or talk about the
budgeting process I'm talking I want
um the focus of our education to be on
the students and what's in the best
interest of the students
and a lot of the testimony that you hear
today is it would be really hard
it would be really hard for Budget it
would be really hard for planning but I
don't hear a lot of discussion about it
really is not was best for the student
like what we're deciding right now is
based on where you live and that is not
necessarily what is best for the student
to go to the school that is close to
them
what what I'm trying to say is that
you should not when you're hearing
testimony earlier and and after me
are are the arguments because it is what
is in the best interest of the child or
is it because it's convenient and easy
and so I think that this bill is mainly
um
trying to adjust that
um focus of the state to say no we're
not we're not in it for the institution
of of public schools
um we're in it for the children and
we're trying to provide an education and
um so we need to make an assessment and
what is in the best interest of a kid
and not just try and prop up this school
or that school they're all public
schools where we're talking about today
is all public schools and and does any
of the public schools in our state re
fit the needs of of the children and
um
and if they do then why shouldn't that
child be able to attend that school
what why should the government come in
and say no that's not appropriate
because you don't live there and
especially when there's housing issues
and maybe you're not able to maybe you
would be want to move into that District
but because there's essentially no
housing you're not able to move at that
time and maybe you're going to plan to
move in the future when something
becomes available but right now you why
harmed or lack of a better word or not
not reaching their full potential
because they're not able to make that
move right now in this climate of not of
uh housing shortage right and so all of
these things come into Factor but the
real question is what is in the best
interest of these children is it is it
that school or this school and where is
the government
um proper role if it's just to say you
know we're trying to educate the kid and
trying to do what's best for the kid or
are we really trying to just prop up
this this specific system and obviously
we've already heard before that that
there already is complications as far as
budgeting it's not an easy process and
yes there there is funding from the
state that is based on the prior
attendance but the school district the
school budget is still
um based on uh their historical needs
and what they believe may be the case
and there is a provision in this that
um you can lit not have more than
um one percent uh changing changing uh
because of this and so you have some
range to be able to
estimate what is going to be the change
in this next particular Year yes it's
not exactly but you don't have an exact
number now and so
um I don't think that there's any
um reason that that should should be a
uh
a detriment to this this idea and
there there's a process for
being able you don't just because
um you know you can have a policy that
says you're going to accept this many
students if if that's if you don't want
uh to the question before about oh what
if you are maxed out and you need and
you have another person come in well you
don't if you're already maxed out you
can have a policy that says you're not
going to accept more than this many
students because this is your maximum
you know capacity and so the when uh uh
a parent and an administrator is having
that conference they can come to the
realization that this this school is not
going to be able to meet the needs of
that student because they don't have the
capacity for another uh another student
and so
um in the times of um of declining
enrollment and and less children that I
think a lot of uh schools would be happy
to be welcoming in additional students
um because what we're seeing mostly is
people uh is is declining enrollment and
so having a full school will make
um you know a better productive use of
the the taxpayers money so thank you for
for letting me testify thank you very
much I do have one question for you to
ensure that there's no special
preparation
preferential treatment given to a
particular student have you looked at
the charter school admission process
thank you for the question I'm familiar
with it are you I did not consider
putting it in this this bill but I'm not
opposed to such a change if that you
think that that would be appropriate I
my goal of this bill is is to be focused
on what is in the best interest of the
children and not
um a specific
um you know school district and so if
and so if the lottery is the correct way
if you have a you know a bunch of
students which would all be able to be
adequately served by the school and and
you chose it by Lottery I'm not opposed
to that I'm just I think that um that
the sentiment as far as like what we're
what our goal is and and trying to
educate and give these children the best
option I think that is
is where my head is at for this thank
you Bill thank you there are questions
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question absolutely
um
and thank you for looking out for the
best interest of kids because I've spent
my 45-year career looking out in the
best interest of kids whether it's best
interest manifest hardship or tuitioning
to another District but I'd like to
address a new bill on page three lines
and doing what's best for kids should
always be our priority
and in reality it comes down to
what people can afford so let me give
you an example this particular line I'm
referencing says that a student
reassigned
would the average daily membership would
be counted on the students resident
School District so I interpreted that as
that school district would receive
adequacy at a base cost of 3 800 per
pupil
the next line says that any tuition
would be forwarded to that other
District
so let's take an average per pupil cost
on the low end of twenty five thousand
dollars per pupil so that that says a
district needs to provide that
difference of money
now given that scenario
I can tell you that from a property poor
District that has only 50 to 55 percent
taxable property
because the other 45 percent is federal
and state National Forest lands
and a property tax of 39 per thousand
I guess I'd want to know
what impact do you feel this should
weigh on a taxpayer
um to come up with a difference in the
money and to add to that
in 2013
my district had the free spending in the
month of January because we had expenses
whether it was not a district placement
or other expenses that hadn't been
budgeted for
and the town is not going to give more
money would you see the role of a
taxpayer playing a role here
thank you for the question I didn't I
didn't really
um I heard a lot of uh numbers and and
the cost and not a lot of question about
what is in the best interest of the
child or or if the the needs are being
met and so I think that that when we are
having the discussion with the taxpayer
in that situation we will be discussing
that
um that these are the that we are trying
to educate the children in the best way
and and trying to meet the needs of that
child and so
we would have to explain that this is a
cost of
educating the child and that is
um you know we don't we would not want
to
um give this
um this child uh negative
um
like a setback in life just because it
it was
um hard or that the the budget
was more difficult I think that we would
bring in that discussion we would bring
the the needs of the child into the
Forefront of the discussion so thank you
for the question thank you thank you
representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair thanks for
taking my question so um so along the
same lines is what representative
cascadden was asking about let's take an
example of of another two towns that are
um that are about
um you know 20 minutes half hour away
from each other uh Hopkinton one of the
towns that I represent in Newport
um about uh 20 miles away and um and
very interesting school districts
because both of them have some of the
highest property tax rates in the state
but are on the opposite ends of the
Spectrum in terms of student outcomes
and I hear what you're saying in terms
of the importance of of looking out for
students and and making sure we get good
student outcomes I think we probably all
agree on that but um but would you
support
um
would you support uh this well again
Newport and Hopkinton both with high tax
rates Hopkinton just barely able to to
coming up with the resources it needs
for strong student outcomes Newport
even with a high tax rate can't come up
with the resources they need for uh for
uh for us for a good school budget to
deliver strong student outcomes would
you support the state applying its
resources in a way to help out school
districts like Newport have access to
the resources they need to serve their
residents
thank you for the question
um what I
um am hearing out of your question and
or
um
and
is that
um
that the cost
the cost per student is not always or
it's not always correlated with student
outcomes like the cause per pupils spent
on the student is not always correlative
with the student outcomes and so no no I
just want to make sure you're not
putting those words in my mouth because
I did not say that and the facts do not
reflect that
thank you for the clarification okay
that then um
your your example had two towns with
both High tax rates and one was meeting
the needs of students
and one of them wasn't
and both of them both have high tax
rates and so the question
in that sense scenario is that maybe one
of them
is not uh maybe they need to you know
change what they're doing to model more
along the lines of the one that's
meeting the needs I don't I don't think
that this bill is going to solve that
issue
um and uh and so the the tax rate is
neither
um
you know a high tax rate doesn't mean
that you're needing the needs of the the
children so I think that the goal should
be meeting the needs of the children and
not focused as much on the tax rate
specifically follow up Mr chair a quick
one yeah it will be quick so so uh
Hopkins able to meet the needs of its
children with a high tax rate uh to
raise a a school budget that's um that's
very much sort of State average on a per
pupil basis Newport not having access to
the resources it needs still a very high
tax rate higher than Hopkins tax rate
um can't even come close with that
they're trying as hard as they can So
based on your answer are you suggesting
that Newport res taxpayers need to work
even harder maybe
um another 20 30 40 50 on their tax rate
to uh to try to put together a
reasonable school budget and uh and have
this uh similar outcomes or Statewide
outcomes
thank you for the clarification uh no I
don't I don't I don't agree that more
money means better outcomes so I I think
that there may be other uh Solutions but
I don't believe that money if you
already are putting a lot a significant
amount of money towards the the um this
meeting the needs of the child I don't
think that
always the solution is putting more
money towards that so what other
Solutions are you talking about hold on
reps we're getting into the area of
fiscal capacity disparity Aid and all
that we're not going there on this uh
are there any other questions
representative Tanner thank you I asked
the other sponsor of this bill and I'd
like to ask you this is this based on
model
um legislation from Alec thank you no
thank you
uh we're gonna I'm gonna stop testimony
on this right now and I want to thank
you very much for coming forward uh Jess
Edwards uh you're here to speak hello
I'm Miss Bill yes sir will you come
forward please
thank you uh I'll keep it short
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31. right now I'm
I'm here representing
um my my daughter and her experience
many of you knew uh Elizabeth Edwards
when she was in the house a few years
ago
Elizabeth when she was about
eight or nine years old she uh she was
with us when we moved to St Louis and uh
we went we went into a very nice School
District The Rockwood School District
and but my daughter had exceptional
needs and they couldn't really meet them
in the Rockwood School District so I I
worked very closely with all of the
administrators and leadership in the
Rockwood schools to see if we could
figure out a way to give her the
full-time support that she needed
instead of a part-time support and
um and it had and they just couldn't do
it there was there was no way to make it
happen so it happened one day that I
took a friend of mine from work I I
dropped her off her at her house and I
saw a little cute
School in the neighborhood and I thought
oh that's a cute school I'll just stick
my head in there for some reason they
had a deal on the wall talking about the
exactly the kind of program that my
daughter needed exactly so I made an
appointment
impromptu appointment to talk to the
principal and and talk to her about my
daughter and said hey she said if you
bring your daughter here you're going to
have to worry about the transportation
we don't handle the transportation but
if she meets the eligibility she's she's
more than welcome to come and I said
this is so great I'm in the Rockwood
School District I'm talking to those
people and this is exactly what they
need I wonder why they don't know and
the principal let me know well they do
know as a matter of fact the person
you're talking to is on our board she
knows all about this program
that person withheld information from me
that would have helped my wife and I
transfer our daughter much sooner to
this program that would have benefited
her and the reason she didn't do it is
because when the child transferred the
school district had to transfer at the
time it was five thousand dollars is 25
years ago and she was more interested in
keeping the head count for her program
and keeping the money that she was in my
daughter and here 25 plus years later
I'm still hostile and angry that my
child was viewed as the property of that
school district and that they were
holding information from the US as
parents that that would have helped so
fortunately we were in a rental
situation and we got we went ahead and
got my daughter enrolled into this
program it was just great for her and
because we were in a rental situation
had the resources we moved you know
within a few blocks of this school
building and everything worked out
really great so so what I am a strong
advocate for is school choice this we
need to worry about the kids one kid at
a time what's in their best interests
and all this money stuff we can figure
it out this is this is why we have
adults involved in the education system
we're supposed to figure out this stuff
so that the kids can benefit from having
the best possible education for their
needs and I would ask you to find a way
to support this bill whether you know I
need some kind of an amendment around
the money limiting the money from one
school district or another right you
know I let's worry about the money
separate but let's worry about the kids
first and foremost thank you thank you
very much representative are there
questions for our representative Edwards
thank you thank you very much uh Louise
Spencer
hi Mr chairman thank you for taking my
testimony thank you members of the
committee my name is Louise Spencer and
I'm from Concord I'm also co-founder of
the Kemp Street Coalition which is an
all-volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization education is one of our
Prime
issues that we focus on
um
so this this build would be just another
blow to the struggling schools in our
state because it would allow let's face
it the majority of kids that may be
looking to move out of their districts
would be moving out of schools that are
underfunded that don't have the programs
that are needed we heard about
Allenstown perhaps having to cut what
parent wouldn't want to look for the
best possible school for their child but
those struggling schools would not only
lose the money for the student but then
be faced with also having to pay
additional money to another District to
the tune of paying more than what they
would pay to educate the child in their
own District creating a incredible
and in all deference to the chairman I
think this bill is all about disparity
and funding in our schools and our
failure to make sure that we are doing
what we must do
so that all our schools can perform and
provide what is needed now that means of
course occasionally a child is not going
to get their their needs met in a school
and we already have a bill a statute
that allows schools to look at moving
their child moving a child if that this
that school district or that school
definitely cannot meet the needs of that
child but that's very different from
what's being proposed here which is
basically putting it in the hands of the
parents to say I'm going to send my
child where I choose to send my child
and the districts can you know
regardless of what I'm paying for taxes
the districts can figure that out and
figure it out how that's going to be
paid
um
I've seen Brill after Bill after Bill in
this committee that allows for
certain children to get certain
privileges
because they have parents who are there
and available to advocate for them and
that's a really wonderful thing if you
are lucky enough as a child to have a
parent who can advocate for you
but not all children have that not all
children have parents who have the
capacity for whatever reason that these
are often very loving parents but they
because of work because of other other
things they they don't necessarily have
the capacity to advocate for their
children so what we need to do is fix
our schools for all children all of the
children not allow certain kids to be
pulled out of schools that pull money
and resources out of those schools and
then allow just the remaining students
to have to deal with the the remains of
you know what's left to them
we talk about the best interests of the
child someone was saying oh because
we're talking about funding we're not
talking about the best interest of the
child well it's in the best interest of
every child in our state to have strong
public schools in every community and we
need to stop focusing on allowing one
child to pull money out of one district
and put it you know into homeschooling
or another District we need to start
talking about how we're going to fund
our schools our Public Schools how we're
going to meet the Mandate of Claremont
and adequate education so with that I
will
um
I will conclude my testimony are there
questions from the committee
not seeing you thank you very much okay
thank you the last card I have here uh
good morning good morning my name is
Sarah Smith thank you for taking my
comments and on this bill I wasn't
really intending to speak but as I was
listening to this it did occur to me I
have something relevant to say
um
uh as I was growing up in Montgomery
County Maryland I went to school in the
in the in the local schools and because
uh the the county funded was the
fiscal person for the for all of the
districts within it
all the schools and there were 30 or 40
high schools it was big
um but they allowed us to switch high
schools if we wanted to
um because it was all funded together
didn't matter there's a school with a
special program I wanted to go to and I
and I just signed up and switched and
provided my own transportation to get
there
um so it was it this this uh I I like
the idea of having this kind of
flexibility but I don't think it will
work under our current system
our current system of funding by the
towns is we're not allowed would not
make this a fair system at all
um I live in the town of Pembroke and
some of you may remember that
a few years ago not too long ago we had
a we had a situation where we get we get
students tuitioned in from other
districts and there was a miscalculation
on the the amount of students coming in
um and we had to make up a million
dollars in our budget and we got a bell
for an extra thousand dollars
uh a couple of months later without any
other preparation we knew we had maybe a
uh I don't remember exactly maybe a
couple weeks noticed that we were going
to get this big huge bill in addition to
what we were already paying which is
pretty large in Pembroke
so I I don't think this this will work
under our current system just the
um
our situation was caused by about I
think nine students who did not that
they were counting on who didn't sign up
and that's just a small little amount
but it was a million dollars to our town
cost each each of the taxpayers
somewhere around a thousand dollars more
so it just won't work this this whole
this idea
um won't work under our current system
I'm I'm in favor of switching over to a
county-wide system myself but that
doesn't seem to be on the table so uh I
would uh I would prefer that we uh just
uh
itl this bill and and uh and do
something more realistic about these
issues that we have in the same thank
you very much other questions
not seeing any thank you very much just
received another card here
um
is it Teresa
would you please not go you know the
last card was one minute or so and they
went longer so we also have to try to
keep I understand we're getting way
behind schedule so my name is Teresa
Cornell I'm from Loudon New Hampshire
I'm here um two things I have a very
similar story as Jazz Edwards my 20 year
old intervened with a child that was
suiciding
um and when that child got out of uh
Hampton sight word actually threatened
her life I worked very diligently with
Merrimack Valley School District and
Concord a school district to try and
make it so that she had her right to an
education she was a traumatized
nightmares PTSD the whole nine yards
facing this child in the hall but yet
the school district couldn't refuse him
the right to attend school because the
whole occurrence happened outside of the
school so we shoehorned her in using the
CRT program to put tuition was at
Merrimack Valley tried to transfer it to
Concord I came up with the difference it
was a flip been Nightmare and my
daughter paid a huge price for stepping
into the Gap and actually ending up
saving this child's life by bringing it
to adults attention when she saw it on
social media
the following year they couldn't approve
the whole thing she was put into crtc
classes that weren't appropriate for her
that were way above her ability to keep
up with she went from a straight A
student to I was like losing my child
I ended up having no other choice but to
put her to Bishop Brady
so there's no Transportation also as a
foster mom believe me US parents we want
normalcy we want our kids to have what
we had growing up to get on the school
bus at the end of the driveway go down
and participate with their friends that
live in the neighborhood that's what we
want there's no way we're going to put
our child into a different School
District unless there's something
catastrophic that's going on that we see
our child not having the right to an
education we have to pay for
transportation so some of the issues
I've heard put a deadline in place
that so the school districts know
whether that child is going to be
attending them or not
um have the money that that property
taxpayer me as a Mom is putting it into
my school district let that be the
dollar amount that transfers to the
other school district and leave it on me
to make up the difference
to figure out how to pay for the
difference of tuition if it's more if
it's 25 000 at this school district
versus 12 000 at this school district
don't have me have to put her into a
private school like Bishop Brady where
she's going to school with orthodontist
kids who are picking on her because she
doesn't have the right jeans on and she
can't compete with those families or she
feels like an outcast because she's not
Catholic right this is providing public
school choice this is a good Public
School option we want our children you
know to be able to go and get that right
to an education kids are the priority
the transportation I had to bring her to
school and pick her up again it's not
something that I think we're going to
see huge Exodus of happening but I think
it's something that will prevent us from
having to put our kids into a school
option that's not public school and
finally I'm a foster mom and I can tell
you our foster kids as they get bounced
from home to home that is in a different
District to a different District they
lose out on their normalcy not only are
they having the loss of their family and
their friends but now they're going from
school to school to school this would
benefit benefit that population and I
will always be an advocate for those
kids that's where my journey began and
they get lost in all of this they should
be able to stay in their school district
even if they've moved outside of that
District we need to Shepherd some things
and look at the situations and and do
our best if we're spending three hundred
thousand dollars and that's Using twelve
thousand dollars a child with 25 kids in
the class
that money certainly isn't going to the
teacher
something is going horribly wrong when
Merrimack Valley school district has 45
million dollars for 1800 students and
our test scores are in the gutter
there's a lot of work to be done but
this I think is something that we can
put some a deadline
um the money that that taxpayer with
that Resident spends towards the school
district is what would follow the child
the difference it would keep us out of
having to go to private schools which we
already are seeing the mass Exodus of
people homeschooling and taking them out
of the public schools altogether because
they're getting bullied they're not
getting what they need our children by
law have a right to an education thank
you we need to move on here are there
any questions
thank you very much uh we're going to
Coast this hearing and in about five
minutes I'm does anybody have to take a
stand-up break yes we yes yes yes yes
okay uh we are going to take a five
minute break and come back and start on
104.
security
foreign
okay welcome to the uh hearing on
hb104 this bill is relative to
multi-stall bathrooms and locker rooms
in schools uh I am going to set up some
rules for this particular hearing
I'm going to allow the the prime sponsor
I'm going to give five minutes to the
prime sponsor and the remainder that are
coming up to testimony no more than
three minutes and we will have a timer
going here and the collusion of the
three minutes
it's going to stop and we're going to
move on together you'll get a hand
signal and then that will move on but
the prime sponsor we've always taken the
tack that if the prime sponsor is
referencing the bill and and specific
things within the bill that we need to
know we've given them some latitude and
that I'm I plan on doing right here so
the first uh speaker will be the prime
together
get right to it thank you the record uh
my name is Mike Moffett Merrimack Ford
lovely towns of uh Canterbury loud and
so I am not the original Prime sponsor
for this measure the original Prime
sponsor lost her re-election bid by 18
votes or whatever and is less out of our
current mix so is I have great respect
for The Honorable Melissa Litchfield I
agree to keep her bill alive and bring
it forward to you today
so I'm going to cook this year a couple
of thoughts though of course uh in in
2021 this committee heard a bill
I was part of the committee at that time
and that Bill had to do with sports and
transgender issues it was HB 198 and as
we were still constrained by the covid
thing uh all the testimony appeared uh
happened via Zoom
and I think a lot of you remember I
think 34 people tested by 33 of them uh
testified in opposition to the bill
which would have limited transgender
participation in sports
so I was very moved by the testimony
that day and I think uh those people who
testified moved the needle they did for
me
uh it broadened my awareness and
understanding of transgender issues I
learned some things even in my age
uh transgender issues were not on our
radar screens back when I was in high
school up in Groveton back in the 70s
so I mean the committee ultimately voted
to retain that bill so we heard the
people that day we heard mostly the moms
we heard the moms
so now in 2023 this committee has
another bill here that involves again
transgender issues
HB 104 simply seeks to mandate that
multi-style bathrooms be designated
same-sex as in one bathroom for those
who have XX chromosomes and another
bathroom for those who have X Y
chromosomes
the knee for such a bill as this would
have perplexed the good folks back in
growth and in the 70s but back then boys
are boys and girls are girls
today 2023 things are more complicated
uh there are transgender issues that
we're still learning about
in trying to understand better and I
expect that we'll hear from some of the
same moms today that we heard last term
and I expect these moms will again
Advocate to let their children select
the locker rooms or the bathrooms in
which they feel most comfortable
but
I also expect this time around we hear
from some other moms as well
uh Boston media reports yesterday that
school officials in Milford I know you
have some Milford folks there are
considering reinstating a bathroom rule
there that would allow students to only
use the restroom or locker room
uh that's in accordance with their
biological sex that's a look right now
right now it's a local issue for Milford
and for other towns to deal with
uh the court policy a lot of times is to
allow students to use whatever bathrooms
they choose what could possibly go wrong
well a lot could go wrong consider the
young girls in Loudoun County Virginia
who were assaulted in school restrooms
there
by a biological male wearing a skirt
timid School administrators dithered
and dissembled and covered up those
crimes down there until local outrage in
Loudoun County Virginia
finally results in the firing of the
superintendent
Virginia subsequently passed legislation
mandating gender-specific bathrooms so
the legislature in Virginia took action
after the crimes after the facts
foreign
we do not allow posters to be displayed
go ahead
I apologize
I'll see what the poster was on YouTube
later I'm curious so to finish yeah to
finish up as I say uh Virginia
uh took action after the crimes New
Hampshire has a chance to instead of
being reactive and pass legislation on a
Statewide level after
crimes we hope there are none
if if when
but we I think
form eruption of Litchfield and many
others think we should be proactive
instead of reactive so I know I keep
referring to moms but there are also
dads out there
and no one
no one should underestimate the emotions
it can be Unleashed when a dad thinks
his young daughters or granddaughters
are not safe or protected when they go
to school
I'm not the original sponsor she's not
here I can try to answer any questions
as best I can if there are any thank you
very much you're just getting down to
your time limit are there questions for
representative Moffett yes represent
McDonald thank you and good morning
representative Moffett I'm curious I
know there is another bill in the house
this session to Define biological sex
which is also in line four of this bill
if that bill were to pass would it
impact the passage of this bill or would
they contradict or conflicting anyway
thank you for your questions it's a
great question I think it might be HP
396 I'm not sure what the number is
that's very Broad and covers a lot of
different things this bill that
representative Litchfield uh put in is
specific to the bathroom in locker room
style issue uh great question and that's
something that could be funded out if
that other Bill also covered that this
then um that might make this a pro
Superfluous uh great question thank you
thank you for the questions
representative sure thank you Mr chair
thank you rep Moffett
um my question goes a little bit to the
intent of the bill and I just wanted to
ask would it be generally correct to say
that the bill is not necessarily
suggesting that a person who identifies
as a as another gender is likely to
commit a crime but rather somebody who
is likely to commit a crime would take
advantage of such a policy thank you
representative this is very well put and
I want to as I try to say in my
testimony uh I I anticipate some
ideology here uh I I
don't want this to imply that any group
is more prone to uh criminal Behavior
than any other group uh the 99
plus of of the communities that we're
talking about are all wonderful people
uh but the way you put it it captures
the intent I think that Melissa
Litchfield had it it you put it very
well thank you
further questions representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Moffett for taking my
question
um do we know right now how many schools
allow
anyone to use the bathrooms or right now
are bathrooms in the public schools
restricted based on gender or sex thank
you for the question a great question I
don't know what what schools do what I
know Milford has been in the news uh
yesterday they uh and so we know that
milford's looking to change their
policies locally so right now again it's
a it's a a local policy decision for
school boards to make as to their
bathroom policies uh what this would do
would make it would be a state it would
be a statute a law it would cover the
whole state and provide some definition
and recover everyone which I know it
would not no longer be a local uh
position but this I go back to the
Virginia case the reason Virginia passed
a law was because the under localities
they they weren't protecting their young
people
thank you further questions
Nazi thank you very much thank you Mr
I'd like to welcome uh representative
welcome to education thank you Mr chair
good morning committee members for the
record I'm Janine nodder town of
Merrimack I represent uh Hillsboro
District 12.
when women began working in the Mills
they advocated for separate bathrooms
from Men
they fought hard for that right
bathrooms are not separated by gender
but by biological sex that is why ladies
rooms have feminine products and Men's
Room have urinals
we are undoing the rights that women in
this country fought so hard for
I would like to also say that women and
girls who have been sexually abused can
feel terrified when a member of the
opposite sex walks into the lady's room
and I ask that you vote ought to pass on
this Bill thank you very much
representative are there questions of
Representative risk representative
Tanner thank you thank you and thank you
for taking my question do you think this
bill
um I know it's in schools but certainly
when they the schools are open for you
know public events would this eliminate
Young
women mothers bringing young boys
children into the women's bathroom to
use that bathroom
that's a good question and I would not
imagine so but I would like for you to
ask that question to my friend
Anne-Marie Banfield
um or Ian Hewitt who is the lawyer for
Cornerstone but if it doesn't then maybe
an amendment because
um I as a mother I used to have little
kids too I would I would bring them into
the bathroom as well but I don't I don't
think that that applies thank you thank
you any other questions thank you very
much thank you
okay I didn't I thought there was an
explanation mark at the end of that
welcome
okay
from Laconia from Laconia yeah thank you
Mr chairman and distinguished committee
members my name is Stephen
representative Stephen bogert from
I do not have statistics or reports to
give you
all I have is some common sense
I speak to you as a father of four three
daughters and one boy
I speak of you as a grandfather
I have two two grandchildren boys and
one daughter and one soon to be unknown
okay we leave that privilege as the most
reads all multi-stall bathrooms and
locker rooms in New Hampshire public and
charter schools for elementary middle
this bill is not about being any
political party
it doesn't matter how you associate
yourself
in any way shape or form and that's the
it is about our children our adolescent
children
who
at a young age still don't understand
a lot about what they're going through
when they reach
the age of 14 15 and for uh young ladies
it could be a little earlier they are
going through biological changes that
we must allow them to grow in their
natural forms okay they talk to their
parents their parents give them guidance
it is about having a safe place to go to
the bathroom or change their clothes for
gym
are for sports
we all been there
where you're sitting there and you're
with your own
back in the day as I look around we were
all in in the gymnasium we were all in
the locker room and we all felt that
weirdness
about getting changed and and in my day
you even had to take a shower after gym
so that even emphasized it even more so
hot
representative about 15 seconds left
children are going through hormonal
changes I went through that schools are
supposed to be about learning without
this Safeguard children will be worried
about going to the bathroom and gym and
not enjoying the experience that schools
should bring
how does the school protect the children
from issues that arise from mixed
bathrooms like pictures being taken or
social media reprisal being taken out
Children you've run out of time do you
have written testimony
I have what I have here yeah if you'd
like to submit that to the clerk we'd
welcome that okay thank you very much
other questions
not seeing thank you very much uh
thank you again for giving me the
opportunity
hey guys this bill my name is Maria
Perez
I'm a state representative from Milford
District 43 and I'm speaking it against
this bill
I'm embarrassed embarrassed to my town
make the news
not for something good
we'll make the news because our
transgender students
being attacked
by the school board
we're talking about kids we're talking
about humans
you're talking about human rights
it's the buy share of the national
Latino caucus is a human rights
shame on the people who's trying to push
if you have religion believe
don't post don't try to push those
beliefs in your community
don't try to push the students we have
enough mental health we have enough
crisis with the kids in school
this is not welcoming to the students
this is potion
for kids to feel unsafe and welcome
let me explain something to you
High School's in Milford
especially the high school they had a
water leak in December
the water leak went all over the places
the hidden system is not even properly
working we have issues at the library
and Milford
and now we try to put this National
agenda
against the transgender students and the
lbj2 community when we don't even have
the money to fix the heating system we
don't have enough money to fix all these
issues in the school
but now someone is trying to push
getting money out of the budget that we
like negative already
because voucher bills they're already
passed and we're taking away money from
our public school system
to push this
agenda with the bathrooms
let's be honest let's go back to the
table and do what is right for the
students and keep putting money into the
public schools that we can have a better
education this is not the way we should
be spending the money or the time
humiliating students human hearing kids
and then assuming that there are
criminals and rapers
they're humans remember that we're
talking about kids and we should be
talking be very careful
this is our next Generation so what
we're doing is
creating
and welcoming the safe communities for
them
we have enough of this representative
your time is up thank you please don't
support this Bill thank you very much uh
the question representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Perez did I hear you
correctly did you say that we're taking
money from public schools to push this
agenda and if so should this bill have a
fiscal note attached to it it should
I'm sure
I want to see how much they will calls
because to be honest in my town last
night what I heard they have no idea how
much it's gonna cost but we already have
issues that we can't even fix because we
don't we don't have a budget to fix them
thank you
um very cool this is quick
I haven't read that news story yet what
was what
is with the money before if the
bathrooms are already
there
what are they trying to change so they
try to put single stools so that they
can have a privacy on the school on the
bathroom so they they put dividers into
the bathrooms or build new bathrooms so
they they they have like a wolf
up and down so they can have like
privacy
representative McDonald
thank you thanks for being here again
this morning
um again with the financial aspect so
Milford would have to change their
already existing bathrooms are you aware
of other schools in the state that would
have a financial burden to passing this
I haven't heard from other schools but
to be honest what I see in my town is
enough to be very concerned because we
attack property taxes already people
already struggling to pay property taxes
and our town already struggled to uh
have money
to cover other issues that we have roles
that we have the library again you know
we have other issues that we should be
spending the money but we spending the
time and money
to push this agenda
to put and then calling kids rapers and
Colin probably other things
this is not what we need okay thank you
thank you very much other further
questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you referees I
I believe I heard a reference to
um pushing religious beliefs in regard
to this and I wasn't exactly sure what
was meant by that could you elaborate a
bit okay so
I'm going to be honest to you so last
night and last week
a member of the school board from
that is making difficult oh
a welcome transgender students in
bathrooms and lockers okay in the same
school board member
he said he's a pastor of his church
and he make comments
of his church when he was given his
sermon about
that he's pushing his agenda
religion for me because he's from the
church
and then he'd also given feel
he feel like he's wasting his time being
part of the meal for school board
and he's posting his agenda
religion agenda
thank you
for the questions
thank you very much
uh representative Jody
you
hear me
although it's not this pillow okay okay
[Music]
thank you for having me my name is Betsy
Harrington I'm from Deering
this book brings up a lot of old
feelings for me because of what I
experienced as a child and then as an
adult I was the only girl in my town who
played hockey I played as the only girl
even through high school back in the 80s
I eventually tried out for the Olympics
in women's hockey
I dealt with a lot of sex discrimination
and had many uncomfortable situations
being so far outside the norm of that
time one rule that made sense was that I
was not to change in the boy's locker
room
it was uncomfortable for me because I
had to go to the ladies room and change
on the dirty floor
I did not have appropriate space to
change or shower like the boys did the
combinations were not made
I wanted to play and those were the
boundaries I had so I stayed within them
even though they seemed unfair to me
I've never told anybody this part
as an adult I caught an adult male
recording me while I was fully naked in
the bathroom he had a tiny camera
I saw them when I had bent over between
my legs I freaked out he immediately
stomped on that camera and smashed it I
don't know what was on it I don't know
anything about that recording
I see places where I fully unclothed as
sacred my situation would be more likely
if we allowed biological men in women's
spaces it makes sense to separate
bathrooms by one's genitals which is how
the separation of these faces began we
use facilities differently if I were
menstruating I wouldn't want that known
having a male in the next stall gives no
privacy or safety once I unwrap my
products I imagine the neighboring stall
will hear and maybe even make an
uncomfortable comment this is one reason
why we are separated by our genitalia in
the first place we have different needs
and fears losing our private spaces to
people who were born men defeats the
purpose of the separation in the first
place their need for a space did not
negate ours I'm sorry but like I
experienced as a child use the bathroom
that fits your genitals even if it's
uncomfortable it's life it's the
boundaries that exist I can accept that
some discomfort is present for someone
identifying outside their biology but
the ladies in the bathroom would be
trans for that discomfort if we gave up
our space to biological men snowman is
going to live with some discomfort
should it be a few biological men or all
women who wins same-sex spaces should
remain as they were decided by your
genitals thank you thank you very much
are there questions of Miss Harrington
yes representative pettineau
thank you Mr chair and thank you Miss
Harrington for your testimony and for
taking my question
um you suggest separating people by
their genitals but what about the
instances where genitalia has been
personally I feel like if you made that
commitment to become a woman and it
you're fully surgically altered I would
be less afraid right because you're not
going to rape me in that way
so I I would say if you've made that
commitment I would be more comfortable I
think it's really for me it's about the
genitalia
thank you very much are there further
questions
thank you for coming today thanks
looking at the time good morning slash
afternoon my name is Anne-Marie Banfield
I'm a parental rights advocate in New
Hampshire I've been doing this for 20
years at least I think chairman Ladd is
probably the only person on this
committee that has known me that long
um I need to also mention that I've
never been compensated for this I do
this because what basically why you do
it you feel compelled
uh I do have written testimony but I'm
going to try to make this very brief
because I do represent thousands of
parents in the state and because
thousands of parents follow me and I
represent so many of them I'll just
bring up a couple of the issues that
they're facing with this in their own
schools I helped a parent in Northampton
over the summer whose eighth grade
daughter went and talked before the
school board saying that if they passed
the jbab policy which I'm sure you're
all familiar with that allows anybody to
use the bathroom based on gender
identity that this eighth grade student
testified before the school board saying
that the girls would not be feel
comfortable going into the restroom and
that they would hold it and that's what
I'm hearing so this is impacting girls
already
um and it's impacting boys I hear from
um parents of boys also who are just not
comfortable in a modest situation
so there's many reasons why a student
wouldn't use a restroom this is
certainly one of them but you do have
but you serve all students you serve
transgender students too in your
District so obviously there has to be
some kind of compromise and what I think
most people are comfortable with is
something like this where you have a
female restroom for the biological
females and males for biological males
and then you offer transgender students
something where they feel safe it's not
that you want to put them in an unsafe
position and I understand that and I
would agree with that but there has to
be some kind of compromise
uh this is perfectly legal to do this
also and Ian Hewitt from Cornerstone who
is the attorney that spoke in Milford
explained how this is legal I don't see
him here today but if you go back to the
Milford school board meeting you can
hear his testimony there or I'm sure
maybe he's sending it to you already
in terms of the amendment in terms of if
a mother brings a a small son into the
restroom that might be a good amendment
to to add to this as I think you brought
up what if a mother I mean if that needs
to be spelled out then you spell it out
an amendment I think that that's
appropriate other than that I think
that's the only
um let me say I want to make sure that I
covered everything
um
I oh I visit schools all the time I was
at a deliberative session last night so
as an adult adults are also going into
this restrooms sometimes with children
so do you want adult male who identifies
maybe as a female going in with a
six-year-old girl you know you got to
think about all the scenarios that could
possibly happen
thank you that's my three minutes
are there questions yes representative
Tanner thank you and thank you for
taking my question I think you have a
copy of the bill in front of you
and as I read it when it says all
multi-stall bathrooms and locker rooms
in all New Hampshire Public Schools
it seems to me that the bill is
precluding uh what you said to have a
family bathroom like they have in
airports and public places or a
gender-neutral bathroom in the school
um do you read that as
as what I'm saying that the bill is
written excludes that
I I think what you're doing is you're
looking at the situation of how do we
how do you address it at the local level
I think that's up to your local
officials and they're doing that already
so in the case of Northampton for
instance they did not adopt the jbab
policy uh and so I'm assuming that
they're that they're already using this
as part of their practice in the school
so how do you how do you serve your
transgender students if there's only one
I'm assuming that they're going to make
sure that there is maybe the teachers
launch I know I've heard of taking them
to the Teachers Lounge shoes restroom
the problem with when it's open to
anybody is the girls have started
complaining that the line forms let's
say that they say okay girls you go use
that one stall bathroom so you have a
long line of girls out there waiting to
use one restroom versus something that's
a little more logical and you ask okay
to our transgender students we're going
to offer this one rest because there's a
very small percentage in the school but
I think by by stating this then the
schools have the opportunity to be
creative on how they
um how they serve also their transgender
students if that makes sense you know
just to follow up on that so are you
saying let me get it correctly that this
bill that that if there's a bathroom in
um middle or high school it has to be
designated as a sex only bathroom like a
female bathroom or a male bathroom and
that because it says all bathrooms in
all locker rooms there can't be it it
excludes a public bathroom that's
labeled either family or neutral I I
wouldn't I don't read it that way I
would read it that the boys restroom is
the boys restroom and the girls restroom
is the girls restroom and if they have
another single stall bathroom that this
would certainly allow for something it
was multi-stall like a locker room if
they had a section of a locker room that
was family or gender neutral I I would
assume that that would have to be again
a local discussion about how to serve
those students without violating without
with making sure that these restrooms
are available to those kids because
they're already labeled if you go into
schools they're already late they're
already labeled yes
thank you for the questions thank you
okay
foreign
good morning everyone my name is Bill
Blum and I currently live in Atkinson
New Hampshire and I am here today to
speak in opposition of HB 104. I'm proud
to say that living in New Hampshire for
the last 18 years and truly now living
our state motto Live Free or Die yes HB
104 defines bathroom segregation schools
and I will not speak to direct
experience as a minor in regards to this
as I am obviously not currently living
within this age group
however I will speak as someone whose
story and authentic self will kept in a
closet for more than 30 years of my life
up until recently I was not living free
my soul was actually dying
not living my authentic life caused me
to be confrontational short-sighted and
just plain mean ultimately not being
honest and open with myself and others
about who I was cost me my job as well
as my marriage
the good news is I am still here and now
more so than ever
I am choosing not to die
unfortunately bring being present in
this building over the last few weeks
has taught me that more than half of our
state's adolescent transgender and
non-binary Community are actually
considering death
and even more alarming to me and
hopefully to you as well
more than a quarter of The Adolescents
in transgender and non-binary Community
actually attempt to complete John
Stark's statement in the obviously wrong
manner
as someone who has both used the male
and female restrooms throughout the
state I will now share some inside
information with you all both the
women's and males bathrooms have stalls
for privacy the male bathrooms have
urinals in the women's bathrooms do not
the women's bathrooms do however have
little Trash boxes in each stall for
things that do not go down the toilet
and the man's bathrooms do not and they
both have sinks too optionally use after
one uses the bathroom to stop the spread
imagine this one second it is between
periods at the Whittemore Arena during a
UNH versus Humane game
I need to use the bathroom and I go in
and I'm simply not there to look around
guess what is really going on with other
people the point is to use the restroom
for what it is intended for and to get
back to your seat or the beer line
before the game restarts
in closing
I will just leave you with one simple
question given the fact that I have had
two cups of coffee this morning
which bathroom should I use to not be a
target of discrimination and hate if I
were to Simply live free and not die in
The Sacred and historic building today
thank you all for your time thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee
not saying thank you very much for
coming you're welcome
good morning everyone my name is Don
Johnson I'm from Laconia I'm a parent
I'm a school board member
I wasn't going to speak today but I have
to say
after listening and talking to many kids
in my community
having opposite sex in a bathroom when a
woman or a man
is going in to use the facilities is
very uncomfortable many of these
students are now not choosing to use the
restrooms if they
are open to the opposite sex to go and
use the restrooms these kids are already
having enough hard time
going through puberty and everything
else and finding their own way
and to make them feel uncomfortable to
go in and leave themselves is absolutely
horrifying
I know many kids will rush home
cannot wait to get off the bus or get
out of their cars to use the restroom at
home because they are in fear of what
might happen and the embarrassment that
they may have in a locker room or in a
bathroom I applaud you please support
this bill and let's protect our kids
thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee
thank you very much
nobody knows how to say it anyway
welcome thank you
um I'm here as a mother and I am here as
a former teacher
um I have 20 years of experience in the
school system
I'm also a mother of two students who
have medical conditions and in order to
get any accommodations for them we
always had to file for 504 plans
so as far as I am concerned gender
dysphoria and transgender is a medical
condition and if a student needs
accommodations then they need to go
through these meetings and let me just
tell you if you've ever been to a 504
meeting it is not easy it is not easy to
get accommodations for any child no
matter how many pieces of documentation
you bring and how much medical
information
people talk about being harassed my
children were harassed continually
because they would ask for
accommodations from teachers who would
not give them the accommodations that
that were agreed to in the 504 plan
a simple accommodation as getting extra
time on a test or extra time to complete
homework this is not impacting any other
student in a school system other than my
child who was not given the extra time
to get an assignment in or to take a
test because of a medical condition
that is wrong
the accommodations that are going to
affect other kids those other kids need
to be taken into account I would not
feel comfortable having a male in the
bathroom with me at any time and neither
should my child or any other child be
forced to take that and be in that
situation
um
and again if there is a medical problem
then yes then those students need to
have a 504 plan they cannot come in one
day and say I'm going to go in the other
person's bathroom because I feel like
that this day that should not be allowed
there needs to be a 504 plan there needs
to be medical diagnoses and there needs
to be documentation on how that child
not being able that child being able to
go into whatever bathroom they want to
will affect their Educational Learning
and I don't see that affecting a child's
learning ability and that is not part of
the children's curriculum
so please protect the girls please
protect the bathrooms thank you very
much I apologize for the I didn't yell
that's all right your manuscript's
wonderful thank you that of a teacher uh
thank you and thank you for your
testimony If This Were to pass do you
see it preventing these IEP or five or
four meetings from accommodating
transgender youth students that is going
to need to go to the federal because
these are both federal laws so you would
have to look into seeing what the
federal law and there are
um different requirements in order to
meet the accommodations so my one child
who has a medical condition she did not
qualify for an IAP because she didn't
meet the standards
so there are standards within those
programs as to whether or not
accommodation meets and will be allowed
thank you thank you that's a good
question accommodations and
modifications yes it's at the federal
level
uh further questions
thank you no Pam
foreign
members of the committee I speak today
as chair of the building code review
board and respectful opposition to this
bill not because I particularly disagree
with the premise but based on a general
position that amendments to the building
code should be at the code level and not
written at a law
I'd also note that in my professional
career I've been dealing with this issue
for many years now the current New
Hampshire building code addresses this
issue where the 2018 International
building and plumbing codes which are
the model codes that the state building
code is based on prohibit
require most multi-fiction facilities to
be single sex
the bcrb is currently reviewing and
holding public hearings on the 2021
International codes where the model
codes will in fact permit multi-stall
facilities to be all gender these are
sometimes referred to as the European
style restrooms
if things stay on schedule and the codes
are approved the 2021 codes would go
into effect by the summer of 2024.
in the past gentle or not so gentle
pressure from the legislature has
resulted in amendments through our board
reflecting the desired technical outcome
while preserving the right for designers
Builders owners and users to request
local relay from code Provisions for
special circumstances changes in opinion
by interested parties or federal
requirements once written into law no
relief or modification is available
failing the provision of the desired
Amendment the legislature still through
our board the legislature would still
have time to revisit this issue before
the current codes expire
I'd like to refer to what I think of as
RSA 0.0 I'm speaking facetiously but
that refers to the law of unintended
consequences
we have three
I'll call them code Provisions written
into our RSA 155a currently biomass
boilers log homes and arc fault circuit
interrupters two of those three are out
of date and ready for repeal because
they've gottens fail they've been they
just have been out of date so I would
caution you about writing this kind of a
rule in the law things change very
quickly
I'd also mention that there are other
occupancies where this is probably of
Interest summer camps and public
swimming pools come to mind same kinds
of issues
so I request that you consider defeating
this bill we would look forward to
working with interested parties to
develop the appropriate amendments to
the State Building Code and lastly if
you do pass this bill I would strongly
recommend that it be located in RSA 155a
were amendments to the building code are
located so that the folks that deal with
building construction can find it thank
you very much thank you very much are
there questions representative uh try
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh is there a
difference
is there a difference
um because public schools are
government schools that rather than
private State summer camps for example
the code deals with occupancies and
schools in general below the 12th grade
are group E occupancy so it's
independent of whether their government
or uh public or private uh if you look
at things like public swimming pools
they could be at a hotel which would not
come under the group b Provisions but
for our purposes
I would say pretty much the schools
you're talking about are all group E
there may be some exceptions at the
lower end of the age bracket follow-ups
yes
given what you've heard from the
testimony here is could you give us an
idea what a path for compromise might
look like if you sat down with us
years ago I worked with representatives
from the Yale law school who were on the
sort of Leading Edge of this whole
discussion and it's pretty clear that
the that the compromise if you will
solution as one of the other speakers
mentioned is single-user restrooms
many schools are putting a lot of them
in now because mostly because of
bullying
so that allows you to preserve the
multi-stall traditional restroom
arrangement in schools and provide a
sufficient number of single user
restrooms which people may want to use
for a number of different reasons that
costs money there's no question about it
further questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
that testimony um you mentioned that
your organization has worked with the
legislature before sometimes we utilize
gentle means sometimes not so gentle
means to persuasion
would passing this bill not qualify as a
not so gentle means of persuasion to get
this done it it certainly would get to
the heart of the matter the the problem
we've had is when we write
prescriptive code requirements into law
there's no room to maneuver the things
that we haven't thought about today
can't be dealt with out in the field and
then we've got a law that's just that
much harder to get revised later
so we just that's why we have building
codes and we don't write every word of
the building code into a law
there are lots of circumstances that
come up that we probably don't
understand sitting here today so
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair would you be so kind
as to email your testimony to the
committee it's very helpful I have it
written I've done enough editing that
I'll send it to the clerk this afternoon
uh earlier on representative Tanner
asked a question of one of the speakers
and did you have the bill in front of
you
uh yes okay thank you I'm looking at
line three the first word of the line
says all
so from your building code expertise
with that would you
presume then and that means every single
bathroom
one of the things to be careful of and
this gets societal issues as overlapping
with construction issues is that this
would apply to existing as well as new
construction clearly that can be dealt
with through the codes but it needs to
be dealt with explicitly right typically
the building code only applies when a
building is being constructed or altered
okay new construction
or alterations right right yeah may I
ask one more go ahead thank you
um so with this from a building code
perspective uh eliminate uh gender
in group e
and I
forgive me I think this this refers to
public schools and Charters so I'd make
it clear that it applies to private
schools right uh
it would it would eliminate all gender
if you will multi-stall right fixtures
okay thank you thank you Mr chair
thank you are there further questions
thank you you're welcome
Therese Grinnell Loudon New Hampshire
um a couple of points I feel like every
human being really just wants to be
understood right and we all want to be
respected and we all want to be loved
for who we are so you've got two
opposing kind of perceptions on this
argument as the mother of an eight and a
nine year old little boys I question
their maturity to know that oh now you
can go to whichever bathroom you want
that they would do it and our teachers
wouldn't have to be starting to manage
Behavior that's silly inappropriate body
touch all of that nonsense right like I
want my teachers to be teaching my boys
to read
um I love this idea of a single use
stall available I think most schools
have them at this point That Could Be
unisex if they don't I think we could
probably put something in place where
you know from
you know the top of the hour to the half
point of the hour is you know this
particular bathroom is unisex but if the
females I guess my point is what we're
doing if you take a step back as we're
saying one person is saying I want to be
respected that based on how I feel my
gender is I want to be able to go to use
that gender's bathroom and then you have
others that are saying well
I want to use a bathroom that only
affiliates with my genitalia so how do
we respect both groups
right without disparaging the other
group
so we either go to the European style
where everyone just goes wherever they
want to go and then we just kind of
change our culture which we've had here
or we look at what are the ramifications
of that for like an eight and nine year
old again going in and thinking that
they can go and
you know watch the girls and the girls
can play and now the teachers are in
there having to tell everyone what's
appropriate so I think there's a lot of
question here but I think there's some
easy solutions and I think you know if
we have the multi-stall bathrooms kind
of be generically just like the locker
rooms so you don't have people feeling
uncomfortable that they're changing in
front of the opposite sexual genitalia
but then you also then have
accommodations for people who are
feeling as though they have male
genitalia but they feel they affiliate
with the female
gender and vice versa that we have a
space for them will that cost money it
might but that's where our culture is
going and at the end of the day everyone
needs to be respected and everyone needs
to be loved and everyone needs to be
understood and that's what I'm hearing
from both sides I would love to see a
study done on how many of our public
schools in New Hampshire have a
multi-use bathroom because I believe
most of them do
and so are we really creating a bunch of
division and media and what's going on
in Milford and everyone getting upset
with each other or can we just come up
with a simple solution that respects
both perceptions
and that's what I would recommend this
group try to do thank you very much are
there any questions from the committee
now see thank you very much
his position
okay thank you
hi thank you Mr chair and committee
members my name again is Louise fencer
I'm from Concord New Hampshire and today
I am actually
um reading the testimony of Abby Maxwell
who's a parent from Hopkinton New
Hampshire so
um and she writes dear members of the
House Education committee I am writing
to you to strongly oppose HB 104. my
daughter is 10 years old she loves to
play the flute and cello to read to play
Minecraft and to ski this year through
the school ski program she got to ski
with the school friend and her friend's
father I thought they would go off alone
but the father asked me to join them he
had a let's go Brandon sticker on his
helmet and so I assumed that perhaps he
viewed things differently than I did
however I agreed to ski together we
brought up the lift it turned out that
we had both grown up in the very same
small New Hampshire town and we had both
worked at the same ski area as teenagers
he had graduated 10 years ahead of me
but we had many of the same teachers it
was so fun to talk and laugh with him
about our school in town it was like we
had a deep shared understanding of each
other and where we came from in the
world I skied with him and our daughters
a few more times throughout the year and
I kept thinking about the experience did
he know my daughter was transgender of
course there's no way to tell looking at
her but she is out at school and we
publicly advocate for her rights year
after year it's not hard to find out
what if he did know I don't know how
this man votes or why though I can make
some assumptions still I have to believe
that if he knew about these bills if he
knew that this bill would require him to
look at my daughter and tell her that
she was not allowed to use the bathroom
he would never stand for it maybe he
would have in the past I don't know but
now he has been forced to see our shared
Humanity he has held my daughter's hand
and helped her to stand up on the ski
Trail he has asked her if her leg hurt
if her hands were too cold he has cared
for her which means he knows how utterly
cruel and senseless it would be to tell
her that she cannot go to the girls
bathroom
this is my third year in a row fighting
these bills my husband and I are so
tired we are working so hard to protect
our sleep and our mental health and
these assaults so that we can still give
our daughter a good happy childhood it's
not easy we love our home yet with every
one of these bills we wonder when we
will have to leave
obviously we cannot live in a state
where our daughter is ostracized for who
she comes to the world as I have to
believe it is not your aim to harm
children and families in this way I pray
that you recognize our shared humanity
and stop these bills thank you Abby
Maxwell
and I just want to quickly thank you
very much you're just out of time am I
okay very good are you getting questions
from the committee yes representative
Belcher yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
that testimony
um you had said that you were
um reading this testimony from uh
somebody you know and I receive the same
testimony
in my email I did read it because I do
try to keep up with testimony that comes
in but I was curious because I heard you
say something different he said he had a
let's go Brandon's sticker on his helmet
I assume that he meant that he voted for
laws that harm my child I don't believe
that's what you had said I'm wondering
did you modify the testimony at all or
was it I didn't intentionally modify the
testimony so I was just curious that
wasn't my intention so let me look here
if I did that it was unintentional thank
you very much yeah okay any further
questions thank you for the correction
thank you okay thank you thank you uh
yeah I'm gonna see that cards right
thank you chairman Laden to the
committee uh my name is Sam Hawkins I'm
the public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
non-profit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy
on behalf of Nami New Hampshire I'm here
today in opposition of HP 104.
lgbtq individuals especially those who
are transgender gender non-conforming
are at an elevated risk for experiencing
anxiety and depression and are more
likely to consider an attempt suicide
than their heterosexual or cisgender
peers according to the Trevor Project in
2022 39 of LGBT lgbtq youth in New
Hampshire seriously considered suicide
and 10 percent attempted it Beyond New
Hampshire a 2020 study in the Journal of
interpersonal violence found that 82
percent of transgender individuals
across the US and Canada have considered
suicide and 40 percent have attempted it
the jiv study found that internalized
stigma emotional familial neglect and a
lack of school belonging made a
significant contribution to suicidality
for transgender individuals this data
supports the premise that access to
Identity affirming spaces is one of the
most significant ways we can promote
trans well-being
this is from the Trevor Project report
but open representation the presence of
other lgbtq people in a welcoming
environment have been identified as some
of the qualities that make a space of
affirming for lgbtq youth at New
Hampshire these spaces are few and far
between as only 47 percent of lgbtq
Youth in New Hampshire consider their
school to be an affirming space and only
18 percent believe their community at
large to be very accepting
this bill could only serve to further
restrict access to affirming spaces for
Trans youth School a crucial and
developmental everyday environment would
become a place where a child can no
longer Fully live in accordance with
their identity
where these numbers of affirming
environments decreases we expect anxiety
depression and suicide will likely
increase
urges the committee to recommend
inexpeding to legislate for HP 104.
thank you very much are there questions
representative penernal
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Hawkins
um
certainly we're concerned about people's
mental health and high risk for suicide
but
um your statistic that 39 of lgbtq Youth
um seriously consider suicide do we have
a percentage of Youth who are lgbtq
because this would be a percentage of a
percentage yes thank you for that
question I do not have that number but I
can look into it and get back to you
yeah
further questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for the
testimony
um I wanted to ask you
you you uh suggested that these
affirming spaces would be very important
toward reducing harms to transgender
youth would you agree that parental
involvement is also an extremely
important
item in in that parental involvement in
their lives and and what's going on with
them
uh thank you for the question I would
believe that uh supportive parenting is
incredibly important to transgender
children as seen by the grv study uh
emotional familial neglect impact
suicidality thank you I and the reason I
asked that is because when I go to the
Trevor Project website the very first
thing that comes up
is an indicator that says to anybody
visiting his website click here to
quickly scrub your history and get out
of this website so your parents can't
see you're on this website I'm wondering
if this is something that is not meshing
thank you for the follow-up uh I mean I
believe that I I said that uh
it is the familial neglect that is
harming these children these children
who would not want these their parents
to see them accessing the site are the
parents that are neglecting them
thank you thank you for the questions
from the committee not seeing thank you
very much thank you have a good day lily
O'Brien
good morning good morning my name is
Lily and I'm a junior at Plymouth
Regional High School in Plymouth and I'm
here to testify in opposition to HB 104.
I have attended New Hampshire public
schools for my entire educational career
I've also played and participated in a
number of sports where we do in fact use
the locker rooms I can say with the
utmost certainty that I have never
wished the bathrooms or locker rooms to
be mandated as same-sex
growing up in a world of advancing
technology where practically any
information is at the touch of my
fingertips I've grown accustomed to
learning and hearing about current
events immediately as they arise
likewise I've heard of countless pieces
of policy and legislation like this one
requiring same-sex bathrooms and locker
rooms in schools of messaging that
typically Falls along the lines of
protecting our children I ask this which
children are we protecting and who are
we protecting from most students like
myself give no attention to their peers
in the bathroom or locker rooms and
instead go about minding their own
business in fact the protection children
need while at school lies far from being
found inside the bathrooms there are
however a number of people that would
benefit from maintaining neutral
bathrooms transgender and non-binary
individuals that face discrimination and
dysphoria in their day-to-day lives find
relief in neutral bathrooms that allow
them to use the restroom in peace
outlining a separation like this bill
intends to do forces these students and
faculty to unwillingly put themselves in
a situation that may cause them
increased dysphoria or anxiety
school should be a place where all
students and staff no matter their
identity feel safe and accepted it
should not be a place where something as
simple as going to the bathroom is
mandated and separated based on sex
where they feel unsafe and unwanted in a
place of privacy my transgender friends
simply want access to a bathroom that
affirms their identity transgender
students and staff using bathrooms that
affirm their gender are not threats to
Public Safety they are not dangerous and
should not be dehumanized by the subject
of bathroom debate
I have never felt uncomfortable or
unsafe sharing a locker room with my
transgender peers I have however felt
incredibly unsafe sharing a space with
people who push a hateful narrative
against their transgender peers hidden
behind claims of safety when it's
stemmed from a place of hatred and
refusal of acceptance take a moment to
listen to your students who are here
today telling you what we want someone
else's identity does not affect you and
it certainly does not affect you in the
bathroom or locker room places where
personal privacy are at its highest
where someone chooses to use the
facilities in a school should not be a
topic of discussion which is why
important implore you to oppose hb104 we
should be acting in favor of all
students no matter their identity to
ensure that their schools are a place
where they feel welcomed and accepted
thank you thank you Lily do you have
written testimony there yes so if you
can provide the clerk a copy that would
be appreciated are there any uh comments
or questions questions from the
committee
yes representative Woodcock it's just a
call I just want to thank you we're very
well presented developed uh statement
thank you
good morning welcome thank you my name
is Abby again I'm a senior Bedford High
School I also stand as the student
representative on the school board
however I'm here representing myself
um I'm here to testify an opposition of
house bill 104. this bill is clearly
anti-trans legislation targeted children
HB 104 threatens people's access to
facilities that affirm their gender this
bill would make it harder to have
neutral bathrooms that provide more
options for people of all genders for
example a place for non-binary people to
use the bathroom in peace and many New
Hampshire school buildings neutral
unisex bathrooms are usually not very
accessible and have one single stall
trans students and School staff using
bathrooms that affirm their gender
identity are not threats to Public
Safety
the bill pushes a narrative that will
only worsen what are often difficult
circumstances for Trans young people I'm
currently in high school and can say
that I've never once walked into a
school bathroom and wondered if every
person who has the same Parts as me
because it doesn't matter bodies are
bodies and where that body chooses to
use the bathroom has zero effect on me
if anything I want my peers to be able
to use the bathroom that feels the best
of them so they can focus on school and
friends and not worry about where
they're going to relieve themselves
this bill doesn't protect anyone
all it does is feed into the anti-trans
rhetoric that is plaguing the country
right now
I am more scared of CIS white men than
I've ever been of a trans or queer
person
I urge you committee to please shut down
this bill it's time to listen to the use
of the Youth of New Hampshire
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions from the committee
thank you come for coming today do you
have a written testimony oh who
representative Damon you had your hand
up
thank you Mr chair I just want to thank
you for your honest direct testimony
thank you yes I I do could you provide
it I'll hand it over yep thank you uh
and I'm a junior at Bedford High School
which is a public school I'm here to
testify in opposition to Bill HB 104
speaking to my trans peers on this topic
many of them wanted to share what they
think I've spoken to a variety of people
trans women trans men and gender
non-conforming people for their safety I
will be keeping their names Anonymous
unless they express the desire to have
their information known
according to student a aged 18 quote a
lot of trans kids get harassed in
gendered bathrooms regardless of if they
go to the one people think they should
go to or the one they want to go to it
results in a lot of them just not going
to the bathroom the entire duration of
school which is not good for physical
health end quote student B-17 identifies
as non-binary quote removing genderless
bathrooms makes it uncomfortable for me
to use the bathroom at school I feel
pressured to pick a side so to speak
non-jittered bathrooms can also also
offer safe spaces for people with
anxiety or sensory disorders to just
have two minutes of Peace holding in
waste unnecessarily can lead to larger
health problems so it's necessary that
non-gendered bathrooms are structured
within Public Schools students end quote
student C is 18 quote well after being
shouted at for using the women's toilets
I was terrified to go back I had to use
the disabled ones if I had used the
men's toilets I would feel personally at
risk for my physical health and mental
health
personally if there were free toilets I
wouldn't care but if you force me back
into the men's bathrooms it would
destroy me I would not be able to go to
the toilet anywhere I went and that
would really affect everything I'm not
going to put myself at risk for just
wanting to pee end quote Logan 19 is a
college student who has attended Public
Schools his whole life quote as a legal
adult who is medically slash legally
socially transitioned I have the
privilege to enter men's restrooms with
no hold back still I have to be on the
defense taking note of my surroundings
knowing an exit knowing who saw me enter
and could follow me inside keeps me safe
I've actually gotten UTIs from holding
in my pee because the men's bathrooms
are such a threat this safety plan is
essential for transgender people the
terror and anxiety I felt when I was
younger because I didn't have the
advantages I do now was deliver
deliberating
in Oklahoma end quote in Oklahoma it is
currently illegal for people to use a
bathroom that does not align with their
sex student D is a high schooler in
Oklahoma
quote in my state it's not okay for me
to live without shame I don't think it's
possible to live without shame because
I'm trans because of the state law we
trans youth in public schools
specifically are targeted and banned
because of state law we oh sorry are
from using the bathroom of our preferred
gender and instead are forced to use our
birth given gender assigned bathroom we
have no genderless bathrooms and it not
only isolates us further but causes
distress in the school about our
existence we Face ridicule for being
trans daily and constantly hear others
talk down about us the banishment of
genderless bathrooms only furthers the
negativity and stigma we face in a
public school daily end quote thank you
very much for your testimony are there
questions from the committee
representative Tanner
um thank you and thank you for your for
your testimony and and being brave here
thank you very much if you have a copy
could we have a copy of your testimony
good afternoon chairman Ladd and
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is Emma savini I am
the children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a non-partisan non-profit
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates for the health and
well-being of all Granite Staters
um we are in here in opposition of House
Bill 104 because Transit 9 binary youth
have the best mental health outcomes
when they're able to live according to
their preferred gender identity
um and this bill would prohibit their
ability to do so
um I think we all envision a New
Hampshire where our children are able to
freely Express themselves live in safety
and uh thrive in an environment that
caters to their well-being
and live without the burdens of their
Mental Health
however in just the past year as you
heard from many other folks
lgbtq youth especially have been
suffering from severe mental health
complications
um and
uh many have seriously considered
suicide
these statistics are Stark reminders
that we as a state can do better for our
children
um House Bill 104 is in direct
opposition to this shared goal of
creating a safe space for our children
and encouraging and proper Mental Health
um when children are able to socially
transition
um and live to their lives as their
preferred gender their mental health
outcomes are on par with children who
don't identify as lgbtqia Plus
um something as simple as affirming
their gender identities with allowing
them to use the bathroom of their choice
um has been shown to improve mental
health so this bill we would ask that
you oppose it as just a clear reminder
to everyone that we stand in support of
our children's mental health and we are
supportive in an affirming state for all
children thank you very much for your
testimony are there any questions from
the committee
now see any thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman my name is David
Trumbull I'm from where I posed this
bill for three reasons first is that
transgender rights and safety can
co-exist there's a report that was put
out by four groups including the
transgender center for the national
Center for transgender equality that
addressed this this very specific topic
it says non-discrimination laws that
explicitly protect lgbtq people have
been enacted in 19 States and more than
200 municipalities with no increase in
public safety incidents and this the
report is called bathroom safety
non-discrimination laws and bathroom ban
laws so you can accomplish both
objectives you can have access to
bathrooms for transgender people and
Public Safety second is human rights
lgbtq rights should be considered as
just basic human rights transgender
people need to use the bathroom like
everybody else and should not be shamed
into not being able to go to the
bathroom so an entire day of school you
might wonder how many people were
talking about the UCLA School of Law
Williams Institute this past year in
2022 said that there are 1.6 million
people who identify as transgender in
the United States that's more people
than the entire State of New Hampshire
they say that 1.4 four percent of people
age 13 to 17 identify as transgender and
that's not even counting non-binary
people this study says that in New
Hampshire just identified openly there's
over 700 students between the ages of 13
and 17 and obviously there's many more
who don't answer yes to these questions
so 700 students just to remind you when
we debated the EFA accounts there's
three thousand of those 25 percent of
them were brand new people going from a
public school to a private school that's
700 people so all the discussion on efas
was for about 700 people we're talking
about 700 students at least who can't
use a bath if you pass this kind of Bill
would have a hard time using the
bathroom of their choice rather than
their sexual identification at Birth the
third thing is
the law educates you have a choice to
either pass a law that's based on fear
and lack of acceptance or you have a
chance to Pace pass a law that's based
upon tolerance and understanding in
human rights the law speaks volumes to
the people of the state and if you pass
this law you're telling people be afraid
of transgender people even though the
original sponsor said he didn't mean it
to feel that way that's going to be the
way the law will be perceived by people
and that will just put back the March
towards progress for everybody to be
treated equally in our society and the
testimony you got from the gentleman
who's in with the building code said
they're coming up with a new code that's
going to work on multi-stall uh neutral
bathrooms this bill would clearly
preclude that from happening in the
schools and the questioners have pointed
it out thank you very much for your
testimony you're welcome thank you very
much a written testimony I'll send
something in okay thank you very much
match David
um
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Michael O'Brien uh
testified before I'm with party
strategies um I'm a lobbyists both for
American Federation of teachers also for
glad and ACLU
um however really intestifying uh for
myself here I just want to share a quick
story
um that my wife reminded me up you're
gonna you probably hear me talk about
her quite a bit when I get up here she's
a high school teacher at the end of last
year
um a transgender girl went and used the
boys bathroom because it was the
bathroom she felt of least resistance
within the school to be able to use two
boys dumped buckets of water on her head
and used homophobic slurs against her
inside the school inside of the bathroom
that this bill would mandate that she
continues to use
for Trans students it can be
as we've heard just a terrifying to have
to use the bathroom that you don't feel
comfortable in this story breaks my
heart
um as my wife tells it to me she knew
the student and taught this student so
just wanted to tell you a story that
happened
six months ago of a student here in New
Hampshire who faced just a horrible
situation because she used the bathroom
um that she again felt was the one the
school wants her to use this bathroom of
sort of least resistance for her happy
thank you any questions from the
committee uh representative Lakers
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um a school having single stall
genderless bathrooms solve the problem
obviously being a CIS male and without
being a trans person myself it's a hard
question for me to answer only to say
that we should be welcoming people as to
who they are and shouldn't be putting
them into different places because they
we perceive them to be different and so
I think what we should be doing is
looking to welcome everyone as who they
are and that's the best case scenario
thank you for the questions from the
committee
good afternoon and ah thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Sarah
Smith
um and I I post this uh bill and I have
three things to say about it
um
uh first of all uh the the bill says
that
um
at the end that shall be same-sex but
the bill never defines sex and so it's
um to me
deliberately vague
um so if I Define sex I say well okay so
somebody's sex identified on their
driver's license on their birth
certificate and how they have identified
that that would be how I would interpret
same-sex but I hear people here
interpreting same sex purely on the
biological birth of the of the
individual
um so this is deliberately vague
um as as a and that's a problem right
there how do you how do you interpret
that
um
and uh you know also erases and intersex
people or non-binary people
um I was struck by the testimony of
about
um often as as the previous gentleman
mentioned based on fear
um of women uh expressing fear about
what something that their privacy in the
bathroom
um and I wanted to share a little
incident with you to put in a different
kind of perspective I'm a retired school
teacher and
uh we had a problem for a while against
taking kids a long time to go to the
bathroom and uh one of our bathrooms was
it's an old school and you know they've
been remodeled badly a long time ago but
we never had any money to fix it so
there were really some huge gaps between
the door and this and the side of the
stall and yeah you could see in and the
girls we were embarrassed by that just
by the fact of other girls being able to
look in and they refused to use that
stall so it would take a long time to go
to the bathroom because they they were
only two other stalls to use so this
this is not an issue about whether it's
uh there's a a transgender individual or
anything there was an issue because
there was not enough privacy between
girls and this is to me is what this
issue is talking about now I'm in favor
of the So eventually it
um people you know were like oh this is
ridiculous finally they came along and
said well we'll just put another we're
just going to fix this door we'll put a
little strip there so there's not a gap
and that was it that was it that was the
problem so uh and I and I see this in a
lot of bathrooms now that are you know
fully doored and completely private
um that's the issue that we're talking
about we're trying to ban a certain
class of people
to fix an issue that is not of their
making and
and we're also trying to ban People
based on behavior that we don't very
much thank you are there any questions
yes representative Belcher thank you Mr
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
that testimony I have I have some degree
of familiarity with the background on
the concept of gender as a social
construct going back to youth Butler I
don't know that I've ever heard anyone
argue that sex itself is a social
construct or that can be changed or is
not firm and it seemed like you were
suggesting that that sex was a vague
term can you can you elaborate on that
yes I I would say yes that the term sex
refers to a number of characteristics
and I'm not a physician I can't
elaborate on them I could get you a
better elaboration of that but there are
a number of characteristics that
determine sex and sometimes it is not
easy to determine sex based on those
characteristics so
um so that is a really deep question
that needs to be gone into because uh
uh it is not it's not a question of of
uh genitalia for instance or chromosomes
there are a variety of different ways
that people present themselves
um and so if you if you want to you need
to develop a background in some of the
the medical issues that that come up I
could have
um
you could have someone I know who's a
physician who could explain to you the
different ways that sex are determined
thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you very much
good afternoon good afternoon my name is
Diana George
um I oppose this bill
I don't have a written testimony because
I wasn't planning on testifying today
however I'm a mother
parent of a transgender 22 year old who
came out at age 15.
we didn't we had no idea my husband and
I but we chose to support and love our
child
as any parent should
and he is thriving he's a student and
he looks
you know
so there would be it would be very
awkward for him to be using
a female
or yes female gender bathroom
so I think that that also needs to be
yeah and what this other woman just said
there are intersex people
there are people with XX chromosomes who
look male
um
also
if a man I work at the women's prison
if a man wants to get into a bathroom to
rape you they're not going to pretend to
be a transgender person that's just
silly
um
I'm just so tired of these of these
discriminatory bills it's it's just so
exhausting for the trans people and for
the parents
and this is going on all around the
country it's a huge attack on us as
families as we're good people we're
um
foreign
also by using a single stall bathroom a
separate bathroom for Trans
and non-binary people it's it's a form
of outing them
if they happen to pass
as they say going to that bathroom
because they're forced to makes other
people know that they are Transit and
they may not want people to know that
they may not want their parents to know
that
because their parents may be
abusive and not supportive
so please consider all of this when
you're thinking about this bill and
considering this bill
thank you thank you very much for coming
today are there further questions from
the committee thank you
okay
hello my name is Lane
I am like any other teenager I enjoy
hanging out with friends and family I
study hard so I can do well in school I
love playing soccer skiing hiking I also
happen to be a transgender girl
being trans has been a lifelong journey
as soon as I could talk I literally told
my parents I am a girl my brain did not
align with my body parts and that's just
the way I was born
it hasn't been easy for me
um but when I socially transitioned at
the end of fifth grade it was the best
day of my life because I could finally
be myself
I'm so grateful for the level of support
that I have received and it's made me
the proud trans girl that stands before
I use a ghost bathroom in locker rooms
without an issue no one has ever made me
feel uncomfortable nor have I ever made
others feel that way everyone values
privacy
to suggest that somehow we are a threat
is not factual end it is fear-mongering
trans kids are kids we're students who
want to be able to go to the bathroom
like anyone else
using a bathroom using a bathroom
comfortably is a key part of thriving in
a school environment
and singling out trans kids by
preventing us from using these bathrooms
is not fair
please have some compassion
send this bill and others like it have
been brought forward it's clear that my
mere existence makes some people feel
uncomfortable
there's nothing I can do about that
however I will say that one person's
discomfort should not Trump another
person's civil rights in this case the
ability to learn in a safe environment
or to be able to participate with
everyone else without being singled out
please do not attack Trends youth I'm
missing school today to be here because
I think it's important that you see that
we are people just like you who deserve
to be a hath who deserve to be healthy
happy and accepted thank you thank you
very much are there questions from the
committee
thank you very much
thank you chairman Ladd thank you
committee for hearing my testimony my
name is Chris Churchill and I'm an
attorney with a glbtq legal Advocates
and Defenders glad
um I live and work in Boston but I'm a
New Hampshire licensed attorney and I do
a lot of litigation and legislative work
here
um today's transgender students are our
future neighbors co-workers teachers
leaders our parents and friends we need
them we need them and all other young
people to be really successful adults
that's why we provide public education
in the first place these young people
are integral to our community and
they're entitled to equal educational
opportunities this bill doesn't say what
the sponsor says it says there's no
mention of chromosomes or genitalia in
the text of the bill at all a bathroom
is a facility and a bathroom doesn't
have a sex or a gender the intent behind
this bill according to the prime
sponsor's testimony is for this
committee to vote on a bill about people
in other words it's about excluding
certain people from facilities uh and as
the building expert testified this bill
is not the right vehicle for excluding
people from facilities
uh the building conflict with New
Hampshire State and and federal
non-discrimination laws which prohibit
discrimination on the basis of sex
gender identity and transgender status
um
it's also a violation of the guarantee
of the state and federal constitutions
which guarantee equal protection on of
the laws by singling out transgender
students and treating them differently
from other students this bill is
unlawful and unconstitutional
many courts have addressed where um kind
of address cases where a transgender
student was excluded from them using the
bathroom of their gender Gavin Grimm for
instance was a transgender boy who used
the boys bathroom in his high school
without a problem until a small group of
parents complained Gavin's School
buckled under pressure from this
minority number of parents after a long
legal battle that lasted many years the
federal court of appeals for the fourth
circuit ruled in favor of Gavin's right
to use the restroom and Gloucester
County School District in Virginia had
to pay 1.3 million dollars this is one
of many cases that have come out of uh
come up the same way costing school
districts Nationwide millions of dollars
with one outlier case from the 11th
circuit going the other direction Gavin
was not a threat to any other student
he's a kid who needed to use the
bathroom at school just like any other
kid and when a transgender boy like
Gavin goes through every aspect of his
life as a boy he's not going to fit in
where he's when he's in the boys
bathroom he's going to feel the
isolating stigma
um if he's forced to use a single user
restroom against as well of course that
option of a single user restroom should
be available to any student who wants to
use a single user restroom and I really
do applaud school districts for building
more of them to provide students with
more options to make them comfortable
but a sense of belonging is something
that can't be denied to any student
based on a core aspect of that person's
identity it's unlawful and it's cruel to
exclude transgender students from using
the restroom like anyone else
I'm happy to take questions thank you
very much does the judge cut you off
like that too no they typically now are
any questions from the committee
representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much for uh for joining us this
afternoon Chris could you talk with us a
little bit um about
um maybe uh instances of violence that
may have occurred between or when when a
trans student is using a restroom that
that doesn't conform to their to their
um to their Identity or their preference
um their identity and also instance of
violence that may have been reported as
a result of um of of trans-inclusive uh
policy that's a really good question and
thank you for asking our repellent out
so um in 2018 there was a first study
that was released ever to my knowledge
about
um and you know studying whether there's
been any increase
um in instances of violence in restrooms
uh related to a change in bathroom
policy and that was a study done in
Massachusetts and it showed that there
was no increase in any incidence of
violence against anybody in bathrooms as
a result of the existence as a result of
the presence of transgender people or
the right of transgender people to be uh
to use the bathroom consistent with
their gender identity and so um since
then there have been other studies that
have come to the same conclusion there's
no evidence that there's any increase in
any risk of violence as a result of
policies that allow people to use the
restroom consistent with their gender
identity so that answer your question
thank you very much uh represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to follow up on
that question
um and he spoke to as far as studies go
as far as rates but are you aware of any
incidents
um I'm not up on all the incidents that
might have happened that involved
transgender people or non-transgender
people over the many years right
um before there was ever an issue of uh
transgender people you know using
bathrooms in public spaces because there
wasn't high levels of transgender
visibility in the past uh there were
incidents where uh where people would
would perpetrate violence against people
of the same sex or people of the of a
different sex in bathrooms so it's
always been the case it's always been
true it continues to happen to this day
I have no doubt uh and there's been no
increase in incidents of it so
um you know if you want to talk about
anecdotal incidents of violence um you
know I'm not the right person to be
asking that question thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Tanner
is there
um thank you for taking my question
are there many instances of transgender
people or of non-transgender people
pretending to be transgender people
committing assault
that's a really good question I'm not
familiar with any incidents where a
person has pretended to be transgender
for the purpose of uh assaulting
somebody in a bathroom but I will add
that it is possible just like it's
possible for a non-transgender person it
is possible for a transgender person to
commit an act of violence that's you
know that is an inevitability of life
that there are people who will commit
acts of violence and it's super
important to keep our bathrooms safe in
our Public Schools nobody should be
questioning that that is absolutely a
number one priority but what we know
from the research that's been done is
that the existence of or the presence of
transgender people does not change the
rates of violence in those in those
spaces
thank you very much are there further
questions from the committee
representative Woodcock thank you thank
you for taking my question do you know
of any cases in New Hampshire that have
been filed that prohibit or limit
transgender students from using uh the
bathroom of their choice
um as of right now I have not heard of
any any schools that are excluding
transgender people from using the
bathroom and if I did I would want to
know more about it because I would
consider I would consider you know um
working with with a family who is
affected by it to to address the issue
with the school I did attend a Milford
School District board meeting and gave a
presentation to the school board because
that school board was considering a
change in policy which they ended up
ultimately including last night
rejecting that potential change in
policy would have prevented transgender
students from using the restroom
consistent with their gender identity
but to this day the school district in
Milford has not adopted a change in
policy and continues to allow trans kids
to use the bathroom in Maine
um this goes back to 2014 so our
neighbor in Maine the Supreme Court
there heard a case ultimately where my
organization had filed a lawsuit against
a school district because of excluding a
transgender girl from using the bathroom
from using the girl's bathroom and the
main Supreme Court ruled that that was a
violation of of course a violation of
the state's law against discrimination
against transgender people
um and the plaintiff in that case Nicole
means is now a successful movie star so
it just goes to show that when uh you
know you remove the obstacles that in
achieving a good education people thrive
so thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you representative
representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so you answered that
there were no cases of non-trans people
pretending to get into to access
bathrooms but
if it's not a same-sex bathroom why
would there be a need to pretend there
wouldn't be any barrier to either sex
I'm not sure that I follow your question
thank you
you don't have to give a reason to go
into a bathroom if it's not gender
exclusive or sex exclusive
right I'm not I'm actually not familiar
with uh you know I I heard some students
testifying about uh about bathrooms in
their schools and then then what I
gathered from from the testimony was
that that anyone can go into whatever
bathroom that they want I don't know if
that's a school policy anywhere in New
Hampshire I'm not I'm not up on any
school policies that would that would
that would say exactly that so um as far
as far as I'm aware there are policies
that separate bathrooms based on sex and
um and also that those policies do not
exclude transgender people or gender
non-conforming people from using the
bathroom that makes them most
comfortable which is still separated
based on sex it's just not excluding
trans people
um so does that answer your question at
all because I I'm still not sure if I'm
catching one yeah and I think I'm go I
mean I follow up no we're gonna move on
we'll talk later uh represent Damon
foreign
could you share with the committee and
in writing would be fine
um the rsas that this bill is in
conflict with in New Hampshire so we
have that for our executive session
please yeah um but absolutely but 138
I'm calling 38 and 138 colon 39 those
two rsas are the school of
non-discrimination
um you know statutes that speak most
directly to this issue but there are a
host of other statutes that are involved
um so yeah I'm happy to follow up in the
committee with laying it out I didn't
prepare written testimony because I
wanted to hear what was being discussed
here before I wrote something up for you
I wanted to be useful so I'm going to do
that later today or tomorrow and I'll
send it to you thank you thank you
helpful representative McDonald thank
you Mr chair and thank you for your
expertise and law in this area in
particular my question is online for the
bill it says the word pupils which to me
thinks students or people at least for
our student age maybe a student at
another school would this exclude adults
from following this so the concern was
maybe an adult who identifies as one
gender but maybe biologically is another
in this bathroom with students I'm just
curious this is where pupils apply to
adults
if someone were to ask me what would
what would a judge say about the word
pupil and whether it applied to adults I
would say a judge would probably say
that that doesn't apply to adults in the
school setting
thank you thank you very much other
further questions
thank you very much for your testimonies
today thank you reply thank you
committee you're welcome uh this
concludes our testimony on 107 before
and what I'm going to try to do here is
that
the next bill 352 we have only four
cards and we get through this real
rapidly and what I'd like to do because
one of those persons we have testifying
as a as an individual who's worked here
and we passed a bill in her son's name
Martha Dickey uh when we dealt with
suicide prevention in the previous year
and she has to get out of here very
quickly so I I've asked that Joe
Alexander representative Alexander
uh open this up quickly by presenting
the bill and then we can get uh
Martha Dickey and then there's two
others all of these people are
testifying in support of the Bill thank
you chairman lad members the committee
for the record my name is Joe Alexander
I represent the town of Goffstown I'm
here because we are on a mission to help
solve the mental and Behavioral Health
crisis especially month use youth in the
state this effort started my first term
in 2019 we passed SB 282 which had to do
with suicide awareness and prevention
training for minors with teachers
Educators and people that interact with
minors follow that last year pass and
sign into law SB 234 which would put the
suicide hotline on every student ID in
New Hampshire and it was actually really
great to be able to see that Goffstown
IDs with that number on the back so this
is a simple bill it would just allow for
a student to have an excused absence for
a mental or behavioral health issue this
is not meant to be necessarily
structured the idea is is that it's an
awareness to tool for educators parents
and people that so students can help
deal with Mental Health crisis so with
that I'm going to defer to my friend
Martha Dickey who will kind of give a
better layout of the Bill thank you very
much representative Alexander uh Martha
welcome back to education
thank you chairman Ladd and members of
the committee and thank you again we're
still very honored and humbled by the um
bill that was passed in Jason's name and
um as Joe Alexander just said it is
great to hear from people where it's
being implemented throughout the state I
will be brief because I do have to get
back to work
um I'm not going to share my story
except for to say to folks who might not
know me
um I lost my son Jason in 2017 when he
was 19 and he took his life since then I
have worked with both This House and
Senate to recommend legislation that
will help our young people have access
to better support for their Mental
Health
I am here today to speak in favor of HP
352 relative to excuse absences due to a
student's mental of Behavioral Health
here again I believe we have another
bipartisan Bill aimed at helping the
Youth of New Hampshire during the past
10 years we have seen High suicide rates
nationally as well as in New Hampshire
additionally between 2007 and 2018
suicide increased 57.4 percent in 10 to
24 year olds and in one survey of high
school students one in three youth
reported persistent feelings of sadness
or hopelessness and one in five had
seriously considered suicide
SB 282 passed in 2019 requires training
for faculty staff and Volunteers in SB
234 the Jason Dickey Suicide Prevention
act Pat just passed just last session
put the National Suicide Prevention
hotline number on the back of student
IDs with both of those bills implemented
I believe that this bill complements
them having a mental health day
notification system in place that a
parent can call the child out of school
will also offer the family a chance to
liaise with the school it will also help
to destigmatize mental health as well as
give the student a chance to rest and
recharge the purpose of a mental health
day is to recognize and acknowledge the
fact that symptoms from these mental
health related conditions can often
interfere with a Young Person's ability
to be fully present in school
there are currently 12 states where
students are allowed to take mental
health days in a 2020 Mental Health
America survey of young people's
greatest mental health needs the top
responses from 14 to 18 year olds with
better access to mental health
professionals and mental health absences
or breaks as part of school or work
mental health day is not intended for a
student to avoid classes or assignments
rather An approved mental health absence
can help open the door for schools to
assist struggling students with overall
mental health care I respect
respectfully ask for your support and
consideration of this bill and thank you
all for your service to the state of New
Hampshire and for the opportunity to
speak here today thank you Martha are
there questions from the committee
representative
thank you very much for thank you Mr
chair and thank you very much for your
testimony your story is very moving I
just have a question because I do hear I
homeschooled my kids but I do hear of
parents that say oh my son or daughter
just needed a mental health day when
kids call when parents call into school
to have their kids excused do they have
to give a reason that they're keeping
their child home that day or can they
just say they don't feel good today and
and would that cover the mental health
day I mean I'm fully aware that this is
an important sure consideration thank
you that's a great question and um
representative Alexander and I have
talked that through a little bit um I
think some of it is subject to
interpretation I think it takes the need
for a parent to feel like it's been a
while since I've had a child in school
so it might take the need off the the
need to say you know Joey has a headache
today and he won't be in to maybe if
there was a crisis or you know potential
crisis to actually be upfront and say it
was a mental health day and perhaps open
the door for communication
thank you thank you are the further
questions
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you have a good afternoon thank you very
much uh is
is represent Perez here still
here
and uh Emma it's a big Nate from
hello again
um for the record my name is Emma savini
I am the children's behavioral policy
coordinator at new Futures which is an
organization that is a non-profit
non-partisan non-profit organization
which Advocates educates and
collaborates for the health and wellness
of all granted Staters we are here in
strong support of House Bill 352 because
it would eliminate an inequity that
students are experiencing who are
experiencing mental health challenges
experience every day
um as the bill sponsor said this is a
simple solution to allow for students to
take time off to decompress uh perform
you know self-care whatever they need to
minimize future
um
you know
symptoms of their mental illness and
improve the overall outcomes for their
Mental Illness but also give them time
to seek help if they needed it
um
as of right now at least 12 other states
have passed similar legislation to this
and many others are have it pending like
New Hampshire does
removing these barriers this barrier of
having an absence on their report card
removes the stigma of having mental
illness and also improves the ability
for students to take that time without
fear of negative consequences to their
grades and other aspects of their
education
as I mentioned we are in strong support
of this bill and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions
that's the refers in Belcher thank you
Mr chair just to get an idea of the the
scope do we have do we have any um
statistics on for instance what percent
of students experience some sort of
mental health condition that might fall
under these uh guidelines
um I'm I'm I can absolutely get you a
broader statistic but just quickly
15.8.08 of New Hampshire youth reported
suffering from what at least one major
depressive episode in the past year
which is higher than the national
average at uh just over 13 percent
um but I can get you further statistics
as needed thank you very much for the
questions
thank you thank you and and the last
card which we have is from Sam Hawkins
thank you again chairman ladding
committee uh again my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm the public policy assistant
at Nam New Hampshire uh we're here today
to speak in support of HP 352.
uh so we all know New Hampshire kids are
facing a mental health emergency 15 000
granted stagers ages 12 to 17 have
depression and suicide is the second
leading cause of death for New Hampshire
Youth and Young adults ages 10 to 34. on
a national level one in six U.S youth
ages 6 to 17 experience a mentor mental
health disorder each year
of these 50 of all lifetime mental
illnesses Begin by age 14 and 75 percent
by age 24.
adolescence is a stressful and rapidly
developing period of life where youth
learn to navigate their education
complex social and family situations and
begin to plan for their futures well
these are challenges for all youth
they're exponentially harder for youth
with a mental health disorder shown by
the fact that high school students with
depression are twice as likely to drop
out of school than their peers
formally allowing excused absences for
mental and Behavioral Health needs will
help combat stress and address emotional
struggles for students before they reach
a crisis Point additionally it will
provide time and freedoms for students
and families to pursue counseling and
other assistance
this policy would encourage you to take
ownership and active accountability of
their mental and Behavioral Health by
opening the discourse and surrounding
mental health and by opening the
discourse surrounding mental health and
encouraging crucial dialogue between
students parents and teachers HB 352
could also work to reduce the stigma
surrounding these disorders
in standing committed to a comprehensive
and multifaceted approach to addressing
the youth mental health health crisis
Nami New Hampshire urges the committee
to vote to recommend ought to pass for
HP 352. thank you very much are there
further questions from the committee yes
uh representative dry
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking a question
um
I see a lot of these kind of problems as
an EMT we're talking specifically about
the student there or with a familial
problem with mental health be a
justification for taking a day like this
uh I'm not sure whether there there
would be room for that in in what's
proposed
um I do think of family Mental Health
crisis uh allowing for an absence for
that would be helpful thank you
uh represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
just to give me a better understanding
of mental health versus Behavioral
Health can you give me a couple things
that might fall under each category
sure I think uh mental and Behavioral
Health uh sort of together as an
umbrella term
um cover it's obviously mental health
disorders like depression anxiety and
then Behavioral Health would cover other
disorders such as autism ADHD things
like that I believe
are there further questions from the
committee
thank you very much thank you and with
where
no we got a lot of cards up here but for
different bills okay for the committee
we're going to take a break now
um
we for for our physical health and
social health and mental health uh we're
going to have to um take advantage I
don't know but sometimes I take a mental
health and I get out of the house and I
go fishing
and that's a great pain reliever so
absolutely we will take a break here and
we're going to come back and continue on
with our docket but we're going to come
back here at 1 30.
1 30.
foreign
I'd like to welcome everybody back to
House Education uh we're starting late
we had a couple long bills this morning
uh we are right now on
hb505 relative to Comprehensive Mental
Health education in schools and I'd like
to welcome the prime sponsor Bill
hello thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you to the members of the committee for
reporting the year time and
consideration today my name is Jody
Newell and I'm representing Cheshire
foreign Keene and I'll be speaking very
briefly as the prime sponsor of hb505
and as the mother of two New Hampshire
students
and all my testimony I aim to speak on a
particular aspect that may not otherwise
be covered by others so while I would
direct you to the mental health experts
who will be contributing their support
whether in person or through emails of
support as well as the New Hampshire the
wonderful New Hampshire students who
have organized diligently around this
issue some of whom have come here today
to share their personal experience on
the necessity of this bill
but my intention is to answer two
questions why is this necessary and why
in this form
the short answer to both is that mental
health is truly fundamental and
far-reaching mental health permeates all
aspects of Education the way we learn
how we receive and relate to the
information and those learning alongside
us as well as how we utilize what we've
learned
further our schools prepare young people
to participate fully in our society and
that will Define our social structure
and policies after we are gone or as I
like to remind my boys when the tables
turn and they'll be taking care of me
educating these Minds requires that we
understand how they function
that we need to heal uh he their unique
challenges and thought processes and
integrate this knowledge into our
preparation for the many aspects that
they will encounter in adulthood simply
put a comprehensive understanding of
mental health is fundamental to Leading
good and productive lives which is why I
feel the inclusion of mental uh of
comprehensive mental health education in
this section of long which establishes
the essential topics to be covered in
the New Hampshire school health
curriculum is extremely important and
with that I'll conclude my introduction
thank you so much for your time thank
you very much are there questions for
the representative
yes representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for the
testimony introducing the bill I'd just
like to ask you if you could
just spell out for me the difference and
I want to make sure I have a clear
between are we talking about the the
teaching of mental health is in like
teaching a psychology course or are we
talking about the practice of mental
health as in we're practicing psychology
to help students be more like well-being
or or something along those lines yeah
great question actually we have some
really great resources in the state of
New Hampshire around supporting people
uh to manage the mental health and
things like that what we're talking
about here is comprehensive mental
health education would be that would be
teaching people about various aspects of
mental health this is to be included in
the health curriculum which already
covers things like you know physical
education why would you not cover things
like uh your uh your emotional
well-being in a variety of different
things so that rather than a teacher or
an adult keeping an eye out for which
they already do uh keeping out keeping
an eye out for different symptoms and
factors that may indicate somebody is
struggling with their mental health this
would provide a broad understanding for
the students themselves so that uh you
know even if it's not visible to a
teacher or something like that they can
understand what what is happening and
learn how to reach out to support uh
reach out to those uh you know the many
supports that we have and then it'll
help them to manage that as they're
moving forward
thank you I appreciate it those are
questions
can you give a thank you for taking my
question by the way can you give a
further definition of what you mean by
comprehensive how much how in-depth
Etc is is do you mean by that well I
think the point of putting it in this
piece of uh in this part of the law is
to establish it as a priority
um that people so so it doesn't
necessarily flesh out exactly what it's
going to be taught so we talk about the
other things that are in this uh in this
part of the law are you know things like
teaching people teaching children about
physical education it's like teaching
kids about HIV and AIDS about suicide
prevention those kind of things
um so what this part of the law does is
it sets out these specific topics that
we want to be prioritized and then that
is fleshed out as far as how it's
implemented would be fleshed out later
basically what this bill says is that
this should be a priority and we should
be incorporating this into our health
curriculum in whatever way that takes
form I think that would be the next step
this is kind of the first step saying
this is a priority let's let's work it
out
further questions from the committee
representative Hall
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I kind of follow up
on that on the previous question so if
the word comprehensive were not in here
with the priorities do you think that it
would
end up being implemented differently or
yeah I thank you for the question I I I
appreciate that I think
um the difference is is that we really
want to make sure that
um you know in using the word
comprehensive we're really trying to say
that there should be a firm
understanding of a variety of mental
health issues I think a lot of times we
talk about uh you know people are aware
of uh learning disabilities I I let me
just tell you about my own son you know
my own son comes home and he's telling
me about things that he's learning in
school he asked me
um about if a friend of his has ADHD
says you think he has ADHD he said well
I I don't think so and so we're talking
about you know what are what are kind of
the symptoms of that and as soon as I
start lifting up listing off the
symptoms he says oh no that's not it so
all right well you know what ADHD is but
you don't know what the actual symptoms
are you know what I mean so you know
what an ADHD is a very very familiar one
whether he learned it in school or
anything else people I think are are
commonly aware of that now I think it's
a about having
a deeper understanding so that people
understand what are the sign that
children understand what are the signs
and symptoms for for that kind of issue
not that one only but you know are there
further questions from the committee not
see any thank you very much I'd like to
thank you chairman Ladd thank you
members of the committee uh for the time
and letting me to testify on House Bill
505 today
for the record my name is representative
William Darby from Hillsborough uh
District 11 Nashville Ward 8.
I offer a personal family experience in
support of this bill one of our fan one
of our daughters has high functioning
autism and an executive function
disorder while she acted immaturely for
her physical age and struggled with
friendships she did well academically
and in elementary and middle school she
struggled so I'm in the less structured
environment of high school but decided
against an IEP because she wanted to
remain with her classmates and graduated
in four years
a couple of years after high school
while enrolled in college our daughter
had a psychotic break with
hallucinations that caused her to be
retained in the emergency room for
several days before the psychiatrist
would release her to inpatient care
since we were fortunate enough to have
insurance coverage
it was determined that she had developed
psychiatric sorry psychotic depression
which led to many scary months for our
daughter and family as we signifi and
was a significant setback to her
progress in school
with therapy and medication our daughter
can now largely manage your illness and
it's completing our bachelor's at snoo
as she is both introspective and highly
articulate we discussed her
um I discussed her mental health
challenges with her my wife and I didn't
she offered Keen insights that I share
with you now
it was during first it was during an
optional psychology High School class
where she first realized that she may
have depression after taking a
self-assessment
while this helped her understand her
behavior she did not share her Discovery
with anyone including her sisters likely
due to embarrassment
she also conveyed how her peers would
talk down to her in a childless voice in
school as they lacked the understanding
that her autism did not effective
cognitive abilities
Comprehensive Mental Health would have
directly benefited our daughter for
numerous reasons including
destigmatizing mental illness
teaching engagement skills and helping
students recognize the onset of mental
illnesses in themselves and others
for many people Mountain almostis are
first diagnosed during adolescence and
early adulthood
mental health is just
and it's just uh is just as essential to
students development as health education
wellness and physical education which
are currently required by RSA 189 10.
I would it would help many students like
our daughter to reach their potential
and become productive adults I urge you
to vote ought to pass on House Bill 505.
thank you very much representative are
there questions from the committee yes
representative Balboni
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um I would like to know do you know of
any uh mental health curriculums that
are being used either in the state or in
other states
I'm not aware I can tell you that she
was not
um like I mentioned the psychology class
where she learned about the principles
of psychology not um Psychology from a
health perspective
um was her first sort of exposure to it
yes
sorry as a follow-up um do you envision
that this curriculum would be taught by
um I guess that's the question who who
would teach this curriculum
from my perspective it would be
um health professionals the same way the
health professionals teach Wellness
um teach different aspects of of Health
I think that you
um you can learn the curriculum and and
convey the curriculum
thank you thank you very much uh
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair thank you the speaker is an
interesting spot today
um you you mentioned autism spectrum
disorder and the way I interpreted this
bill it says Comprehensive Mental Health
I interpreted that to teach on subjects
such as anxiety depression would
neurodivergent conditions such as autism
that's in my family as well do you
believe that would be taught within the
realm of this bill as well
no I would hope so a autism depression
eating disorders that I think there's a
wide variety of
um mental health issues and that's why I
appreciate the word comprehensive all
right thank you
thank you very much uh the represent
Belcher
thank you Mr Sharon thank you for the
testimony
um we heard earlier that it's a it's a
teaching um tool to to educate people on
Mental Health
um if I'm not misunderstanding however
you're suggesting
that there might be some sort of a
screening element involved in this for
mental health or something along those
lines no I I did not suggest no I what I
interpreted uh
um that bill sponsor um to say is is
largely what I tried to summarize it
will teach students how to
um about mental opennesses which will
destigmatize it it will teach them how
to engage with students that have mental
illnesses which will help them engage
with them uh more readily and it will
help them to recognize the onsets of
potential mental illnesses so they might
be able to recognize that in themselves
or their peers there's I don't expect at
all
um you know a teacher to be diagnosing
students
further questions representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
for uh thanks for joining us this
afternoon as well as to the uh the prime
sponsor for uh for bringing this in
today
um I was wondering too if if under
wellness and comprehensive mental health
um such a subject could also include
um and you know I I totally understand
that not everybody in New Hampshire has
um you know is able to
um Avail themselves of health insurance
but a large percentage of granite
Staters do either through um through
um
um the um the the Affordable Care Act or
through their employer or through other
self-insured plans uh or through the
granted Advantage but that all of these
plans are are required to um to provide
um uh access on a on a on apartment
parity you know mental health parity
um uh health insurance coverage uh along
with you know comparable to
um and to the same extent as they do uh
physical wellness and that having that
knowledge would be beneficial for uh for
students coming through our system could
that be part of
this sort of comprehensive
I'm not totally understood
just creating an awareness that uh that
that the uh that our health care uh
industry as well as the insurance
industry have to cover mental health
conditions um I think that makes sense
right um recognizing that
um you know I think students are used to
going to the um you know to their yearly
checkups right but they're not used to
going to their their yearly councilman
appointments because they don't have
them
um like I mentioned and the research is
you know is very easy to find a large
number of uh adolescents and young
people first experience severe mental
health issues for example psychotic
breaks
um another daughter of ours ended up
with dated a young man who had um who
had his first uh incidents with bipolar
disorder
um in his early 20s after she had dated
him for many many months so I can point
to two specific examples in my own life
where people did not see this coming and
all of a sudden they have you know these
really serious impacts recognizing you
know the onset of those and recognizing
that there are there is help for those I
think would would be very beneficial
thank you
representative Tanner
um do you know and thank you for taking
my question do you have any idea of
what's actually being taught within our
or even prescribed by the um
department of education standards for
health education right now whether it
includes Mental Health
it's
um I will say that I did a little bit of
research
um and this is not an area of expertise
of mine but I did do a little bit of
research and I do find some
um recommendations it looks like that
the state puts out for mental health
um I can tell you that another daughter
of ours we have six daughters
um uh uh is a mental health nurse that's
what she does professionally now
um she has also she spent a lot of time
now with my with our daughter that I've
mentioned here
um that this was
she went to school in Manchester
um this was not something that she did
not have this background coming out of
school either so I'm not sure what the
standard is but I I don't believe that
it is if there is one that it is being
upheld to a level that is helping the
students adequately
um just as a follow-up um so I taught
health for a long time and
um we always had uh and even now there's
a unit on suicide prevention uh mental
health first aid and stress but it's
it's a it's more General than I think
your daughter's course in Psychology
which probably was at the junior senior
uh further questions
thank you very much thank you so much
for the time today
um I think we've asked a couple of
technical questions as to this point so
I'd like to invite up here Elizabeth
Eaton she's representing the board of
good afternoon thank you chairman and
before you get into yeah you know
because you've been haven't indicated
you hear more for technical support I I
I'm assuming because there's nothing
check whether you support or don't
support what correct the the board does
not take a specific position uh
generally they would support this but I
do have some uh written statement from
um from the board so I'm here to present
you please then go forward with your
written statements and communicate that
with us and then we may have some
technical questions one of which what is
comprehensive mental health
adverse Mental Health
so certainly okay thank you why don't
you go ahead with yours and then we'll
ask these type of questions thank you uh
this is from Debbie Robinson she is a
member of the New Hampshire Board of
mental health practice and she wrote I
am writing today to support hb505 I
represent the New Hampshire Board of
mental health practice as a public
member I have worked in mental health in
New Hampshire for 28 years and can
affirm that a lack of comprehensive
mental health education in school
curriculums is to the detriment of
students and the adults who love and
support them
children pre-teens and teenagers are
struggling with a complex world at the
same time they are experiencing complex
emotions and relationships
many of them do not have awareness of
warning signs of mental health struggles
let alone what is normal or what is
expected given the stressors they
experience and how to process all of it
open dialogue about these risk factors
and how to seek appropriate support will
create opportunities for care that can
be life-changing and in some cases
life-saving we owe this to our young
people their families and the community
that's the end of the written testimony
and I do believe she emailed it to the
board to the committee members earlier
today
I want to before any questions come up I
want to reiterate that I work for the
office of professional licensure and
certification I'm an attorney I'm not a
mental health professional however I do
sit in on all of their meetings I hear
all of their discussion tonight
um and they voted to
um send me before you to represent them
other questions
but I do have one
um the bill starts out the school shall
ensure the health education physical
education
are part of our curriculum
and at this point in time I look at the
fiscal note I'm seeing that the
Department's estimating well there might
be a need to purchase material
but I don't see any labor costs
associated with this beyond what may
already be in existence where we're
teaching it through
how the local wants to do that whether
it be through the physical education
teacher the health teacher Etc so
um where I'm asking is when I see the
word comprehend I see other areas like
physiology and hygiene and health and
what we discussed previously in previous
years here and added to the wellness
portions of this
but nowhere do we say comprehensive we
say things like mental health and then
um I think it it gets out of that domain
where we could almost Comprehensive
Mental Health get into a singular course
on that
um so that's my concern so I was wanting
to know if the board had some kind of
understanding what is meant by
Comprehensive Mental Health the next if
you don't the next one's going to go to
the Department of Education sitting back
there Diana and to find out where they
are on that or even Rebecca Fredette
because we see things like autism
and other health impaired emotional
disabilities all is categorical IEP
categories out of the 13. so where are
we you know where's this thing going is
and how are we defining it
I can only speak to how the board um
looked at this and discussed this bill
um when you when you look at the words
um
you're looking at health education and
then it kind of breaks it down into
physiology hygiene health and
interpersonal relationships
um that's all part of what health
education is and so there isn't any
breakdown here of Comprehensive Mental
Health there's no breakdown of mental
health into different categories the
same way that the the other physical
education and health education was
broken down
um I'm I'm guessing but I don't know I
didn't
you know we didn't get into what it
specifically means but that's the
overview of what the board discussed
um I don't know if that helps at all are
there further questions from the bureau
here
thank you very much thank you
is the department ready to come up or
Rebecca
same deal okay
represent Cornell there is a an office
of Social and emotional Wellness within
the Department of Education that has
someone in it to implement that we've
been through this a couple of sessions
ago the mtssb and they do do Regional
trainings with schools and different
things so I don't know how much
different this would be or what is
actually happening with that so it would
be nice to have someone
that is overseeing that department come
in and tell us what is going on in the
state because supposedly I think
something is I I know that there are
trainings that districts can sign up for
to to have stuff done so it would be
nice to get
some
knowledge yeah I agree with you and we
will
let's continue on with the hearing
process then
um I'm actually here to read one of the
testimonies from one of the high
schoolers I have to leave
um so good morning
um
Mr chair and members of the committee
I'm Erica Perez but I'm reading
um Nancy mathur's
um that's funny
so it says my name is Nancy mature I'm
from Hudson New Hampshire I would like
to testify in support of hb505
comprehensive mental health education is
increasingly important in schools all
across New Hampshire students having
access to adequate Mental Health
Resources has remained a challenge for
students in New Hampshire and this bill
Works to strengthen mental health
education in schools as a high school as
a senior in high school I have seen many
of my peer struggle with their mental
health due to these struggles some
students rely on substances as a coping
mechanism which causes even more harmful
effects both physical and mental
therefore it is crucial to provide
adequate mental health education in
schools students will then be aware of
proper resources that are available to
help them during these challenging times
as the president of my school spring
change to mind Club
I work with peers to raise awareness
surrounding mental health stigma this
club runs after school although we do
have a solid group of students in this
club some students cannot make it to
club meetings due to sports driving
situations and other activities this
bill makes sure that schools Implement
proper mental health education in
certain classes they're structured
during the day
this allows for all students to have the
same mental health education and
increases accessibility to that
information because students who have
been driving and working situations can
also receive that education this bill
Works to ensure that students are better
equipped with knowledge to navigate
challenging times and provides
up-to-date and adequate resources so
students can find help during these
tough times thank you for your
consideration please vote on to pass on
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Karen Reed and I am
a representative for Hillsboro District
27 Deering in Francis town I have been a
registered nurse for about 30 years 18
of those years have been spent as a
school nurse in most primarily in
Connecticut but sometime here in New
Hampshire as well so I've witnessed
firsthand the decline of student Mental
Health
um and I have to say that
um there are so many attempts um to help
you know there we have social workers
guidance counselors
um School psychologists our teachers are
trained in SEL and trauma-based
um education
um there's just there is a lot of
support I am not for or against this
bill I just want to give you my
perspective in that comprehensive is
very nebulous and also students these
the mental health issues kids are
bringing to school these days are very
very serious multifaceted and cannot be
treated in a school setting and I my
concern is that if a teacher is tasked
with teaching mental health to students
they're she's not gonna or they're not
gonna know who is suffering from what
mental illness it's a confidential thing
a student can be triggered or whatever
and the teacher is not going to know
that
um and what about a student that um is
secretly suicide has suicidal ideation
um goes to these um classes and makes an
attempt
his classmates or their classmates are
going to feel very guilty because they
didn't pick up on those signs
um I just feel that
the level of mental health the kids are
suffering from from is best left to
licensed
mental health professionals who are
better equipped to deal with students to
put a teacher in the position of
um generally teaching mental health
Concepts and how what's healthy and
what's not it sounds good but I do think
there's going to be a some collateral
incidents that we aren't even aware of
and I do have an example of that one of
my schools we brought in the
administration brought in a program
um you know to prevent um a certain
thing I don't want to get into specifics
I looked at the curriculum the materials
went to the orientation sounded
wonderful well the last activity of the
day the students had to draw a picture
and the pictures the kids drew were
disturbing on themselves and then the
kids that never had an exposure looked
at these pictures both of those kids
groups were very confused and there was
nobody to help process help those
students process process any of it they
were just left to go
I was very uncomfortable with that
luckily
nothing came of that but that is just
one potential for having a teacher who
is not a mental health professional help
kids it's just to me I would like to see
that left in the hands of a
professionals teachers are you know
health class you already cover hygiene
um you know nutrition uh you know
dangers of drugs some sex ed they cover
you know the basics this is a whole
other level that does leave me with some
concerns as to safety
students have so much access the student
if they're if they feel they're in
crisis or a friend that has some
concerns
all the guidance counselors all the
social workers all the teachers doors
the principals are always open and the
kids know that
so
I just think that this is not maybe not
necessary at best and at worst you know
may cause some untowered effects to our
our student population so thank you very
much I'll take any questions thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee yes representative Belcher
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony I think you raised an
important point that sparked an idea in
my head
as it comes to comprehensive and you
said it is a little bit of a nebulous
concept and as I consider some of the
stuff I've read into things like
um well-being and some of the concepts
that are Incorporated under under these
broad umbrellas I'm wondering and is it
possible that we actually could Under
the Umbrella of comprehensive
be getting into some topics that might
be controversial might be perhaps
ideological even that parents might not
agree with absolutely and if there was a
curriculum adopted I think that there
definitely needs some parent input and
transparency
what I'm seeing in a positive note
though on Mental Health Wellness is
um you know the students take activity
breaks they do mindfulness they do you
know deep breathing that is all good but
when we're talking about you know
bringing up suicide depression Eating
Disorders cutting we have so many kids
now that cut I just think that um you
know it's this is dealing with this and
addressing this cannot be learned in a
weekend
um you know staff development this takes
a course of study to you know to be able
to really help students and I think
that's best left to their professionals
there's a questions representative Myler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here so I'm a little confused on
where do you draw the line between
information sharing in a curriculum for
example
vis-a-vis of the fear
that the knowledge of that information
may take someone over the edge can you
talk it from a nursing standpoint can
you talk about that fine line between
information versus unintended
consequences of that information I think
I understand so what you're saying is
just because a student is presented with
an uncomfortable
topic will that cause that student to
spiral or decompensate
I'm not a mental health professional I'm
just putting that out there as a
potential but what I can see happening
is if you know if there is a student
that's kind of struggling
um and does make an attempt
um his class their classmates may feel
responsible because they took this class
they were showing they were told the
signs and symptoms of what to watch for
and they didn't see it so
um you know I think we need to tread
lightly I do think our kids are
suffering and they do need so much help
but I do think that whatever you guys
decide policy wise please just tread
carefully and and think of the untoward
effects that a class taught by a teacher
to kids who potentially have very
serious mental health issues what those
implications might be
thank you further questions from the
committee representative Woodcock thank
you General Bud good afternoon thank you
just following up on representative
Milo's uh dialogue uh in the
um the way the build is written it is
sort of uh embeds uh mental health
instruction or curricula in the typical
Health instruction classroom obviously
the word comprehensive is throwing us
all off not only What that particular
means in this particular case that being
said uh I want to be sure okay are you
still are you advocating for or against
basic understanding of uh issues of
mental health and emotional health uh is
part of the health curriculum or you
advocating not to have this product
curriculum
I at this point this kind of leading
to caution because there is no
um curriculum and what what might one
person might think is just a basic could
could lead to questions to more deeper
to more
um you know because what it would look
like is you know during your Cal your
school year the health teacher or the
gym teacher would have you know
so there would be a component on mental
health and what you're saying is if it's
just grazes the the the
ideas you think that would I don't know
I because I could see that going deeper
than just a surface
um knowledge if that was your question
okay thank you my concern was that
sometimes a lack of information is an
error versus no versus too much there's
a fine line absolutely thank you thank
you representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I just want to clarify what I think I
heard early in your remarks
which seemed to be a suggestion that
students being aware of risk factors for
suicide would increase the risk of
suicide did I hear that yeah you didn't
hear that correctly if if a student is
having suicidal ideation you know and
say the the you know uh topic of suicide
is addressed and talked about or
whatever
whatever that's going through that
student's mind May the may prompt it may
not but regardless if that student
doesn't have an attempt the P the his
friends and his classmates may feel
responsible whether it was related to
that or not it could be months later but
they're like I should have known I
should have seen I was taught the signs
and symptoms how come I didn't see
there's a lot of Burden with that
especially if there I feel you know we
all need to be aware of kids and their
mental health and any suicide ideation
absolutely but to to
to put that to on kids again that's we
need to be careful we need to tread
carefully I may I
I appreciate your further explanation I
just want to state that I'm very
confident that the large body of
evidence and mental health is that not
I do have a question and following up on
that line of thinking
we've been dealing with nutrition and
eating disorders
and we do believe that uh by a teacher
getting into uh talking about this topic
without a basic understandings of all
the causes and effects of that such as
you're going to do some fat testing in
the school that does that lead to
anorexia and
other types of eating disorder I have
seen that in a middle school
where half the girls came out with
anorexia or or a severe and that is a
do you I hear you I think I hear you say
that before we engage in this we need to
make sure that we have a well-defined
curriculum
and that we can stay out of the opinion
making and in the science area of the
subject yeah and I I would like it to be
presented by um if if it is adopted I
would like it to be taught by a
counselor or a social worker or the
school psychologist as opposed to it to
um you know health teacher somebody who
can help these kids process whatever
because we don't know what's going to
come out of their how they're going to
perceive their lesson we can't know
what's going on in their mind and I
would feel safer having it taught by a
counselor social worker school
psychologist somebody who can see and
help these kids process if needed you
know thank you all right further
questions
thank you very much thank you next chart
thank you once again chairman and
committee I promise I'll give you a
break from me after this my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm the public policy assistant
at Nami New Hampshire the National
Alliance on Mental Illness
last year the American Psychological
Association the American Academy of
Pediatrics and the U.S Surgeon General
all declared that our youth are facing a
mental health emergency
we can see this in our state in New
Hampshire there are increased numbers of
Youth boarding and emergency departments
awaiting an inpatient bed while
experiencing a mental health crisis
there are increased numbers of Youth
seeking assistance from community-based
Mental Health Providers and finding them
finding themselves facing months long
waits for initial appointments
youth are reporting greater instances of
anxiety depression and thoughts of
self-harm
suicide is the second leading cause of
death for Granite State youth and young
adults ages 10 to 34. the mental health
education is actually required by
administrative role yeah in spite of
this Navy New Hampshire has heard from
several students who indicate that they
have had zero mental health education
within the health education program in
their schools and I think we can see
that in other testimony we've heard
today
by codifying these requirements HP 505
would ensure that every school provide
this critical education and reduce the
stigma surrounding mental health by
recognizing acknowledging and validating
mental health symptoms and illnesses
we need all hands on deck including the
state schools by requiring mental health
education and statute this bill is one
tool that can be used to help address
the youth Mental Health crisis in New
Hampshire therefore Miami New Hampshire
urges the committee to vote ought to
pass on 505. thank you thank you Merit
very much are there questions
yes representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair just looking at people see your
testimony and we just said
can you explain what what it means from
a mental health standpoint to validate
um mental health and mental illness uh
yes thank you for your question
um it's not a very scientific term of
course
um
but in the way that we shove mental
health symptoms and mental health
discourse into uh sort of into the
Shadows outside of uh open and
comfortable dialogue we make the
children who are suffering from those
symptoms feel as if there's something
wrong with them by acknowledging that it
is a normal condition that many people
suffer from
we are validating their experience and
making them more comfortable to come
forward and talk about it
thank you further questions
thank you very much oh representative
Luna I didn't see you down there no
thanks thanks it was sort of a late hand
growing up and thanks for uh thanks for
joining us today it's been been very
helpful I noticed in um in one of the
um pieces of information that went out
in fact I think it was from
so it's not your testimony maybe from uh
Miss savini um but um but I think you
sort of touched on it too that um in in
New Hampshire
um
I guess the number of Youth reported
suffering from at least one major
depressive episode in the past year is
about 15 percent which is um almost well
coming on two percent maybe not quite
higher than the national average and
when you see when you see shifts like
that from a national average that really
really stands out and I was wondering
what do you what do you know about what
other states are doing in terms of
incorporating or folding in
um mental health into uh into uh um
Wellness uh curriculum thank you for
your question
um I absolutely agree that seeing the uh
that rise above the national averages is
alarming uh I'm not sure what other
states have been doing we didn't look
into that in preparing this testimony
but we will and I'll get that would be
great yeah thank you very much
while you're doing that is it okay for
you to would you please check in and see
who's conveying that curriculum yeah is
it the classroom teacher is it the gym
teacher or is it somebody specifically
trained to as we've heard that to handle
this type of uh heavy duty topic we're
absolutely looking thank you thank you
like further further questions yeah
good afternoon I don't have any written
testimony
um again Anne-Marie Banfield parental
rights advocate in New Hampshire focused
on academic excellence and education
I'm here to oppose this bill
uh some of you have already covered for
the reasons so this comprehensive the
word comprehensive is extremely
concerning
um
I think the the nurse behind me who
spoke uh brought up some points that I
would have liked to have brought up but
she covered them so I repeat them
uh this would be Health curriculum this
would be Health uh subject in the
subject of Health
we have state standards in this state
and they are vetted and they are
scrutinized and they are put together by
professionals and so when I see putting
something in like this with absolutely
no idea what this means absolutely no
idea what that will look like in a
classroom absolutely no idea what's
going to be taught
then I say go to the State Board of
Education if you have standards that you
would like to meet in mental health that
our children should be learning then you
go to the State Board of Education you
don't come to this committee
uh that way the commissioner can decide
who sits on that committee and then
hopefully we would have mental health
professionals that would go through this
and scrutinize them
teachers are not mental health experts
and yet we're here we are again putting
this on their shoulders
often times as some of you teachers who
who serve know that when they bring in
these programs they give you about eight
hours of training and then if they throw
you back into the classroom and now you
are supposed to cover these subjects
it's not your area of expertise yet this
is extremely important I don't want you
to to think that because I don't want
this put into State Statute the way it
is that this is not important in fact
just the opposite if you're going to do
something like this you better make sure
that there's a child psychologist PhD
level who has clinical training
and education
in every school in this state because
they need to be overseeing something
like this
says the the the
um presenter said that this is a
priority
it's a priority that's why they wanted
it this isn't State Statute so removing
something like this if this goes wrong
becomes impossible
we have social emotional learning in the
school right now and we're finding
problems with that we're finding
problems with mental health
programs being brought into the school
group therapy in classrooms and parents
haven't consented
we're in this bill does it say anything
about what this is going to look like
and will parents be allowed to consent
as they should per essay there is a
provision in there that requires
parental consent when there's any
assessment or mental health services
so what does this look like
um first of all I want to bring up the
school shutdowns that is one of the
biggest proponents of mental health
problems amongst our students brought to
I'm going to just bring a couple more
points
um I know that some of you have seen
this video because I've sent it to some
of you in the past
in Columbine where there was the school
shootings there was something that they
called deaf education several years ago
they were concerned about the mental
health of their kids too so they decided
to Let's talk about
death and suicide to help the students
and they covered this on a program
called 2020 and you can go back it's on
the it's on the um that's on YouTube and
I'm sure some of you have seen it and if
you haven't I've sent it to you so you
should have seen it
and so what they did is they brought in
somebody to talk to the kids about death
and so they started interviewing the the
person from 2020 interviewed some of the
kids in the class
and how it began to make them start
thinking about suicide
and so where they were trying to prevent
they were actually doing harm to these
children who's liable for that
if somebody
acts out in that way who's liable for
that what about liability
um you brought up the Eating Disorders
in schools there was an article not too
long ago and sorry but it was one of the
housewives one of the women who who's a
housewife on TV one of those shows and
she talked about how she was a bulimic
and still struggles today and where did
she learn about it she says in school
so if you have somebody who doesn't
understand the impact that they are
having on these children teaching and
covering these subjects you may be doing
them very serious harm very serious harm
and that's I'm sure what everybody in
this probably room wants to avoid
so without that that detailed
information I could never support
something like this and again I would
hope that if this is turned down that
maybe this is taken to the commissioner
and we look at standards that can be
scrutinized and looked at and vetted and
debated once they are released to the
public so I can look at him as a parent
we can look at them as mental health
professionals and determine whether it's
appropriate
um
one last point
this cause this costs resources this is
resources that we will be expending on
this
and have any of you called the one
Mental Health Hospital in New Hampshire
to see the wait list to get a child in
there I've called them and week to week
it changes child could be sitting in our
hospital for a week
before they are admitted to this
hospital if we're going to expend
resources let's make sure that it's
being expended
for children who need this kind of
mental health professional in their
lives let's make sure that we're using
this money wisely
I'm just not seeing where this is going
to make that best Improvement that's all
I needed to say thank you for listening
thank you very much are there any
questions yes reps in Belcher
thank you Mr Shearer and thank you for
the testimony I am I'm glad you pointed
to the word comprehensive because there
is one other health related program I am
aware of that uses the word
comprehensive in the title and it's
called comprehensive sex education have
you ever heard of this oh yes can you
speak to that at all and what's what
involves
wait a minute I don't think that's on on
topic here we're talking about
Comprehensive Mental Health not sex ed
another day all right thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
okay good morning afternoon
my name is Olivia Cheney I'm a junior at
Bedford High School and I am here to
testify in support of hb505. mental
illness runs in my family and I suffered
greatly from a couple of things
um but I don't know much about mental
illness I've attended multiple mental
health recovery oriented programs
but I still feel like I know nothing
about it
I've heard people talk about the darkest
corners of their minds I've been to
programs where I was learning about
mental health six hours every day for
months straight and yet my understanding
of it as a broad topic is hollow and
unfulfilling so I wonder how lost those
who don't have the same history as me
feel I wonder if they feel isolated I
wonder if they cry at night
the majority of people diagnosed with
depression in New Hampshire are in high
school according to the cdc's risk
factor surveillance system
with a majority demographic being in
high school it's most effective to
provide mental health education to high
school students this is a prime time to
develop empathy for our peers via
education mental illness is dysfunction
in the brain and can be hard for others
to understand the opportunity to enforce
a mental health curriculum is the
opportunity to stretch empathy Beyond
just what you have experienced mental
health education could teach students
how to talk to someone when they're
angry or about accountability or
self-regulation or how to ask someone
for help the list can go on and on
mental health education does not need to
be confined to mental illness it can
give students the foundation to move
into adulthood confidently and safely
a couple years ago I had an episode
where I could physically felt all of my
thoughts filling up my head pressing
against my skull and I didn't know what
to do I was scared I was irrational I
was in pain I was ultimately sent to the
ER but by the time I spoke to the
psychiatrist there I was caught I calmed
down I was ashamed I had just wasted so
many people's time and effort the
psychiatrist recommended I go to a
behavioral center this Behavioral Center
primarily focused on children who were
getting in fights in school or involved
in drugs so it was not equipped to
properly treat mental health it served
no purpose in my recovery
prior to my episode I was never taught
what options I had I didn't know how
mental illness could affect my body I
didn't I never knew that I was capable
of feeling like I did I was never taught
how Unapologetic mental illness can be
if I had more knowledge I could have
made a smarter Choice than going to the
ER that's not what I should have done
that day but I was never told what else
to do
in school we learned I've learned about
different mental illnesses in health
class we learned how to identify things
like schizophrenia bulimia or anxiety
I didn't learn what to do when someone's
having a panic attack or a delusional
episode or even how to build a proper
support system
if schools don't tell us this thing
these things who will
do I have to be in crisis to receive
support
thank you very much are there there are
questions from the committee
perhaps in woodcock
thank you thank you for taking my
question I was going to ask you if you
had any of any basic Construction in
probably the health curricula which you
mentioned that there was some there
do you know if in terms of the health
curriculum uh in bed so obviously also
the high school at Bedford High is this
by a regular health teacher or typically
my summer program a regular health
teacher and at Bedford High School
health and physical education classes
are by one teacher okay so you're you're
thinking
is then that the program that's embedded
now in the curriculum should be expanded
more to give more information to the
students yeah more so about as it says
in um
what to do next yeah
yeah personal and
yeah thank you so much thank you thank
um yes it's right in front of her so
we'll get that hopefully when you're
done okay
um any further questions from the
committee
now stay G as
am I you gotta correct me here
Marion
okay
welcome
good morning members of the committee my
name is Narayan sajeev and I'm a junior
at National High School South I'm here
today to express my support for HP 505 I
build aim aimed at enhancing mental
health education for high school
students
this is an issue that's close to my
heart as I have seen the impact that
limited health education can have on
young people
as a member of the governor's youth
advisory Council on substance misuse and
prevention I have had the opportunity to
collaborate with organizations and
leaders all over New Hampshire to tackle
this issue of substance abuse among the
youths
Pro work we have discovered the shortage
of mental health education in the state
leading the G act to advocate for this
bill this bill will greatly improve
students access to the Vital Information
they need for the mental well-being and
would help to address the growing need
for comprehensive mental health
education in our schools
during my high school years I had the
opportunity to take my health class
online but I was disappointed to find a
lack of emphasis on Substance Abuse and
Mental Health
these are topics that are vital for
young people today and are often
overlooked in the current curriculum the
lack of education on these subjects can
lead to dangerous consequences for
students later on in life which is why I
took the initiative to research more on
my own but I noticed that many of my
peers did not do the same
the covid-19 pandemic the covid-19
pandemic has only heightened the need
for a comprehensive mental health
education in our schools with mental
health struggles On The Rise as the
other people have mentioned it is more
important than ever for high schools to
receive education and access to
resources to navigate these challenges
the current curriculum High School only
requires one health class for a quarter
of the year over all four years uh which
is simply not enough time for to provide
students with Comprehensive
understanding of these topics
in conclusion I strongly urge the
committee to support HP 505
comprehensive mental health education is
vital for high school students and will
provide them with the information they
need to succeed in high school and
Beyond by supporting this bill you will
be giving tools tools they need to make
informed decisions about their mental
well-being and navigate the challenges
that I had thank you for your time
consideration thank you are there reps
in woodcock
thank you chairman good afternoon how
you doing how are you fine thank
you a couple quick questions just so I
may have about your online course but
was that a curriculum from the high
school or was that a separate curriculum
somewhere else I took it on vlax it was
Health opportunities and physical
education it was uh and kind of just a
follow-up to that uh from that class was
interacting with an instructor or was
just uh uh information I had a velox
instructor but the thing is most of the
work is done by yourself so you just
occasionally have a few check-ins but
yeah it wasn't really the same as a
proper uh in school education okay the
reality is that most of the people at my
school are taking online so they're
getting probably similar experience to
me um I took some research from running
on but most of my peers did not do the
same okay thank you so much thank you
representative a good question for you
then following up to represent Woodcock
and I think that's an important
important part is this the type of
subject that should be done online or
something that should be done with
another human body in the classroom with
you instructor yeah I think in person
it's going to give a much better
educational experience when it's online
you're just kind of reading articles
typing a stuff by yourself you don't
really get to see you don't really get
as much out of the curriculum as you
would if you are sitting in a classroom
and learning thank you further questions
thank you very much thank you so much
understood three you know this one right
here just there's four people can't rely
uh good afternoon members of the
committee my name is Lily O'Brien and
I'm a junior at Plymouth Regional High
School in Plymouth I'm here to testify
in support of hb505 it is important that
we create a community where young people
and students can build a positive future
for themselves which is why it is
critical that this legislation is passed
to ensure that we are granted the
education we deserve I have attended New
Hampshire public schools for my entire
life and have experienced firsthand the
effects that mental illness has had on
my peers and Community our education
laws and policies serve the purpose of
meeting the educational needs of all
students yet we're still without mental
health education much to us education on
prevention strategies and response
methods this is a grave disservice to
the students of New Hampshire it is of
the utmost importance that students are
equipped with the proper knowledge to
handle situations impacting and
affecting their mental health that they
are highly susceptible to
within my own Community I have seen many
of my friends struggle with their mental
health myself included
stressors that come from a multitude of
factors that include schoolwork social
engagement and many more are only making
it worse
I've watched my friends fall away from
whom I've always known them as becoming
yet another statistic charting teen
self-harm or eating disorders within the
youth population
we attend school each day for five days
a week and yet the only health education
we've received has been a semester-long
course in our freshman year that covered
the surface of physical health and
social well-being mental illness is a
very real topic that has become
increasingly prevalent in youth
populations and we are still yet to
receive education on it my friends and
classmates have been grappling with
these situations and are unprepared to
handle them
this issue has also severely affected my
school community and my school has tried
to solve it through motivational
speakers lunch initiatives allotted
mindfulness walks and many other methods
but to no avail
if this bill passed mental health
education would be streamlined and
normalized in conversation and my
friends peers and every other student in
the state of New Hampshire would be able
to gain the necessary knowledge to
handle these situations and be equipped
to respond to them this legislation
would act as a preventative step for
health care so that our only medical
treatment for mental health wouldn't be
going to the emergency room as a last
resort investing in preventative Mental
Health Care is important so we can
respond to mental health concerns before
they reach the point of life or death
which is something that I've sadly had
to deal with one too many times
we have an endless amount of resources
and we must utilize them this is an
opportunity to prevent and decrease the
high rates of mental illness amongst
young people that is always being
observed and reported but never acted
upon we are your future the students and
teens are the people of the state who
will be stepping up to lead in the
coming years it is in our best interest
to act upon these issues now in order to
equip students with the resources we
need to ensure a strong and successful
future I urge you to support us your
students and your youth by supporting HP
505 thank you thank you
questions from the committee
not see any thank you very much
thank you so much for having me my name
is Betsy Harrington I'm from Deering I'm
a therapist I've been a therapist for
over 20 years and you're probably going
to be surprised to hear me say that I do
not support this bill
I personally don't think that we should
be increasing Mental Health and Medical
in our schools I feel like if it relates
to education then I think we should be
taking that on in the school but
otherwise if you're going to take on
mental health issues of children that
are not related to school there are huge
liabilities like as a therapist I just
think to myself what if somebody accuses
you of something
my school has 75 000 assigned each year
for like legal costs related to these
kinds of things that's not enough it's
not going to be enough if we get sued
for something that we did wrong so I
feel like the more you put these
Outside Agency type things into a school
the more problems we potentially have I
think if kids have insurance Medicaid
things like that they should be going to
the Community Mental Health Center like
everybody else with their parents not
during school time remember you had to
take kids out of class
to do these groups there's already
Health they the kids were always saying
that they get a quarter a semester of
Health maybe we should increase the
health time to something more do we have
to put in a new program that creates
more liabilities and more issues when we
have a program that already exists we
can make that one better we don't need
the liability of adding new services
that then take on who knows if that
therapist was inappropriate If the
parents didn't like the way they did it
I feel like we're getting into a place
that puts us at such liability it's
really not a great idea I think if it's
related to their schooling so it's going
to be on their IEP or their 504 plan
then it might make sense to do some
counseling because you want them to
attend school you want them to do their
best but if it's not about school let's
say it's just depression about something
else you should be going to the mental
health center
and you know seeing a psychiatrist and
you know maybe having mom go with you so
you've got that conversation time on the
way there I feel like it really leaves
the parents out when you start to put
all these programs into the school that
the parents aren't aware of have been
approved of I really look at all the
curriculum that my kids get and I can
tell you A lot of it I say no to because
I find it inappropriate so I guess I'd
really have to see this ahead of time
and wonder why it's just not included in
the current health class
thank you very much
all right so my name is Abby Cade and
I'm a senior at Bedford High School I'm
in the town of Bedford obviously
um I also serve as a student
representative on the Bedford school
board however I am here to represent
myself
I'm here to testify in support of House
Bill 505 a comprehensive mental health
education curriculum in is a necessity
in New Hampshire Public Schools
I'd like to take a minute to discuss
what the word comprehensive means to me
comprehensive in my definition means a
complete including all or nearly all
elements or aspects of something
this to me means talking about
everything from warning signs to the
actual disorders to the resources that
are available such as like The Suicide
Prevention Hotline or the mental health
hotlines which I know a lot of schools
are putting on their websites now but
they aren't actually being told about
students on six plus hours at school
five days a week
if we think about a normal nine-to-five
working job students between school and
homework and sports are spending that
much time using their brains as well
this can become incredibly mentally
draining I know through the course of my
high school career I myself plus a lot
of my peers have simply not come to
school because we just need to sleep we
I can say that being in school and
navigating the stress of test
assignments and heavy workloads plus the
social aspects of school can take a toll
on anyone's Mental Health
I know Nami smoke spoke but I do have a
um quote from them untreated
inadequately treated mental illness can
lead to high rates of school dropout
unemployment substance use arrest
incarceration and early death suicide is
also the second leading cause of death
for youth ages 10 to 34.
so I ask
why if mental health is one of the
biggest factors affecting Generation Z
are we not doing something about it why
if schools are the place where
Generation Z is spending the most time
are we not changing something in our
schools
with mental health being one of the
biggest factors in this we deserve to
learn about it imagine how many lives
could be saved if someone had just
noticed the signs teaching about mental
health encouraging students to take to
talk and take a break
and learn about how they're feeling it
provides a better understanding of how
mental illness can affect a person's
life
it can help to reduce stigma which let
me tell you there's a huge stigma around
mental health right now
it can give competence to ask for help
or help those who are suffering it also
encourages early intervention by
recognizing early signs and risk of
mental health because like the others
have said why wait for us to be in
crisis before we intervene
the reality is this issue cannot be
ignored any longer how can we sit here
in contempt at the cries from students
and Educators to change things at our
schools
today I'm angry today I'm I am upset
because I do not want my peers or myself
to suffer any longer and I think that
this early intervention mental health
curriculum would greatly help that
we must do right by the Youth of New
Hampshire and with that I urge the
committee to vote ought to pass on HP
505 thank you for the time and I will
take any questions thank you very much
are there any questions representative
woodcock
thank you thank you my question
um of course during the course of your
testimony you mentioned that you you're
pretty wound up after a long week and
you took a day out of school and that if
I may get suspected bill right before
lunch uh with HP 359 was talking about
the need for students to be able to if I
may representative the need for students
to be able to have a option at some
point for a mental health day or a
behavioral health day for themselves
um obviously we're assuming with this
Paris knowing that Rogers downtown
um you or your uh is a school board rep
are you feeling is that something that'd
be useful
um because this bill is having a high
time as you can see already because the
world coffee has those types of
subsidiary bills like the option to give
kids uh some of the time is that
something to be acceptable not
acceptable in a little while but as an
addition
yeah so I think with the talk about
mental health in schools there's a lot
of things that are in my opinion wrong
with the school system right now and I
think that with a bill like this with
mental health curriculum
attacks the um aspect of trying to
reduce the people who are already in
crisis in the actual like issues that
are already up like that but as far as
the bill you're referring before about
the mental health um as like a absence
from school I would be in support of
that and I think that's a great idea I
do know that like as a school board
representative um I do know that there
are a certain amount of like days that
students have to be in school that like
the district has to provide so it would
be something that had to be like worked
out with like calendars and stuff um so
I know that that is a bigger issue but I
do think with something like this that
can even be the first step in bigger
topics like mental health days things
like that thank you thank you thank you
representation you're welcome thank you
very much are the further questions
thank you
to East Cornell out in New Hampshire I
know we're running behind and I'm going
to go very quickly I think we're at a
Crossroads I love these Youth and I hope
that these you will connect with me
afterwards because what I see every two
weeks at the executive council meeting
is a half a billion dollars going for
things like resources for mental health
but yeah as a registered nurse I'm
seeing people wait up to a year to get
into a psychiatrist to get the
medications their brain needs to
function appropriately we have a mental
health crisis in New Hampshire Bar None
unlike anything ever I've ever seen in
worse than most States it has to be
dealt with but yet we have a half a
billion dollars that goes through that
room in two hours every two weeks to
DHHS for a mobile crisis 1-800 clinic to
get to these kids when they need them
and they go to their guidance counselor
who's not got a PhD in psychiatry
we have to decide as an education
committee what does that what is that
what are we here to do for education
if our test scores are horrible and our
kids are not reading or doing a rhythm
attack or able to get out and write a
resume and do the basic fundamentals of
Education if we spread ourselves Way Too
Thin and there is a lot of crossover
we're not going to be effective anywhere
and that's where we're at already
we're trying to do health care we're
trying to do you know comprehensive
psychiatric care
and yeah our test scores and I'm hearing
in previous testimony we don't have
enough money for Perez
like we don't have enough money to do
the basics and now we're going to spread
ourselves thinner what I would love to
see these kids do with me if they've got
their righteous anger like I do and I'm
hearing it from them and rightfully so
as they partner with me and we start
going down that rabbit show and
investigating where is that half a
billion dollars going that I'm seeing
going through that executive council
meeting every two weeks because it's
certainly not going to Hampton and if
we're going to shut down this new news
center we're not going to do something
good with it only to build another
something
like that's where we need to all get in
the game here and start asking the
questions because the money is not
getting to these kids
it is not a new legislation is not going
to cause that to start to fix the
problem and we have seen too many kids
commit suicide these kids have been
wrecked
through US sending them home during
covid
they're going through so much through
social media they're living in pressures
we never experienced as children and we
do need to step up for them but I don't
think spreading education to do both
health care psychiatric care this and
that yes they're there for the majority
of their day and yes these kids maybe go
home to a home life but there's not
someone there to facilitate it but I'd
much rather see the resource go to their
guidance counselor who picks up that
1-800 number for that mobile clinic with
Riverbend and they have someone right
then and there to spend time with that
child for a few hours after school who's
a professional doctorate trained
individual to make sure that child truly
gets what they need and that we have a
bed available for them in Hampton and
they don't sit for three weeks and the
yellow POD at Concord Hospital
that does them no good these kids are
absolutely right about that but it does
not belong in within the scope of our
education
in my opinion I am opposed to this
within our Public Schools thank you for
your time thank you very much are there
any questions
thank you and with that I'm going to
yes
we only have one card here 517 that's
okay
yes
so why don't you just introduce it and
let them speak to a week and he died in
a minute yeah that's yeah so we have it
knocked off and off the schedule of the
end
um
[Music]
this bill which we have we don't have
anybody speaking 517 so we're going to
actually
before everybody gets hits the road we
want to thank all our students who took
the time out today to
I got it yeah no she's always part of
this education in fact she was in that
first class of names I may call it but
she does
applications
okay I'm gonna go ahead right now with
the next bill it's a very brief bill
here HP 517
so if everybody would turn their books
to 517 and we have representative Miler
welcome representative Miler well thank
you Mr uh Mr chairman my name is Mel
Miler uh representing Hopkinton and Beau
I'm here to introduce uh 517 relative to
background check for surrogate parents
I've been asked to introduce this on the
part of the department since there is a
need I passed out to you two uh handouts
that basically Define what a surrogate
parent is and it was interesting because
when Deanna asked me to do this in all
Canada I had no clue what a surrogate
parent was but as you can see as you
begin to look at this at the surrogate
parent plays a very important role in
the area of special education
and uh and disabilities as you can
Define as it's defined in the handouts
it basically under idea it provides an
opportunity for an individual to
basically be trained and certified in
becoming the surrogate parent for a an
individual who is disabled and either
the parent is in it has an inability to
represent the needs of that that
individual or in fact they don't know
where the parent is and so this is a
serious thing and um but I would like if
if you if you don't mind I would defer
questions to me because the department
is going to be here to basically answer
questions regarding the need for this
particular uh background check for these
surrogate parents but if you have a
question I might be able to answer and
I'm not sure
okay I I think we're gonna just try to
get right to the department
representative Myler that might thank
you Mr Knight this
and with that
um Rebecca do you have our our Rebecca
and Diana you are both going to come up
together
wonderful thank you
Rebecca for Dad is over in special
education at the department of Diana
Fenton works on the legal side legis of
uh attorney side of the department
welcome both of you you can take turns
starting or just go for it please
uh well I'm a lawyer from a health email
uh
no
you're a typical prosecutor yeah and you
still all heard me so there's a problem
right there good afternoon my name is
Diana Fenn I'm an attorney for the
Department of Education uh with me is
Becky for debt with special ed so uh
thank you to representative Miler for
bringing forward House Bill 517 on
behalf of the department
um so the educational surrogate program
has been in effect for a while and Becky
will answer all questions as it pertains
to that program
um my cursory understanding of it is
when a child is placed in dcyf care
um there are times where that individual
may or may not be able to serve making
educational decisions for that child and
so an educational surrogate is a
specialized person who can make those
decisions on behalf of the child they
work with the Department of Education
and they work hand in glove with the
child and so the department does as one
would expect and hope run criminal
background checks on those individuals
prior to them becoming educational
surrogates
the permission for running the
background checks was in our
administrative rules it was not and is
not in the statute it was in our
administrative rules
um and it was brought to our attention
by the department of safety who always
tends to show up whenever I testify
um that that practice
was no longer allowed under the FBI
regulations which this committee has
heard reference to in various forms
um that the authority to disseminate the
background check had to be in statute
it could not just simply appear in rules
along those lines we recognize that the
rules that authorize the background
checks was not entirely clear as to what
the department was looking for what some
of the disqualifying offenses would be
and so this was a great opportunity for
the Department to clarify what that
background check would look for
and we just linked it to 189 13A that's
already set out in statute for
employment this committee is very
familiar with that terminology and that
list of disqualifiers that we have
talked about previously so that
everything is consistent so we're happy
to take any questions and I believe that
department of safety is still here to
answer questions as it pertains to their
process
are there any questions representative
Tanner
thank you
um how many surrogate parents are
currently
around so currently we have um two
different types of educational surrogate
parents we have Master educational
surrogates we currently have six and
they are paid by the department
um and trained by the department they're
typically people who have been a special
education administrator they have a lot
of experience in special education and
they take some of our more difficult
cases and then we have
on the books over a hundred educational
surrogates that are volunteers that take
on just some kids that have had an issue
and are involved with dcyf or students
that um their parents can't be found
they may be living with a grandparent or
somebody else and so we assign an
further questions repson woodcock
good afternoon thank you for coming
um
the information you gave us uh the
handout that over the mileage came
forward uh on surrogate parents for
references all the stuff in Minnesota so
just my question is does New Hampshire
have a training program similar to a
different thing or at all for surrogate
parents sure I'm not familiar with the
handout that you have but I can speak to
it um we do have a training for all of
our educational surrogates they attend a
training with us for about it takes like
at least a day and a half it's been a
little shorter now that it's been
virtual but um and then they have to
take a test that goes through just some
of the New Hampshire rules around
special education and some of what their
responsibilities are and things like
that so there is a whole um training
that we've developed for those thank you
thank you thank you are there further
questions representative Damon thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
do the Serbian parents have any
um
communication directly with the children
do they are they like Casa Volunteers in
any way or develop like how do they
become able to represent for these kids
I guess is what I'm trying to ask so
they're assigned so uh um the process is
that a district would reach out to us
and fill out an application to have an
educational surrogate assigned either
because of dcyf or because they have not
been able to find the parent and they
may be living with a relative or a
neighbor or somebody else and then we
ensure that we go we have a person who
is solely that's her one of her jobs she
goes through the application she goes
through who we have for educational
surrogates and assigns a surrogate
um depending on the age of the child
they do meet with the child they do like
if it's an older student they will talk
to them about their plan talk to them
about what might go into the plan just
like a parent would you know they want
you to work on this or they want you to
work on that but they do become involved
with the child as well so that they're
representing the child's best interests
and they know about the child
oh
exactly
are if the child's with extended family
members you mentioned grandparents are
they sometimes in this role
um
typically they would have gotten
guardianship so this is where maybe the
grandparent doesn't want to do that they
think it's a temporary situation or um
no further questions
thank you very much thank you thank you
we will close this hearing and we're
going to just take 30 seconds here to go
foreign
so um you you can go ahead and move in
all second either way I don't care
um thank you Mr chairman I I would move
uh ought to pass on uh House Bill 517
now second that
any discussion
not seeing any or hearing requests for
any discussion Madam Kirk when you're
ready
we will call the roll
the motion is ought to pass
on HP 517 relative to background checks
right um
chairman Ladd no no go uh cordelli first
right then Vice chairman Cordell please
yes
representative letters
Senator Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDowell yes representative novel yes
representative pedernal yes
representative is not here
representative Myler yes
Representatives Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Paul yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman yes
is there any objection to consent
it's on consent
19 years
okay we are now closing the executive
session we're out of that and we're back
okay
he's playing that on schedule
if somebody on the thank you to safety
captain
um if anybody has to
go to the WSC or anything like that on
the way here
um you may do so as for going through
the hearing process because I want to
get right into this one as well
it was
okay uh we are now entering into 539 the
hearing on 539 this is relative to
this is one where after I have
um
the primary uh sponsor presented most
likely due to the number of cards which
we have I'm going to go down to the
well welcome I was looking for your yes
I'm sure it's in this bundle somewhere
it is Mr chairman okay thank you welcome
uh this is the prime sponsor of the bill
pie 39. thank you Mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee for the
record my name is Jim Cole I'm a state
representative representing Hillsborough
County District 32 which comprises the
towns of Wilton Temple and New Ipswich
House Bill 539 uh very simply would
prohibit K-12 public schools in the
state of New Hampshire
from hosting vaccination clinics during
school hours
in addition to that
it would stipulate that if schools are
to host vaccination clinics outside of
school hours that that a parent would
would need to be present with their with
their children at the time that a
vaccine is administered
so there are
several very important reasons why I
brought this bill forward first of all
there's a fundamental conflict between
the practices in these clinics and the
principle of informed consent
mind you I'm not saying that there is a
conflict between the stated policies and
procedures I am talking about the actual
practices at these clinics conflicting
secondly
hosting these vaccination clinics
detracts from the core mission of our
schools I have spoken to numerous
parents who say that this erodes trust
they are concerned that if they send
their child to school on a day that a
vaccination clinic is being held they do
not know whether their child will be
vaccinated against their wishes and I
have several stories that I would like
to relate to you about instances where
that exact scenario played out
uh third and perhaps most importantly
there are serious safety concerns
associated with this there are medical
contraindications to certain
vaccinations so the flu vaccine for
example can cause serious adverse
reactions potentially life-threatening
reactions
if if a child has certain allergies
um or or other conditions so I'll get
into that in a little bit more detail
but I'd like to start out by by relating
a story that that happened in
Brattleboro Vermont in uh late 2021 I
believe it's November of 2021.
um
a young boy six-year-old boy uh was was
attending an elementary school public
elementary school in Brattleboro where
they were scheduled to host a covid
vaccine clinic
the principal of the school approached
the the parents said we'd love to have
you give us a consent form have your son
vaccinated
the parents specifically declined that
request and said no we don't want our
son vaccinated now in Vermont there's
actually a an incentive system a
financial incentive system for the
schools to uh to achieve a certain
percentage of a vaccination among
student body
so in this case uh the young man and
I'll use his his initials as uh as as is
done in the in the court complaint
his initials were LP
and uh he came home from school that day
and had a name tag on that had his first
name
and someone else's last name
and he said Mommy I got a shot today
and she uh she thought he was playing
around a little bit he said no really I
got a shot later she discovered that he
had a vaccine card in his backpack
it had his first name and someone else's
last name
he had a bandage on his arm
and soreness in his arm and yes in fact
he had been
the school did Apologize
the mother and father eventually filed
suit
one of those parents is in the room with
us today he's not going to be testifying
his attorney has advised him that
because there may be additional pending
litigation he should not testify
nevertheless just in December a superior
court judge in the state of Vermont
dismissed that suit said the federal
prep act because this was the covid
vaccine the federal prep Act and the
prep act declaration that applies to the
covid pandemic
essentially says that nobody is
responsible
nobody
zero
informed consent dictates that two
things
be present information and consent
so information means you are aware of
the procedure being proposed you're
aware of the Alternatives you're aware
of the consequences of getting treatment
or not getting treatment
it also requires consent that is it
needs to be voluntary
and as a general rule when it comes to
minors informed consent rest with the
parents
the state of New Hampshire has published
a document entitled guidance and
standing orders for influenza
vaccinations and there's a section in
there on procedures to be taken with
people under the age of 18 being
vaccinated
in two separate places in that document
it emphasizes the importance of
attaining consent
so I'm going to quote from that document
consent must be completed correctly
if the consent form is not completed in
its entirety I.E missing an answer to a
question signed dated by a parent
Guardian
in September of 2022
the national Department of Public Health
conducted a vaccination clinic at the
Birch Hill Elementary School in Nashua
at that clinic they administered the flu
and they never they never got a consent
form there is no signed consent form
now the the mother in that case was here
unfortunately she had a time limit she
had to leave at three o'clock so she's
not going to be able to testify but I do
have written testimony from her and if
it has not already not already been sent
we will make sure that the committee
gets her testimony
several weeks after that incident
um I was sitting on a statutory
committee which was the committee to
study the listing of childhood
immunizations for children
um at one of those hearings State
epidemiologist Benjamin Chan responded
to some questions about this incident in
Nashua and during that testimony he
referred to this as a never event
you know what is a never event that is a
medical expression it means something
that you'd never ever ever happen
operating on the wrong patient is a
never event
amputating the wrong limb is an Ever
event
leaving a surgical sponge inside a
patient is a never event
this is an event that should never have
happened
at that time the committee was assured
that the state is taking steps to ensure
several weeks later it happened again
in New Hampshire
okay
the mother submitted a consent form
I've provided members of the committee
with a redacted copy of that consent
form so if you look at the handout that
I gave you you'll see what that looks
like
okay I guess they're they're still going
around
and I'm happy to provide
emailed copies as well
on that consent form
I would argue that that consent form
does not comply with the uh
the requirements that I just read to you
a few minutes ago it's not completed it
is not signed it does however at the
bottom of the of the first page say
State and I'll use the the person's
initial
B will not be getting this shot please I
do not consent
the second page
there are a couple of signature lines
there is no signature there is no date
and but there is the word no written in
large capital letters with an
exclamation point and an underline
I would ask you if we have written
guidelines that say consent is
critically important and we should deny
vaccination if we don't have a signed
consent form how in the world
does something get like this get by the
screeners
the lesson here is that
we do not have systems in place we do
not have adequate controls in place to
guarantee that we're not going to have
other incidents like this there are you
know whether you whether you believe
that vaccine vaccines are are critically
important to Public Health or not
parental rights come into play informed
consent comes into play and there's very
one very important reason why
parents might say they do not want to
give consent for their child to be
vaccinated namely that there are
safety and health concerns associated
with that
severe allergic reactions can occur
and
according to this I'm going to say the
CDC website has a list of things it says
it lists people who can't get the flu
shot not shouldn't not are advised
against can't get the flu shot
that includes individuals with severe
life-threatening allergies to flu
vaccine or any ingredients in the
vaccine
or specific metal medical conditions
such as Guillain-Barre syndrome any
devices against people getting the
vaccine if they're simply not feeling
well
parents know what is best for their
children they have the legal right and
the moral rate to give consent or
withhold consent
as I noted earlier these vaccines
undermine trust in our Public Schools
they undermine the mission of our Public
Schools
and
I have personally spoken with parents
who say they do not want their child
going to the school if there is a
vaccination clinic being held in the
case of the family in Brattleboro they
pulled their child out of public school
permanently and put them in a private
I believe that the organizations
conducting these clinics have good
intentions but we have seen
proof at this point that they cannot
guarantee that they will not be
following the procedures that they are
that they are
supposed to be following for this reason
I would ask that you protect trust in
our Public Schools correct protect the
rights of parents to determine what's
best for their children and protect the
health and safety of the children
themselves by voting ought to pass on
House Bill 539 and with that Mr chairman
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um
um just wondering this um second
incident where we have the form copy of
the form uh where was what school was
that located in
um I don't recall the specific school
that was in Rochester New Hampshire
Rochester okay for follow-up yes and
this vaccine clinic was for a flu
vaccine
correct the two incidents that we're
aware of that and again I say that we're
aware of because I I strongly suspect
there are others you know that don't get
reported but the two that we're aware of
in New Hampshire both involve the
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here presenting this so if I if
I'm correct you're not anti-vaccine
your basic concern is just the parental
consent the uh the on the uninformed
consent is what your concern is it has
nothing to do with vaccines
Etc is that correct my exactly my
concern in bringing this bill forward
has everything to do with informed
consent parents rights and safety the
safety of the children
um that's that's why I brought this
forward absolutely absolutely please if
they're not
um I'm not this is a topic I don't know
much about so I'm
glad you're informing this of this yes
uh if these vaccines are not available
in the school
where then would they get the vaccine
for polio you know smallpox whatever the
ones we need to have for kids to go to
school where would those be administered
there there are they can get them at the
doctor's office they can with many of
these including the flu vaccine they can
get them at pharmacies
um they could get them a school if this
bill passes the school could still hold
a vaccination clinic it would just be
have to have to be held outside of
school hours and a parent would need to
be present with the child
and you know I heard anecdotal
information about the Nashua incident
incident that there was quite a lot of
emotional upset among the children being
vaccinated including the one who was who
was vaccinated in error so
um you know I think that the the parents
being present serves two critical
purposes one is that it is absolutely
Rock Solid verifiable consent because
the parent is right there but it also to
provide some some some comfort and
affirmation for for a child who's who's
this is no vaccination that's usually
explaining how to take care of your feet
because this field that your present you
have any impact on that part
um no Mr chairman it actually doesn't
although
last biennium I believe is last year
Health and Human Services heard a bill
which stipulated that parents must be
notified if there are dental procedures
happening in the schools and must give
consent and I believe that that and I
don't believe I know that that bill
um has passed into law so there is a
consent requirement for dental
procedures already but this but this
doesn't touch on that at all no
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Koval for taking my
question this bill has a fiscal note
attached to it and on the fiscal note
says the Department of Health and Human
Services assumes the bill will result in
a reduction in the number of vaccination
clinics conducted in public schools
this may have an indeterminable effect
on Department expenditures as direct and
indirect costs related to vaccine and
Clinic operational costs fluctuate based
on demand and access
Additionally the department states that
school-based clinics satisfy Federal
Point of distribution and strategic
National stockpile training and exercise
requirements a reduction in the number
of clinics may require the department to
secure alternative training and exercise
solutions for the state's Regional
public health networks at an
indeterminable cost do you have any
information regarding that
um I I'd say I don't really have
information about that I think that
there are representatives from the
Department here today if they are
testifying that I think they could
probably provide some of that
information and I think there are some
people who are probably signed up to
testify who have a great deal more
expertise in those programs generally
foreign
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so you've indicated that this would
eliminate vaccination clinics during
public school hours but the bill also
says more than two hours at the
beginning or the end of the school day
correct
is the intent that it really not be
feasible to do vaccination clinics at
schools because that kind of does narrow
the window of time when kids would be
awake yep thank you for the question not
not at all the the intention is that we
don't end up with a situation where
um you know the bell rings at uh 2 30 3
o'clock and you know you're shuttled off
to the the cafeteria for the for the
vaccination clinic the intention is that
this this really truly sits outside of
school hours I can tell you that I'm the
chair of my local school board we have
plenty of events that occur at the
school outside of regular school hours
you know it's it's sporting events it's
science fairs it's club meetings it's
PTO it's there's a lot going on in the
schools so I don't think this precludes
the schools at all from holding
vaccination clinics if they if they so
desire
it just eliminates the possibility that
we have any of these never events
occurring at the schools
first question
thank you chairman good afternoon thank
you for taking my question uh I have two
actually uh in in the first part of the
the uh bill I don't want but this
preclude a school from offering uh a
vaccination clinic for staff and faculty
before school
if they want to host that that's that's
an excellent question I.E I thought I
think the I I think as I as I read the
bill I believe the answer would be Yes
actually and secondly it made a
different one probably the same if I may
representative lights okay thank you um
the second part is uh
if you're if there if the substance of
this is to make sure you don't get kids
who want to help their parents without
consent that's the substance we do know
that that's it's going to happen uh no
matter what program you have
um a small number of youngsters or a
sorority program is going to be this
fall through the cracks somehow so that
being said if the bill was structurally
around item number two
that uh let's just let's assume you
couldn't allow a clinic before or after
school for youngsters if the bill was
around I am number two and it required
parent on-site with the youngster we met
do two things solve the issue of your
biggest concern to safety and
non-consent for parent for youngsters
having a vaccination that they shouldn't
have been getting uh and V allowing the
bulk of the students and parents the
opportunity to get that in a pretty
orderly manner
um thank you for the question I would
all of the parents coming through and
being present sort of in the middle of a
school day
um and one of the issues that I raised
here is that this is disruptive to the
core mission of schools
um I would argue that having parents in
and out of the school for a concentrated
period of time a very large number of of
guests so to speak in the school is is
probably in itself A disruption
there's really no reason why that
couldn't be held you know at you know
five to eight o'clock on a weekday
evening or all day Saturday there's
plenty of times that that could be done
that don't disrupt the core educational
mission of the of the schools okay thank
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for bringing this forward
um I'd like to just take a look at a
little language just to make sure that
the bill is doing all that we actually
would want it to do when I think of the
word Clinic I think of a a specific
event for Mass vaccination
and also when I think of
um
uh of having parents there in order to
be physically present during vaccination
outside of these school hours I'm
wondering is there a window possibly in
here that may or may not have been
intended that would allow students to be
vaccinated during the school day on
school grounds outside of the context of
a clinic
thank you for the question so that is
the the intent of the bill is that
having
people who are authorized to administer
vaccines in the school in the school
administering vaccines is a clinic
um if the question is you know could the
school nurse be authorized to do that
um
I I'm not aware of that being the case
anywhere
my intent would be that that would not
happen either but the bill was
essentially written to to cover the the
existing scenario that we're aware of
which is that there are vaccine clinics
being held in public schools in New
Hampshire thank you
foreign
thank you Mr chair
um thank you representative it's just a
clarifying question I think you might
have said it but I'm not sure so my
school district our health insurance
provides the service to our staff
to tab the flu shot if they so choose
they have to sign they have to sign
their own consent to take it did I hear
you say that this bill would prevent
that from happening
um
I yeah my response was I think that if I
read the bill technically speaking that
that it would however
um you know it might make good sense to
have uh on professional days to to
allocate some time there or if the
committee wishes to amend the bill and
exclude that scenario or you know
specify that this applies to uh to
students only then I think that that
would still fulfill the the intent of
the bill as I've introduced it okay
thank you
get that question for you um
when I took my grandkids down to get
their covert shots from the Army
I had terrible power of medical attorney
that's needed but that's that's not
guardianship
so questioning if the parent is
unavailable to do this and it's coming
two hours after the school days over
it's a grandparent they're able to do
that or it's a legal guardian
you're an attorney here
and you might be able to help me out
with that would it be acceptable if even
letter from your daughter who's a parent
and say it's okay to or
um
so if you're directing the question to
me I would say that a a letter
um would not be sufficient under the
bill as written a power of attorney I
would have to defer to an attorney on
that question
um
I I I don't know how the courts would
ask you yes representative
thank you so I'm just revisiting the
topic of
outside of the school day but near to
the school day that two hour window
and I'm just reflecting on the busyness
of life for working parents young
children coming and going back and forth
and it's not clear to me why it would be
inappropriate with the parent present I
appreciate and understand that
um safety net
but it's not clear to me why that could
not be occurring after school in a
organized appropriate fashion
I I think that that's a that's certainly
a valid question again my concern about
the the the parameters around school
hours primarily had to do with
um
a scenario in which the the parent is
not present so if
you know if the committee believes that
narrowing that window of time makes
sense then you know again it's it's your
bill now so I I would I would I would
say that if if you wanted to narrow
those parameters and that made it more
agreeable to everyone that would be fine
you did mention the word convenience and
I want to respond to that because
um this is something that came up in a
discussion I had with a colleague
um
a few days ago and the the the the the
the argument that he made is that this
is such a matter of convenience and
people are busy and I guess my uh my
assertion would be that there are a few
if any areas of life where we sacrifice
individual rights and
um the Integrity of decisions like
informed consent
um to convenience and
um I would say that uh you know for that
reason I feel it's a very important bill
to move forward
thank you very much
thank you very much thank you I am going
you know hopefully two minutes I'm
holding 25 cards here you can feel the
amount of lab to figure out who's going
to get out of here
chairman lab yeah so you can hear it now
so so we are going to impose that
three-minute rule try to keep it down to
two
um
and for those that are staying for the
last two bills due to the time Factor we
are not going to be hearing those today
we will reset those bills to a time to
be announced
um we could be here to seven o'clock
tonight
so
I don't think it's anybody's you know
wish to do that
so with that I'd like to go forward and
we will be starting the timer up here
thank you
um representative into the committee
so my question to everybody is what was
school originally made for
so this is just an easy Google find and
rather than every family being
individually responsible for Education
people soon figured out that it would be
easier and more efficient to have a
small group of adults teach a larger
group of children in this way the
concept of school was born
when did Reading Writing in arithmetic
become flu clinics
eua which is emergency youth
authorization injection centers and
social emotional Learning Centers
the amount of community-based health
centers in drug stores Walgreens Walmart
that are injecting children for free is
unbelievable why are we infusing this
into our schools
personal story I'm going to age myself
here I graduated from high school in
1991.
in no way shape or form in any school
that I ever attended
there was ever a vaccine clinic nothing
the only Clinic that there was in a
sense if you want to call it a clinic
was the American Red Cross came and they
did blood drives
and all the high school kids and there's
someone on this committee that I went to
high school with so she knows
all the kids would go because they
didn't give blood because they would get
I believe that we need to keep school
for teaching and learning
Reading Writing and arithmetic
there are so many issues when it comes
to this privacy issues the emails that
came from schools in 2021 were
unbelievable and I could name three on
the Seacoast that sent emails directly
to students bypassing parents I'll get
you copies of everything
encouraging them all to get an emergency
youth use authorization injection in
their arms not going to parents
encouraging these teens
to sign up and get a shot
we have to be focused on teaching
students
supporting our teachers
because they need that and there's a lot
of different mental health issues which
you guys talked about earlier
um I'm sorry but teachers are not
doctors and they're not in the health
care profession and neither are these
school boards
the amount of school board meetings that
I attended in um
2020 and 2021
and these school boards were literally
focused
um on about in having students be
injected was unbelievable they're not
Health Care Professionals
and I um I strongly support this bill
and I appreciate
um and appreciate our time
thank you representative are there any
questions for the representative
see none thank you very much for your
testimony
all right thank you chairman members
committee my name is Jason gerhardt
represent Northfield Franklin
I'll make this brief
my main concern with this would be the
covid vaccines
I just do not feel and and data suggests
that are not safe nor effective
and recently I pushed through a
resolution at the county level and then
also at the state level to have the
Attorney General investigate them for
fraud and wrongdoing Florida has already
initiated a grand jury investigation of
the manufacturers so I just don't feel
that at this point I'm going to keep on
pushing for this I just don't feel at
this point we should be exposing the
state or the residents of the state to
the liability and risk involved in these
experimental
whatever you want to call them
and I would also say that I think we
need to see the efficacy Data before we
push this through taxpayer-funded
schools
if we're so sure about this then let's
find out how effective they are before
we start pushing it because in a sense
if you're pushing it through a school
you're basically co-signing saying that
it's safe and it actually does something
so that's my position and I support this
Bill thank you thank you representative
questions
representative
thank you and thank you representative
Gerhard
um
does this bill refer to coveted vaccines
in particular no it doesn't it covers
all of them but that's just my main
focus so this is just a bill focusing on
vaccines in general yes thank you
any further questions seeing none thank
you very much representative
thank you very much I'm representative
Timothy Horrigan from Stratford district
10 which is the town of Durham and I
I I oppose this bill I know medical
liability regardless of whether we pass
this bill or not is a major concern at
schools I know school officials are very
afraid of being sued they're walking on
eggshells
but that's uh going to be but that's the
case already even with this bill and
this is just going to make the situation
worse in school school's already like
sort of Petri dishes there were all the
one of the things that kids do when they
go to school they go there to exchange
all the uh other
viruses and other in their back and
their germs and everything with each
other and um including
including uh including covet
and uh I think it's only it's only
sensible to uh to vaccinate them and I
think having vaccination clinics at the
school is very convenient perhaps
there may indeed have been some never
never events where there's a mix up in
the in the forms
um certainly
certainly it's not uncommon for children
to have the same first name as
classmates in fact sometimes it seems
like about there's only two or three
first names in the whole class the
classroom but that's not an argument
against having vaccination clinics
that's just an argument for keeping
better track of which student is which
that would be the subject for entire
number built a whole different bill
and the situation in Vermont by the way
that lawsuit those parents have stepped
forward they certainly don't have to
come and testify at this hearing but
their names have been published in the
media and their court case currently was
dismissed although they're trying to
revive it but there's no big secret
there but and um it's and I don't think
it's uh I don't think requiring the
parents to come in
is is I think that's excessive I think
having a verified form and maybe they'd
be better job of verifying the form but
that's the solution because uh some
parents themselves are can perhaps
worried about coming to school either uh
either because they're afraid they too
might get infected by all the uh in fact
if there's a uh if there's a epidemic
going around which thereof it is
and uh or there may be other cases uh
they may like for example if a parent is
a special enthusiastic gun owner they
may be afraid they may be reluctant to
come onto the campus Because that's a
space where they're not allowed to have
their gun
and it's only I do recognize school
officials are working on eggshells I
know they're afraid of being sued but
that's going to be the case anyway and I
think this uh vaccination clinics uh
reduced the risk to everyone in the
school community and running the larger
community so I think they should uh
they should be allowed they should be
allowed to continue perhaps you may need
and and of course an alternative of it
with the bill you're not hearing today
we could probably arrange that parents
uh opt into opted to offer off campus
vaccination clinics but I don't know how
that I don't know I shouldn't say but
that's probably way outside what the
committee has the time to do with the 99
or whatever it is other bills they have
so I say
please please itl this bill please
continue having vaccination clinics
especially for especially for covet and
we know you have the right not to be
vaccinated you also don't have the right
to spread a spread a infectious disease
especially not a respiratory virus that
killed over a million people just here
in the U.S So yeah thank you very much
thank you chairman members of the
committee representative poll serving
the towns of
um Don Barton hooks at Allentown and
have some
um like to speak on in support of the
bill regarding five different items
first of all children cannot give
consent that is law in a number of
places minors do not have that legal
Authority in New Hampshire
so it is very difficult to actually meet
the medical standards of having informed
consent I'll cover informed in a minute
when the when the person there is
incapable of giving consent
um secondly schools are education
institutions that's why the bill is
before you guys and not necessarily HHS
we should be spending our time educating
our children instead of trying to turn
our schools into medical clinics that
are not prepared to do to deal with
um there was a filming of an during the
rollout of the coveted vaccinations out
of the facility a medical facility a
nurse named Tiffany Gover took the
vaccination on live TV she was the nurse
manager I'd been in the field for a
number of years and she collapsed from
anaphylactic shock on live television
what happens when a school has a child
who hasn't adverse reaction to a
vaccination goes into anaphylactic shock
do you call the parents to say I'm sorry
your child
um is is on his way to the ER right now
because we decided to vaccinate him
um let's teach our children in the
schools and not try and pretend to be
medical clinics
next in the state of New Hampshire under
the age of 18 currently there are four
records of children who have passed away
say that again four records of children
who have passed away in the last year
some Mom some Dad out there
if you look at the data for what
happened relative to adverse effects
from the covet that the covet virus
there was one loss of life in New
Hampshire under the age of 29.
I'm on division three in finance I'm
looking at this data this data doesn't
make sense
um and then lastly in terms of the
online testimonies I would like to read
one some people aren't getting their
opposition and their support correct
I'll just pick on one but I noticed this
in a couple of places where a person is
is testifying
um
and I quote these clinics would allow us
allow for our children to make Health
decisions that have potential for
various very serious consequences I am
absolutely opposed to this bill these
coping vaccines have caused a multiple
multitude of life-changing and
life-anging ending injuries so some
people are clicking the wrong thing
um when the people go through as a
committee and look at the online
submissions make sure that you're
looking at some of the notes not just
opposed support because I think some
people inadvertently didn't understand
what the bill was trying to do
with that I'll close my testimony
thank you representative any questions
I see none thank you very much
uh is representative Perez still here
nope
yes
thank you again for allowing me to speak
in front of this community
my name is Maria Perez and I represent
District 43 in Milford
and I'm here um speaking of position of
this bill
well let me tell you something
Heaven boxing action clinics who for
people who look like me
sometimes I'm grateful from for having
these clinics for my community because a
lot of people cannot afford to have
or pay or they don't have insurance to
pay
so I'm grateful that students and kids
to have the opportunity to be vaccinated
but not pushing anyone to get vaccinated
most of the time
this mobile clinics come we now
utilizing the nurses at school or we're
not using the school property to do this
they come with a mobile mobile clinic
they come with their own own nurses
we're not taking money away from the
schools we're not taking money away from
the towns on the cities
we're given the people the opportunity
to get vaccinated we're not pushing
people to get vaccinated without parents
consent
if you're talking about taking time away
from students to get vaccinated
we you guys are too two different bills
today
about about giving credit to students
to go for religion
services
why are we saying we're taking away time
from the students to get vaccinated
this is helping the students to be
healthy we should be grateful that their
students and people who cannot afford to
get vaccinated and be Health they have
the opportunity but no
we're going against the help and concern
with the community
let's stop this
I don't know what what I wanted to say
because I keep hearing antibacterating
people and tea vaccine
but they keep pushing
religion
they keep pushing
empty this until that
and nothing nothing nothing
that they've been coming and say let's
do something to provide kids better
opportunity to have a better education
or to have better health
we're not saying that everything that
we're doing is just pushing the wrong
way
please i.tl this Bill thank you so much
for your time
thank you uh questions uh representative
McDonald thank you replica Deli and
thank you for being here again I really
appreciate it I think we all do
my question is a moment you go you said
that
this bill presented an anti-vaccine
argument however I do not see that in
the bill and the prime sponsor did come
forward and say that that's not the case
and that this bill is just to ensure
that informed consent is provided so
wearing the bill could you direct me
just so I could see the anti-vaccine
well you see that the way that they say
in the none of the language but when you
hear them talking
you can hear you can see where they're
coming from
we're taking either time you know or or
anything like that they keep saying that
this is all you know we keep pushing
these injections into humans
no one is pushing injections into human
they're given the opportunity if they
don't want to take it they don't have to
take it
but by saying that we pushing or some
kids they they got an email or anything
like that the parents had the you know
the opportunity to choose not to get the
vaccine
follow-up please yes so just to clarify
the language is not in the bill but
rather in the conversation but again
nothing like that is in this bill
I'm just
speaking about the testimony I'm not
speaking on the bill and speaking on the
testimony and I'm saying
you know we should not be saying you
know that we're pushing no one is
pushing anyone to have vaccines okay
thank you for clarifying them thank you
thank you thank you very much
representative
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and members of
this committee I would like to support
house spell
5 39 sorry about that it's been a long
day
um I just want to point out that um if
vaccinations and meta vaccinations in
school is not a medical necessity it is
a convenient service I believe that we
need to get away from medicalizing our
education system and leave that to
Health Care Providers
um and be to keep this short again I
support Bill 539 and I feel that um
vaccine should be given at the doctor's
office
and as far as convenience you can go to
Shaw's Pharmacy and pick up your milk
bread and vaccination All in One Stop
um I don't think that schools are at a
place that vaccination should be given
anymore and another point is parents are
very nervous and I have had Parents keep
their kids home from school on
vaccination day for fear of their
students being vaccinated without their
knowledge age or on accident and I have
had that happen I'm more than one
occasion thank you
thank you any representative
thank you thank you representative Reed
for taking my question
um
you said earlier you were a school nurse
correct
could you possibly see this bill as a
way to prevent a school nurse from
making a grave error I would call
vaccinating a child against their will a
grave error and in fact I think we heard
representative cofult say that Dr
Benjamin Chan said this should never
happen would you agree with that I do I
it does set up anytime you administer a
medication or injection you know the
chance for error is there but with kids
in particular especially the younger
kids which is the population I worked
with mostly when you get a little guy in
they're all scared they're nervous and
you'll say um you know you have your
consent form and everything else and you
say is your name Johnny whatever and
they're scared now they'll answer to any
name and if and if you don't have some
serious checks and balances in place it
absolutely can happen thank God it's not
a common thing but it has happened and
the potential is there especially with
our younger our younger kids it's
thank you representative Belcher thank
you Mr chair and just to follow up on
that with your experience as a school
nurse
as a school nurse in a typical setting
if if there was a problem do you have
the equipment on hand to run an
anaphylaxis or a code or something like
that we do but we don't want to it's a
very scary experience it really was and
I was hired originally as by the health
department so I was a health public
health nurse working in a school so I am
not anti-vaxx I am pro-vaccine but I do
believe it needs to be given in the
appropriate setting kids are not little
adults you know and for continuity you
know those vaccine records follow your
kids for the rest of their life and if
you get them all over the place there's
you know they fall off the scheduling
timetable there you lose paperwork if
you are consistent in bringing your
child to a pediatrician they have the
records They know how they tolerate it
they know the history that is the ideal
I think sometimes we need to forgo
convenience for you know the for good
health care for our kids
and any more questions thank you
thank you no questions thank you very
much for your testimony and I think next
we'll
um maybe hear from Ryan tannian and Abby
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Abby Rogers I'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
Public Health Services at the Department
of Health and Human Services
good afternoon Mr chair and the members
of the committee my name is Ryan tanion
I'm the bureau chief of the Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control at the
division of Public Health Services and
I'm also a registered pharmacist in the
so I'm here today to talk about the
Department's stance on House Bill 539 so
if enacted House Bill 539 as we've heard
previously would prohibit vaccination
clinics during the school day at Public
elementary secondary and charter schools
in New Hampshire and then it would also
implement the requirement of a parent or
Guardian being present for the
vaccination event
the decision for vaccination clinics to
take place during the school day for
staff and students is a local decision
made in Partnership by the school in
coordination with the remainder of the
school community and the regional Public
Health Network
in addition there are school-based
vaccination clinics scheduled and
coordinated by local and Area Health
Care providers
the department believes that the
scheduling of school-based vaccination
events should remain a local decision to
allow communities to implement clinics
or other services that best meet the
needs of their community and to retain
local control
offering vaccination clinics during the
school day provides access to annual
influenza vaccine to children and staff
who may not otherwise have access to
care or services for a variety of
reasons
the model of school-based vaccination
clinics allowed for children to receive
offered vaccines against communicable
diseases such as influenza in school
after written consent from a parent or
legal guardian allowing the parent or
Guardian to remain in the workforce on
that given day
by not offering clinics during the
school day parents Guardians and School
staff who choose to receive influenza
vaccine would be forced to utilize more
costly and resource intensive Health
Care Resources
participation in school-based clinics is
completely voluntary and it is the
parent or guardian's decision to
vaccinate their children
during a school-based clinic since 2017
the regional public health networks have
administered 37
276 influenza vaccines to school-aged
children and School staff
it enacted thousands of parents of
students and staff voluntarily seeking
influenza vaccine will place further
Demand on an already stressed Health
Care system as stated in other testimony
the department does not intend to make
covid-19 or influenza vaccination a
requirement for School attendance
the model of school-based vaccination
clinics conducted during school hours
has been in place for decades and safety
for students and staff Remains the
number one priority
parents and legal Guardians who
voluntarily choose to vaccinate their
children after providing written consent
are provided vaccine-related education
materials including the vaccine
information statement developed by the
Center for Disease Control and
prevention which describes the risks and
benefits to vaccines given to guardians
or parents prior to vaccination which
provides them accurate information about
the benefits and risks of vaccination
this is important for both ethical and
legal reasons
additionally Healthcare professionals
are available through both the regional
public health networks and the medical
Direction contractor to answer any
questions or address concerns
similar to other models of healthcare
school-based clinics are constantly
assessed and evaluated for safety and
efficiency
through a robust continuous quality
improvement program processes policies
procedures and training are implemented
to ensure safety of students and staff
in addition to a continuous quality
improvement program the medical director
is contractually obligated to have
policies and procedures on obtaining
consent to vaccinate as well as a
comprehensive training program for all
Clinic staff and emergency protocols in
the event an adverse event which may or
may not be related to a vaccination
occurs
furthermore
school-based vaccination clinics fulfill
critical emergency preparedness
functions through this model the state
of New Hampshire and Regional public
health networks meet annual training and
exercise requirements for point of
distribution clinics the activation of
the Strategic strategic National
stockpile and proficiency of the
national Incident Management System
if enacted the state would face
challenges in maintaining a well-trained
and proficient emergency response
Workforce
in summary the department opposes House
Bill 539
due to the Restriction of access to
influenza vaccine for school-age
children and School staff in New
Hampshire's most vulnerable School
communities forcing working parents or
Guardians and School staff voluntarily
seeking influenza vaccine to utilize
more costly and resource intensive
health care resources and placing
limitations and indeterminable costs on
the department to maintain a highly
proficient emergency preparedness
Workforce
we will also be submitting written
testimony after this and I'm happy to
representative
thank you
um
for taking my question there's several
things I'm confused about
what vaccines are children receiving
routinely or not routinely what vaccines
are children receiving at school
um
how do we fund those vaccines because
obviously the children are receiving
them at the school at no cost is what
I'm understanding and then I'm really
confused about this point of
distribution and strategic National
stockpile training and exercise
requirements I'm wondering how
that occurs in the school like what
thank you for the question so the first
question
um the school-based vaccination clinics
that are coordinated by the regional
public health networks historically
offered influenza vaccine
last year was the first year that
covid-19 vaccine was also offered at the
school-based clinics however going
forward due to utilization demand and
the commercialization of covid-19
vaccine going forward the department
only intends to offer influenza vaccine
the second question on how this is paid
for the regional public health networks
receive multiple funding sources one of
the largest ones is the public health
emergency preparedness Grant and we're
univer where New Hampshire is a
universal vaccine state where anyone
under the age of 18 is able to receive
any asip or CDC recommended vaccine at
no cost to them we use General funds to
purchase the influenza vaccine and the
last question
in the point of distribution and
strategic National stockpile as part of
being a grant recipient for the public
health emergency preparedness Grant we
have to meet certain requirements so an
example outside of vaccines for point of
distribution this goes back to
um in the event of a bioterrorism attack
and we have to distribute large
quantities of an antibiotic due to
Anthrax or a radiological event like a
dirty bomb or a
incident at a nuclear power plant and we
have to distribute large quantities of
potassium iodide the regional public
health networks
exercise and train to do point of
distribution of vents
and by conducting annual school-based
clinics we can take that and show that
back to the federal government to say
yes we are proficient in performing
these activities because as we know the
time to actually exercise and train is
not during one of those crises like a
bio terrorism attack or a nuclear event
representative cascadden oh I'm sorry
and you want to follow up you you had
representative cascadden thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for uh taking my
question and actually addressing the
point of distribution I've participated
in two pod drills in my career
and they are held in a high school if
this bill were passed would that mean a
pod could not be held in the high school
or a school building
I think as the bill is written and I
believe uh representative kofal also
briefly touched upon this
it appears that it would limit it to
potentially just vaccines but it does
depend on what the medical
countermeasure to
the the Pod need would be
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and being here today
um so I'm based upon your testimony
my presumption is I've got two questions
my presumption is
that you do agree with the issue of the
informed consent prior to any vaccine
giving to a student is that correct
I believe informed consent can be
obtained in different ways yes okay
second question I have we we've heard
some incidents of where children have
been given vaccines without the parents
knowledge Etc and some unintended
consequences as a result of reaction to
whatever the vaccine might be do you
have any numbers or any data or any
metrics that would give this committee a
little more background to what that
incident rate might be
so to the knowledge of the department we
are aware of
um the two incidences here in New
Hampshire that were
um reported in 2022 however uh to our
knowledge those did not include covid-19
vaccine
so two instances then correct thank you
very much if I could just follow up on
something you just said
um you said informed could consent could
be obtained in different ways could you
expand on that I'm not sure
um what ways you uh have in mind for uh
obtaining informed consent so the the
current process and procedure is
outlined by uh the regional public
health networks and the contractors is
to obtain written consent
there is Provisions in the policy and
procedure from the contractor that also
outline if there's questions or if the
consent is outside a certain date window
if they can call a parent and obtain it
verbally so that that is to clarify your
question that's that's in rules from who
it's part of the policies and procedures
that the uh either the regional public
health networks or the medical director
who's operating the clinic has in place
thank you I just yeah I just sorry this
is Abby Rogers I just wanted to add in
that parental consent is of the utmost
importance when it comes to
vaccination clinics in schools and it's
taken very seriously and it's obtained
by writing and writing
thank you uh representative dry
thank you Mr chairman uh could
a clinic conducted outside that window
like Beyond two hours after or before or
on a Saturday
um fulfill the requirements for
emergency preparedness training
it could potentially fulfill those
requirements yes
representative Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you both
for being here
is there any data available
I'm thinking it's probably more specific
to influenza
on
What proportion of people who would be
eligible and appropriate for vaccines
get them or don't get them
related to these clinics in other words
how much does convenient access
influence the administration of vaccines
thank you for the question so those data
points are would probably not be readily
available however when the school-based
clinics were first developed the focus
and Target populations were schools who
have higher rates of free or reduced
lunch school plans and that was heavily
rooted in the socioeconomic barriers and
or follow
so did did we see an increase in
um people getting vaccination and what
you just referenced with the
population's higher incidence of brain
reduced lunch when the clinics were
started
so that was the original uh metric that
was put in place when school-based
clinics first started we you know we are
certainly open to having discussion to
figure out if that is the best metric
going forward but as far as school-based
clinics in general if you Trend it over
the last five years we have seen a
decrease
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to go
back to a moment ago when you said that
the federal training requirements are
being met through these vaccination
clinics was that was that did I hear
that correctly yes may I uh follow up
um
is it even remotely conceivable that
we're allowing a federal training
requirement around terrorism to distract
people who were administering vaccines
to children
could you clarify the question please if
they're conducting this training
requirement that is a federal
bioterrorism training requirement while
simultaneously vaccinating children in
schools is there even a remote chance
that these Federal requirements this
training could be distracting them from
the job of vaccinating children so thank
you for the question it's
it's approached in the opposite way so
where we have we've been conducting
these clinics for a number of years and
as the public health emergency
preparedness Grant and those Federal
requirements have evolved we have come
to a place where we don't have to do
something separate we're able to take
what we're currently we are doing and
what we've done for the last few decades
and just show the federal government
we're already doing this we don't need
to do a separate event to meet these
requirements thank you
uh representative Balboni
yes I'm just trying to get an idea of
um two things like how many schools
participate in these clinics throughout
the state and how often those clinics
would be held
sure thanks for the question so the
it's almost twofold so some some
Regional public health networks have
reported the number of school districts
that have participated others have
reported the individual number of
schools and I can certainly follow up
with the actual number of schools if
you'd like and then as far as the
frequency that goes back to the local
level decision making so the regional
Public Health Network engages the school
and the school Community they may want
one clinic or they may want several
clinics so the the frequency at the
school level does vary
thank you and I would appreciate the
number if you get a chance thank you uh
sorry just to follow up with some
information related to the
representatives question too just for
the committee that in
um 2022 I can we can say that there were
over four four thousand students
received the um influenza vaccination so
just to give you a number of how many
students utilize and or have access to
to that uh to that um preventable
vaccination for communicable disease
thank you any further questions
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
just one more could you just speak in
broader terms to the utilization of
vaccines in New Hampshire compared to
nationally
thank you thank you for the question I I
would need more context if we're
speaking a specific population or a
specific vaccine
well I could just narrow it down to
influenza
um so are we trending differently than
nationally over say the last 10 years or
something like that because so thank you
again for the question and follow-up to
that we do
um we do track Trends down to the
specific vaccine specific age group
level uh specific to school-based
vaccines what I can say is
um compared to the previous year we
actually did see a slight about a two
percent increase in the number of uh
parents wishing to have their student
vaccinated at a school-based clinic
um and this would be a much broader
conversation we've seen rates increase
and decrease depending on the vaccine
itself but for the most part and
generally speaking in the Northeast we
tend to have very stable rates over long
periods of time
representative woodcock
thank you just a follow-up of your
question from Robert the bear uh when
parents bring their youngsters to a
clinic for vaccination is a in our
school-based program it's ongoing is it
possible for parents to get vaccinated
we do not turn down a opportunity to
vaccinate so yes because a little quick
please
based on that do parents participate
foreign
depending on how the clinic is set up so
if a if it
typically in other folks have mentioned
uh you know how do the logistics work
for a parent coming in in the middle of
the school day right I don't see that
likely again that's something controlled
at the local school level if it's a
weekend event and parents show up
because there's another event at the
school then sure then yes thank you so
thank you for taking my question you've
referred a couple times to if we reduce
if we do away with these clinics during
school hours or shortly before and after
school hours that it would have put an
increased load on other health care
facilities are you talking about
pharmacies and grocery stores where
people also go and get vaccines or are
you talking about it forces people to
then go doctors
thank you for the question uh so
from our perspective at the department
we see as my colleague Abby Rogers
mentioned last year there was
approximately 4 400 almost 4 500
children who received a vaccine at a
school-based clinic
those four thousand five thousand plus
people now need to schedule an
appointment at a pediatrician or go to a
pharmacy
during a time where there are critical
Healthcare Staffing shortages in all of
okay thank you
thank you um did either of you have a
further comment to one of the prior
questions yes thanks I had a comment um
on a question that was asked previously
just to share that the vaccination rates
for for
um Pediatrics I mean it's a pediatric
population is relatively high in New
Hampshire but we did see a dip during
covid-19 during the pandemic due to
access due to folks not being able to
get to the doctor so the um you know the
the school health space the school
health clinics really are a really great
point of access for for kids uh to get
vaccinations when their parents can
consent to that
um it broadens the ability of the school
Community to stay healthy to have kids
in school to have parents be in work and
not have to be home with a sick child
and also um that immunity spreads beyond
the student population to the staff and
also to the broader community
thank you uh representative pedernal
quick one
it's not three questions thank you thank
you
I'm just have a quick a quick question
how long have we been doing this in
schools wait how many years so the
school-based vaccination includes well
generally speaking we have been doing
school-based vaccination clinics
um
we can go as far back as the 1950s and
60s when we were doing polio vaccines
um this specific school-based Clinic
program administered by a regional
public health networks came shortly on
the heels of the H1N1 outbreak in 2009.
okay
represent miler
thank you what uh recourse does a parent
have
if in fact a vaccine is given to a child
thank you for the question uh as
representative Koval referenced
um the comments of Dr Ben Chan who had
participated in the study committee on
the listing of immunizations for
children School requirements which was
held in the fall by the legislature that
that event that you describe as a never
event uh that should having a child
vaccinated without parental consent
should never happen
but as we know in medical sometimes in
medical situations administratively you
know events such as this can happen it
is you know the delivery of medical
operations medical oversight delivery of
medical Medical Care can be complicated
and complex because an error did happen
in the case is described a
representative kovald which I can't
speak to the goal is to improve the
delivery of care and have a better
process in place to prevent errors in
the future so any any child that was
vaccinated without proper parental
consent that I would assume I'm not you
know I'm not a legal person but I would
say that that parent would have a
recourse to have further discussions
with the uh with the clinic with the
administrators of that clinic and and
certainly with their child's provider
um to kind of look to next next steps in
that Arena
representative
one more quick question as
unelected bureaucrats are you in the
position to be making a statement
supporting or opposing legislation
foreign
sure I would say that as representative
the Department of Health and Human
Services we frequently come to
committees to inform the legislature on
uh legislation before the Committees
we're here today to provide information
we are taking a position on this bill
because as we are representative our
mission for the Department of Health and
Human Services is to protect public
health and we feel that by restricting
access for Pediatric patients in the
school Clinic if their parents have
decided this is the best place for them
to get vaccinated and if they signed
proper consent that is not a benefit to
Public Health or to a healthy Community
or immunity
thank you see no further questions thank
you very much for your testimony and uh
mail comment I think sure you want to
add one thing
um representative Ladd had asked a
question I believe of Representative
Cole fault around
um the parental who can give who can
give consent right so according to the
National Children's vaccine injury act
which is a federal act only parents or
legal Guardians May consent to
vaccination for their children
thank you thank you very much
um
we have uh quite a few cards left to go
so um you know let's keep our questions
short from here on and uh hopefully the
testimony as well
um The Honorable Don Johnson from
Laconia
so
hello everyone my name is John Johnson
I'm from Laconia I'm here as a parent I
know as a parent I have taken the steps
to get the vaccines that my children
need I also know that when I sign a
consent form I know that my child will
get it but I do not always trust the
school district to not follow through
when I do not follow a consent form
there has been instances I know across
the state and I know from personal
experience I've even kept my kids out of
a class out of school because of surveys
not being followed when I said my child
would not take this survey and they've
tried to force my child to take a survey
if I can't ask them to follow along with
a simple survey that my child is not
allowed to take
how can I trust them
to not also follow a non-consent form
I just wanted to say that
we need to offer these clinics I am not
against vaccines my kids are vaccinated
to a point
but at this point in time offering these
clinics
during school hours in is in intrusive
and interruptive to our students
education we are there for our teachers
to teach them to learn read write and
arithmetic not to force or push a
thank you uh questions from the
Mr chairman may I respectfully see my
time to my friend a neighbor who has to
leave at 4 30.
sure does she have a card up here yes
thank you
um my name is Risa Evans and I'm an
attorney and I live in Kentucky
um and I'm here to urge you to vote for
this bill for three reasons in addition
to some of the many good reasons that
have already been offered
first we know from experience that
mistakes are inevitable mistakes were
made in Nashua they were made in
Rochester
they were made in Vermont where a
six-year-old child was given a covid-19
injection without parental consent and
over the child's own objections at the
time
across the United States the vaccine
Adverse Events reporting system includes
reports of over ten thousand vaccine
Administration errors of various sorts
since October of 2021 for children ages
5 to 17 for the covid-19 injections
alone
so mistakes have been made and no matter
how well intended we are
and regardless of the fail safes that we
put in place mistakes will be made again
so that brings me to my second point
which is that because mistakes are
inevitable injuries are also inevitable
most obvious are possible physical
injuries to children who receive
unwanted and unconsented to vaccinations
hopefully mild physical injuries but
potentially severe and even deadly
depending on the reason for the for the
child's parents you know having objected
to vaccination in the first place
whatever the underlying medical
conditions are
less obvious but also important Are
Spiritual injuries to children and
parents who's sincerely held religious
beliefs preclude introducting
introducing certain substances into the
body and who experience unwanted
injections as desecrations
also less obvious but also important are
what I would refer to as dignitary
injuries the types of injuries that are
recognized by New Hampshire's simple
assault statute which precludes any
unwanted touching recognizing that
unwanted touching violates a fundamental
right of personal bodily sovereignty
so that brings me to the third point
which is that while mistakes are
inevitable and injuries are inevitable
remedies for those injuries are not
inevitable far from it so in the context
of non-emergency use vaccines even if
parents are able to obtain money damages
through litigation of some sort money
cannot undo the types of injuries that
I've just described and nobody wants to
have to go through that
but even the worse in the context of
covid-19 injections and any other future
injections that are qualified as
emergency emergency use products the
prep act the public Readiness
um what is it the the public Readiness
and emergency preparedness act
precludes really any state law remedies
for any kinds of of injuries so in the
Vermont case and I have a copy of that
here for the committee I just have one
copy but I'm happy to email a link for
people who want to read it in the
Vermont case the court dismissed state
law claims of battery negligent
infliction of emotional distress fraud
violations of the State Health Care Bill
of Rights and other state law claims
that were brought
and the the Court held that the prep act
precludes any state law remedies for
covid-19 injection errors according to
the judge prep immunized all of the
defendants against any state law claims
of and this is the judge's word
malfeasance so basically under under the
prep act as interpreted by the Vermont
court and other courts across the
country basically
um any school-based covid-19 injection
Clinic is a zone of complete lawlessness
there are just no remedies for mistakes
excuse me I'm seven I think your three
minutes is up though thank you if you
have written testimony that you could
share with us thank you thank you very
much deserve better
oh okay
uh
Deborah Chandler
may I please seek my time
oh does that person have a card in
okay
uh Mr chairman committee members so I'm
Aubry Friedman Bridgewater oh yeah no no
you had it the right person I mean your
name is right your name is oh Aubry
Friedman uh Bridgewater private citizen
I totally support this bill
um all the most of the things I've
already been mentioned the disruptions
um the errors no liability apparently
for these kinds of things going on is
unbelievable I mean these things may be
carried for the rest of the kids life
but anyway I just have two things I
could add to the conversation so I'm in
sau4 and I go to the school board
meetings and the topic of vaccine
clinics came up a few months ago of
course I was there uh speaking against
them but what was interesting
um the big discussion is should we have
separate uh covet versus flu should we
do it on the same days or different arms
or all that kind of up of course they
voted for the vaccine Clements but what
the interesting thing was what was the
reason that they ended up doing it we've
been doing it for years now that's a
really good reason for doing something
just because you've always done it in
the past let's not put any thought into
maybe something should be done
differently so we talk about local
control believe me they can be
tyrannical too so the other thing I
wanted to just talk about for a second
was convenience kids are inconvenient I
raised a child I did it a single parent
and I didn't you know you you took your
kid to the doctor
there are certain things you do as a
parent that's your responsibility what
kind of parent would just drop their
kids off at a doctor to get shots
because this is basically what people
are wanting to do is just you know it's
convenient
um I mean even your dog you you take
your dog to the vet that forever the
shots you don't just drop them off so
this whole point of convenience is to me
disgusting I mean there's the pharmacies
it can be done after school or any of
that kind of stuff so this is really
shirking parents responsibilities making
excuses for it it's inexcusable so I
support this bill let kid let schools be
schools anymore they're not medical
centers they're not hospitals and they
weren't meant to be thank you
thank you any question uh further
questions from the committee scene none
thank you very much for your testimony
hello Kathy Holmes Chai Chester I bet
I'll be the quickest one
I just say Amen to what Jim colpalt said
but the extra thing I want to put in is
you know schools don't sing Christmas
songs anymore because they're afraid of
being sued
and so what are you even talking about
this uh liability I'm also speaking for
the check that the taxpayers all over
the state I do not want my town to be
paying millions of dollars in lawsuits
and you can protect every town
okay
that's it thank you very much
questions see none thank you very much
Joseph
Keen
I
definitely on his left so uh how about
hello thank you Mr Vice chair and thank
you members of the committee my name is
Louise Spencer I'm from Concord New
Hampshire and I'm with the Kent Street
Coalition on all volunteer Grassroots
advocacy organization and I'm here to
speak in opposition to this bill
um it seems to me that this is
unnecessarily prescriptive and
restrictive and that we really need all
our tools in the tool kit available to
respond to evolving Public Health needs
um
we can have local school boards look at
this and decide if they're going to do
it in their communities at a given time
but to put a blanket ban on it seems way
too heavy-handed given the health issues
we have
arising over time
the schools have a vested interest in
this and that if if there are epidemics
of flu or other illnesses you lose lots
of
school hours whether it's teachers or
six students that is very disruptive to
the school day and to school learning
we do need checks and balances for sure
and there should be legal remedies
available when things go wrong and
foreign consent is essential but perhaps
we could give parents the opt out
um you know advance notice this is going
to be happening and that they can keep
their kids home as an excused absence
for that period of time there have a lot
who've talked about convenience but
um that's not really fair maybe for some
it's a matter of convenience but there
are many reasons that it may be
difficult for a parent to get their
child to the doctor
disabled parents are one example that
comes to mind so I hear the timer
what's up thank you very much
um representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
verify I'm not sure if you use the
um the word you meant to say were you
suggesting that we should perhaps go to
um an opt out system instead of
affirmative
um informed consent not for informed
consent no of course it has to be
written informed consent what I'm
suggesting is if there's concern about
having a child at school when there's a
vaccination clinic that that would be a
time a parent could say I'm going to
keep my child home without penalty thank
you yeah
you know informed consent is essential
thank you very much
thank you
good evening now
my name is Anne Murray Banfield I'm a
parental rights Advocate focused on
academic excellence and education for
all children in New Hampshire
as you have heard we have two incidents
where children in Rochester and
Nashville were given the flu shot
against their parents wishes I was
immediately contacted by the parent in
Rochester after this happened
in the case of the Rochester child she
was a young child kindergarten
and she was also sick at the time and
you're not supposed to get the flu
vaccine when you're sick and guess what
she got the flu vaccine even though her
parents said no and was sick
she even wrote on the page do not
vaccinate my child
so this bill is very simple it will
eliminate the possibility of mistakes in
the future
offering these clinics during school
hours caused these errors to occur the
parents thought that they could trust
that if they did not consent that that
would be that that would be followed now
parents are saying to keep their
children home if they do not want their
child vaccinated so they lose lose a day
of Education in in the case in Vermont
they pulled their kid out of the school
this continues expect enrollments to
continue to decline
so another last day to receiving an
education because this news has spreads
appearance across the state so expect
more to keep their their kids home
um this is more added to the day and I
think earlier testimony said that we're
spreading these schools so thin that at
what point do we go back to teaching and
learning
um I am not for and I am not against
vaccines so the the implication that
this is anti-vaccine is not true I'm for
parents making this decision I'm for
parents accompanying their children if
they are to receive a vaccine these are
reasonable requirements to expect from
our local public schools and those
administering vaccines they have an
opportunity to provide the service on
um I can tell you I normally don't talk
about personal things but I can tell you
if I was that child in Rochester I'd
have been traumatized because I hated
needles and I would have screamed and
cried and everything else if I was that
child I passed out in a dentist chair
when they gave me novocaine I passed out
when I was 12 years old getting my ears
pierced in the mall
I would have been traumatized I would
never have wanted to go back to that
school again if they would have given me
a vaccine in school
so I and I suspect that many children
are like that probably not all I mean my
kids have had vaccines in the past
uh if the professionals test with this
assignment cannot complete it without
making mistakes then it needs to stop we
have evidence that mistakes are going to
happen let's put some parameters so
those mistakes never happen again any
child could get a vaccine in this state
any child any day anywhere you go to CVS
Rite Aid anywhere this is not
anti-vaccine and it's not a way to stop
it
just asking for parameters thank you
thank you any questions for Miss
Banfield
seeing none thank you very much
Laura
yes
good afternoon thank you you're all
champions for staying here all afternoon
um and we appreciate it my name is Laura
Condon from Bedford I'm a volunteer New
Hampshire director of advocacy with the
national vaccine information center and
I'm here to testify in support of House
Bill 539
um May I remind you as others have said
that vaccination is a medical procedure
it is an elective medical procedure they
are not candy vaccines carry risk
schools are for educating not for
performing medical procedures
we should there was also a question
about uh liability here and I would pose
a question what is the liability of a
school district for injury or death to a
child the result of a school Clinic
school districts have no immunity for
protection of the 1986 National
childhood vaccine injury act for hosting
these vaccine clinics the nurses that
administer the vaccine have immunity
from liability the manufacturers do the
clinic themselves the school district
does not they've got there's a ripe
opportunity here for a lawsuit I know
there was talk about the covered shot
everyone has immunity from liability
under the prep rack for the covert shots
even volunteers which a school is
they're they're volunteer hosts for
these clinics but they are not immunity
from liability for the flu shots which
we've heard from DHHS and and those are
the shots that are actually being given
in fact I will share with you I have
handouts here of two children who have
died as a result of flu shots one was
seven-year-old Kalyn Matton from Vermont
and that's all she got was a flu shot
and the other one was a two-year-old New
Hampshire girl who died in December here
um and she had gotten a flu shot in a
covered shot these were not school
clinics but I just want to make you
aware that the risk of death is there
um schools are for teaching and um
there's plenty of access these days
um to vaccines it used to be that the
school-based clinics were necessary but
it was really become an Antiquated
program because now parents have access
to vaccines everywhere including Corner
Drug service grocery stores doctors of
all kinds hospitals urgent care
facilities even Public Health offices
and clinics there's simply no longer a
need for schools to host vaccination
clinics and schools during school hours
and to track from the essential purpose
of schools and that's to educate our
children
um
these days there's over 20 different
vaccines that can be administered to
Children although we've heard they're
they're only doing the flu and then
covered shots
um let's say I'm going to skip through
some notes here because I know my three
minutes
um
it's um and I've had parents come to me
who said um that they're they're
withdrawing their children from the
public school system one of the top
concerns are these vaccine clinics
um and they're looking to homeschool
their to send their children to other
schools I'd be happy to take any
questions I'm sorry it sounds like my
timer's gone off thank you questions
seen none thank you very much for being
here and for you sticking in also
Allison Dwyer
Dyer
um you can take yari's card out of there
as rep Cole fault stated she had to
leave but she did ask that I read her
testimony so I'll just submit mine to my
testimony to you but I'll read Yaris
good afternoon my name is Yari Perez I
am a single mother from Nashua New
Hampshire I'm here today to ask that you
support HB 539 a bill that would
prohibit conducting vaccination clinics
during school hours my seven-year-old
daughter was given the flu vaccine
without my consent at her Nashua
Elementary School one of these mobile
vaccine clinics my seven-year-old
daughter was traumatized she was brought
into a room her arm was held down she
cried she screamed and she was
administered a dose of the flu vaccine
through a needle that was never
consented to
she came home that day presented me with
the Nashua DHHS vaccine card she did the
best job a seven-year-old could in
explaining all that happened that
morning I checked her bag there was no
fact sheet and no adverse reaction sheet
sent with this vaccination card I
comforted her as best I could and in my
panic I reviewed all my paperwork and
emails to see if I could have possibly
or accidentally consented to this in my
review of my emails and my papers I did
not sign the vaccine consent form so
this had been the worst kind of error
not only did I not understand how this
could have possibly happened but my
daughter did not understand how I could
have allowed this why I would do this to
her without giving her a heads up and
why I wasn't there to go through this
scary moment with her
no mother should have to care for this
avoidable incident after the fact
since this has happened my daughter has
been fearful to be called anywhere in
the school the intercom announcements
give her anxiety and she has been sick
off and on since receiving the flu shot
I am unsure since she'd never received
this vaccine prior to this incident at
school if the two could potentially be
related
I did not know how to address this
atrocity and I'm thankful for my friend
and lifelong National resident Allison
dyer for aiding me and bringing this to
light had she not alerted everyone from
the school to the state I do not believe
they would have taken this issue
seriously I fall into a category the
opponents of this bill claim to care
about I am a single Latina mother who
has struggled to provide all I can for
my daughter since the death of her
father but I am not incapable of making
appointments for my own child whether
that be at a pharmacy or at her
pediatrician's office for regular well
visits or necessary vaccinations
but when this issue was brought to the
attention of the national DHHS they
refused to answer my friend Allison and
contact for my contact information she's
a polarized figure in my community due
to her outspoken and advocacy for the
children of my city
to quote directly from the DHHS director
I will not respond to miss Dyer because
my friend Allison had emailed on my
behalf about this incident and I had
asked that anyone wanting to speak with
me directly about my daughter respond to
Allison and she would provide that
information this is not how public
appointed and taxpayer paid and funded
entities should deal with our children
and families I've seen what's happened
to persons who speak out in Nashua this
should have never happened and we need
to make sure like something something
are there any questions for uh
uh either uh Miss Perez or Miss Dyer
um see none thank you very much and if
you could leave both testimonies that
would be great you can just leave them
up front
Therese Grinnell I think she left
yep
thank you chairman um and thank you all
for staying so late I will try and keep
my comments brief and um not repeat
things my name is Heather Raymond I am a
state representative who represents
Hillsboro District Five uh Nashua and in
fact
um The District in which
um this incident occurred that we just
heard about
um I like I said I don't want to repeat
anything I'm here to oppose this bill
Nashua as many of you know is the second
largest school district in New Hampshire
the public health office administers
over a thousand vaccines each year and
has done so for about 12 years in our 18
schools in that time there was one
circumstance this year where a form was
returned to the school
and the person who provided the vaccine
didn't carefully check it over to to
make sure that it wasn't just completed
but also signed and then they
administered the vaccine the school
board took this very seriously I can
attest to that being a member of the
school board in a prior chair of the
school board down in Nashua we requested
that both public health and the
superintendent investigate the situation
and come up with a plan to make sure
that it doesn't happen again because we
felt that this was completely
unacceptable about 10 percent of our
students get vaccines every year and one
getting one without permission was not
okay it was not okay with anybody since
then Public Health has reviewed their
process they have offered additional
training to their staff and they have
revised it such that each staff member
giving a vaccine must look for the
signature not just glance to make sure
the rest of the form has been filled out
and check off that they have in fact
seen that signature before they are able
to administer any vaccines so
just as far as other information that I
think is helpful for the committee to
know regarding Nashua and vaccines in
general Nash was only done the flu
vaccine we don't do covert vaccines in
school that wasn't something that we
were interested in doing
the flu vaccine according to the CDC is
40 to 60 percent effective each year
some years it's a little bit more some
years it's a little bit less this
happens to be a high year
um 45 of the parents in or the students
in Nashua of our 10 000 students qualify
for free and reduced lunch this means
that their family lives at or below the
federal poverty level some of the
consequences of being at or below the
federal poverty level is that you don't
have access to some of the things that I
think people take for granted in this
state we have a number of schools where
students walk to school there isn't
Transportation because there are
Community Schools but we also have a
number of families that don't have
transportation so to say that we can do
clinics outside of school hours without
having an impact on our community is not
representative of the reality in Nashua
I'm happy to take questions thank you
very much are there any questions from
the committee
great thank you I'd like to call Betsy
Harrington
thank you for having me my name is Betsy
Harrington I'm from Deering New
Hampshire
if children receive vaccines they should
be doing it with a doctor or minimally
with a parent present having a vaccine
performed during school hours then
sending the child back to class is
inappropriate and probably pretty scary
for a child especially if the child is
having a reaction that they are too
embarrassed to share
it could become traumatizing to everyone
to see and experience
adverse reactions aren't that rare
anymore my own child had one when he was
three
he's 14 now
I'm so glad I was there I keep my
children home on vaccination days
they've each missed two days of school
this year to avoid any issues a large
number of parents did as I did and they
kept their kids home too
clinics should not create a situation
where students are missing days of
school in response
the current covid vaccines have warnings
now regarding young men and heart
related injuries that's part of our
student population we shouldn't
participate due to possible medical
emergencies schools are not equipped to
treat the reaction and we can't afford
to be liable kids should be with parents
when they decide a vaccine is right for
their child schools are not medical
clinics and shouldn't be we don't do a
good job my district SAU 34 has given a
flu shot to a child in error I know you
guys have never heard of it but I have
us moms talked a lot about it happened
about two years ago this past year there
was a child given a covid test because
they did like group testing and that
child was not supposed to be tested and
was tested against their will even after
they said they weren't supposed to be
tested and they were told no your mom
said so wasn't true
so there are legitimate mistakes
happening in SAU 34
cobit vaccines have been given twice at
SAU 34. I felt so strongly I stood on
the corner with a sign and that's the
first time I'd ever protested anything
or even started to come to these kinds
of things you know to speak that was the
beginning for me because I just felt so
strongly that I just didn't want any
other moms to make the mistake and of
course I got a few fingers as parents
were driving into the school I stood
right at the entrance and uh but most of
them even the bus drivers gave me thumbs
up and said that they agreed so I was
actually surprised at the support I
received even though I did stand there
alone on that corner uh the day before
in the morning of the vaccination clinic
the first one
I'm going to end this by remembering
officer Rory Bohannon he was SAU 34
resource officer who died suddenly and
unexpectedly at the lunchroom door at
school my own reality has compelled me
to come and beg for this potentially
deadly practice of school-based vaccine
clinics to end
no questions from the committee
good afternoon good afternoon thank you
for having me
I'm Larissa Traxler of Stoddard New
Hampshire and I'm here in support of
House Bill 539
as a registered nurse I take as a
registered nurse since 1995 I should say
I take great issue with the lack of
safety in these vaccination clinics in
the school setting
proper medical safety procedures proper
identification and informed consent are
severely compromised I have reviewed
several of the New Hampshire incidents
within the last year in which safety
procedures and protocols were not being
followed
as a pediatric nurse I have also been
present for adverse reactions that would
be quite challenging to manage in a
as a mom
these vaccination clinics in school this
is one of the many factors why I cannot
send my children to public school
two of my children at the time were age
6 and 14 were put in a line for
vaccination in school despite a very
clear declination
we handle matters of this nature with
our trusted providers
not at school
vaccination clinics are inherently not
foolproof and have no place in the
school setting
children are there to learn
I just ask that you please support House
Bill 539 ought to pass
and I'd rather not take questions thank
you
hi everyone thank you for being here
today
um
so much of what I wrote has already been
stated but I did want to you know just
reiterate liability liability liability
um and vaccine injury is real it doesn't
always happen with seizures or something
that's immediate there's other things
excuse me like lupus that can come weeks
later or months later we have to be very
cautious when we're injecting things
into our children or ourselves and
I want to go back to hb505 and this one
why do we need
schools to be medical facilities let's
let them be schools we really do need to
ensure the separation of um
medicine in school and education
um
I guess that's it
um I'm from Peterborough I don't know if
I said that part yes you did thank you
any questions any questions thank you
very much thank you
well thank you for the invitation yeah
you're welcome everyone else you just
called up I get an invitation thank you
for hearing me thank you for all you
doing for staying so late to hear this
um I am a supporter of
hb359 I am not anti-vaxx I've been
vaccinated my children have been
vaccinated my grandchildren vaccinated
not at schools
I know you guys must be overwhelmed
hearing the tens of thousands of
children's but parents might have three
or four children to them that to those
parents those children are more precious
than you can imagine although on some of
your parents I'm sure what is more
precious to which apparent than his
child
and can you imagine sending your child
to school thinking You've Done Right
Said No No vaccine uh she can't get the
flu shot the doctors told me she can't
and then find out that it has happened
would it make you feel any better
have to listen to some of the people say
well we're trying to do better we're
going to improve does it really make any
of you feel any better hearing a
bureaucrat say they're going to do
better and we hope it doesn't happen
again it only happened because they
happen to have the same first name maybe
so I can understand
I can't imagine that
parents parents not I don't want to say
they own the children but they are so
attached their whole life our whole life
were attached to our children
so parents have the Supreme
the Supreme rule of what happens to
their children and no parent should have
to wonder what's the school going to do
to my kid today ever
and probably the most egregious reason
I've heard to put children through this
is so that some bureaucrat can check off
a box on the on the federal preparedness
form come on I want you to ask the
people and who in Louisiana what they
think about federal health and federal
bureaucrats checking off forms and
helping them
give this back to the parents it's not
going it might be inconvenient to people
but you just think about it come on they
can't do it every Rite Aid every CVS
every Pharmacy
gives out free vaccines
schools don't need to do it thank you
very much
thank you very much with that I don't
have any other uh cards up here to speak
on yes
oh okay I wasn't here for the book come
on up
yes
thank you for allowing time Mr chair the
rest of the committee thank you so much
I'd like to also thank representative
Koval for bringing forth this a very
important legislation
um I think it needs to be a New
Hampshire law or statute because I don't
want to leave decisions like vaccination
to my local school board I don't want
that can you please introduce your name
please I'm sorry Gary York I'm sorry I'm
MD Hopkinton New Hampshire okay yep
thank you
um again uh you you've heard repetitive
testimony throughout the day and
this bill is about the value of informed
consent and obtaining that consent not
from children but from parents where it
belongs by proxy this is their duty this
is a parental rights Bill and in many
respects
it's also a medical Freedom bill for
keeping children and away from being
vaccinated again through a parental
decision which is what we all want to
keep and hold dear in our hearts
um and then uh someone uh many have
spoke again about the separation of
medicine versus education I think that's
very important this is a medical issue
this is keep the education to the school
keep the medical information and
that's not a good deal of my career as a
medical director and a laboratory in a
New Hampshire hospital where there is a
hourly daily round-the-clock 365 days of
the year attention to Quality Control
quality assurance
quality improvement that was our job
and I was responsible for anything that
went wrong in the in the laboratory
setting so
um we've heard about these never events
uh this won't happen again
uh in the hospital setting they were
sugar coated and called a medical
Misadventures how do you like that
yeah
some of these Misadventures are way out
of whack
my concern is uh the concept of a
vaccine van coming to a school system
and what what is the quality control who
is giving vaccines who is identifying
the patient
let's say it's a six-year-old or an
eight-year-old how do you get patient
identification verified they don't have
a wallet or an ID card or anything
they've got a slip that maybe has their
parents signature on it but my real
concern is like who is in who are what
are the what are the things that can go
wrong in a scenario where you've got a
mobile vaccine clinic fan circulating
thank you any questions any questions
from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much
for the committee what we're going to do
is just go the last two bills opening up
recess open the other recess and then
with that when we'll get a time to be
announced most likely these bills will
be carried over for
um the 13th and I'll explain what we're
going to be doing then
so
um
uh we need a rep just to go forward and
recommend or not recommend
tell me yes one of these bills I'm
representative Gerhart one of these
bills is actually mine yeah it was my
intention just to have this bill go away
so if we wanted to introduce it don't
take any questions we're gone
well what we're going to do is we're
just going to introduce it and if you
just introduce it we can continue the
hearing at a time to be announced but
most likely on February the 13th
uh and then
um if there's anybody who wants to
testify another because I did announce
earlier today that we would not be
addressing these bills today
the last two bills so
that means we have to have another date
set up so that there's somebody that's
out there that's this is all been
streamed all right so we'd have to so
but you can introduce the bill and then
we will you know go from there and and
just introduce it by title and all that
you don't have to say anything other
than that yeah I'm playing on okay let's
let's do it yeah please thank you oh
you're gonna go ahead please all right
some representative Jason Gerhard saying
Northfield Franklin
House Bill 634 relative to students
participation in religious instruction
to satisfy elective curriculum
requirements
and I'm not going to take any questions
thank you thank you very much and with
that we are going to recess this bill to
a time to be determined and it will be
time wise somewhere on the 13th
um
okay so we're going to close that
particular hearing
and move on to the next one
which would be
um 634
that was 634 excuse me
okay we jumped over 552. I'm okay so I I
need to have somebody just walk over
there and do the same thing for 550 so
representative do you want to do okay we
have to go home all right so my name's
Jason Gerhard introducing Bill 532 550
by 552 even better and I will not take
any questions thank you very much and
with that
with that we are going to recess this
bill to the same time uh to be announced
uh most likely on the
um February the 13th she would be on
February the 13th
so with that I'm going to close that
hearing as well now for the committee
what what's going to happen the early
bills which we had we're going to
discuss uh our take action on on the
13th do the fact that we went right
through a very short break we were
supposed to have a work session not a
work session but we were going to have a
meeting here to try a four people here
to try and get some of the nuts and
bolts on on 529 we couldn't do that that
will be done uh on the 13th so we're
going to take all those early bills and
take them to the 15th on the 13th there
will simply only be hearings
and so if somebody has to do something
on that date and can't make it down here
know that we will just be taking
testimony no action will be taken on the
13th so that's something you may use if
you have to
wait you could come late you could sleep
in to seven o'clock and and and uh or or
sleep into three o'clock in the
afternoon it's it's up to you uh for
those that have kids to get to school or
it's it that didn't work like that
either so that's just some information
for where we're going to go and and so I
really appreciate the time you all spent
today and and and sitting here through
some of these very very long bills
um welcome to education
foreign
bills which we have not
done
and and then there will be probably so
we don't waste time there will be a
whole slug of bills put on there that
we've had hearings on we'll pick and
choose from those bills try to wipe some
of them out we won't obviously get them
all and then uh
that will be put in the account
um
yeah well the fifth I mentioned the 15th
through the fact that we've got the
early bills which we have to and I don't
care to do early bills on the 16th the
day we have to unload those too
to the the speaker and that has to be
done by noon on the 16th it sort of
gives us that we've had to use that
morning once or twice before in the past
when we just couldn't resolve something
on the 15th but it meant the real hustle
job on the 16th we may be here on that
16th I gotta look at the calendar
um and if that that's going to have to
be in the calendar
so um
I'll work on that tonight
okay we also had an invite to Delta
Dental tonight some people I don't know
if you're going over there or not uh
represent leckis was looking for a ride